we have a lot of hearings today
we're going to start off with the
senate bill 239
if
if you're going to introduce the bill
senator guida
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record bob guy to
senate
senate district 2 and prime sponsor
senate bill 239
this is a bill that
grew out of
the seemingly never-ending saga of
woodsville and haverhill which are in my
district and it's been going on for
this bill's genesis was the fact that
the precinct of woodsville
despite
ordinance
requiring an audit annually
had literally never done a financial
audit
despite 10 years of written telephonic
and electronic communications from dri
dra
requesting an audit
the problem is the dra had no teeth
all right and so
uh what this bill does
because i'm certain that there are other
political subdivisions out there that
what this bill does is to establish a
requirement
and then to
put in a process for remediation of a
delinquent
political subdivision
i worked closely with dra to establish
this
and just to take you through the
provisos we worked very hard to give the
political subdivision every opportunity
god bless you every opportunity to
remedy the problem there are oversights
some very small precincts or very small
towns or whatever might have overlooked
so
dra
would be required to give notice
to the community or to the political
subdivision
right
and
in the absence of an audit
the community would have a period of
time to respond
and
there would be a penalty assessed 250 up
to 250 a day
now for some towns that's a lot for some
some cities that may not be so much but
it's certainly going to raise eyebrows
and ask questions the purpose of this is
to require municipal officials to comply
with the audit requirement it's been in
law for years back in
2011-12
they stripped all the auditors out of a
dra so they don't have the ability to go
audit themselves we still haven't
restored those positions
but this puts into law the fact that if
you're a political subdivision you have
the ability to tax you have the ability
to spend
you certainly have the obligation to
report on a regular basis per the laws
that every other political subdivision
in the state is following and so that's
the purpose behind the bill i'm happy to
answer any details uh questions from the
members of the committee any questions
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question so upon um
examining the statutes
um in this section that the bill
pertains to one of the things that i
noted is that in section one roman
numeral no
number one of the bill
um
lines five and six the the term
political subdivision is referenced
however um in section two of the bill
it specifies
citytown school district or village
district or precinct
so
i guess my
my concern is is do we need to define
political subdivision because i didn't
see a definition
and i know that in some some bills like
for example there's senate bill 259 of
this year where political subdivision
was specifically defined
as it pertained to that bill
so um could you just clarify that for me
to make sure that there's no oversights
i would have no objection to an
amendment
into specifying the specific little
subdivisions up on uh
um
in section roman four i think it was as
as defined down below
um
so again i think that's a technicality
there's certainly no intent to make any
differentiation
perhaps i know if dra has someone here
apparently not but i would have no
objection to refining that definition
and resolving the disparity that you
yes representative maturi
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question it might be
piggybacking
um it might be piggybacking on the same
question does political subdivisions
include library trustees
i don't think it does because i don't
know that i'm not certain but i don't
think it does okay
thank you
representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question senator i have a
uh some part of a hang up when you when
they delivering the fine you say fine it
says fine
of up to 250 per day that could be
anything up to 250
and it's written like it's discretionary
it could be fifty dollars a day to one
place and a hundred dollars was there
any reason why you weren't more specific
and said
it was two hundred and fifty dollars a
day instead of up to
that was i think the request of the of
the commissioner and the dra it gives
them latitude
uh you know a minor infraction uh or an
oversight as opposed to a willful
disregard of the law just to give them
some latitude to apply their judgment
because ultimately the ones who they are
the ones who will make that adjudication
i understand that i'm just uh stating
and i'm kind of conferring concern what
it says up to because
you know could be all over the place and
uh
and nobody there's no oversight there so
i just
raised the question why it wasn't more
specific thank you senator thank you
thank you mr chairman
yes sir
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
uh when you introduced this bill you
mentioned that i believe woodsville was
violating an ordinance by not performing
an audit is that
state statute it's state statute so
in practice this bill would just provide
a fine some kind of a consequence
there's no consequence now for violating
statute no consequence in the way of
enforcement if there was one this gives
additional questions
for the senator
yes representative service
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
in all of the years of non-compliance
by the town of woodsville
uh with with this statute has there been
any communication from woodsville to dra
as to why the audits are not being
performed
subject to
legislation that i introduced last year
it required forced by law
okay a statute that we passed
to not a statute a bill that we passed
to
uh have a an audit done and the results
of those are that audit
independent audit by you know one of the
one of the municipal auditing firms be
returned over to dra we had to pass
a law
to require the precinct of woodsville
to do what was otherwise prescribed in
law because there was no other way to
yes
up
thank you um senator but i don't think
the question was answered
has there been any communication from
woodsville
to the dra or to you or any other
concerned parties as to why the audits
yes voluminous communications once we
put the law through
and then woodsville opened up there was
look
they're still
the results of the audit were not very
complimentary let's start with that just
leave it at that and and so there are
those that might assert there were
intentions there
um but
there is still ongoing both litigation
between woodsville and haverhill and to
answer your question yes
but the communications was only once we
passed the law and put teeth into it
that required them to to do this
audit
which has turned up irregularities so
um woodsville basically ignored the dra
for 10 years
and i really wish someone from d.r.a was
here to testify to this but you can call
the commissioner any time commissioner
stepp and and she'll be certain to
verify or james gary who handles the
municipal over there
his words not mine it was the worst
example of municipal accounting he's
seen in 30 years
there were years worth of checks and
back rooms and all kinds of stuff so
again the reason for an audit is to
ensure that this political subdivision
okay is not playing fast and loose with
the taxpayer authority the tax authority
that they have and the funds that they
raise
so there was really not much no no
communications up until the point that
the law we passed last year two years
ago now
was put in place to force the audit and
then at that point of course they saw
where this was going
yes representative
uh thank you senator i have a question
would you mind if i sat down before sure
thank you i don't want to walk in front
of you or the
person testifying without permission
um
obviously there are other towns and
municipalities and and political
subdivisions that
are in violation of this
um
i know
of one instance
of a school
in particular
where sometimes six months eight months
you would never see
uh
any any audit posted
have you seen or heard of any other
situations for a long length of time
other than the two that you mentioned
there are
again remember we're talking about fire
precincts water districts anyone has the
ability to tax
right or to raise revenue
under the guise of a public service or
as a public entity should be required to
be accountable for the the receipt and
dispensing of those funds appropriately
um
and if they're not there's really no
remedy for a citizen other than to try
to take a town to court
right we do have standing now based on
the law we passed what four or five
years ago
but you know communities and precincts
you take an oath to support and defend
the constitution the laws of the state
of new hampshire so help you god
and there are precincts and water
districts and other political
subdivisions or whatever category you
might want to say they're out there and
i don't say that they're doing anything
criminal i'm not saying that they're
willingly they may not be aware
okay but this also provides
gives a proviso
that dra will notify right
all governing bodies of all
municipalities political subdivisions
and counties subject to this statute
within 60 days the effective date
so it also makes absolutely sure that
every one of these entities that's out
there knows hey you need to do this
audit and there's a penalty coming
albeit we're pretty lenient and allowing
you latitude
i mean you can either do the audit or
within 90 days present a contract that
you've had it contracted to be done by a
you know an auto municipal auditing firm
so
unfortunately
uh you know you have to do the stick and
carrot
right and so
we do need a stick and this would
provide the stick for those communities
or political subdivisions entities that
are recalcitrant in complying with the
audit requirements of the law thank you
senator isn't it
with reference to a question we had
earlier isn't it true that libraries
which would be would come under the
category of the municipal government and
therefore the audit would include them
as well
i would think it would include the
library as a component of municipal
government whether or not it actually
audits the library itself that i'm not
certain
thank you
yes
thank you senator for taking my question
uh to follow up on the earlier questions
concerning
defining the political subdivision i
want to make sure that trust funds are
included in that
because trust funds
are seem separate from
at least in our community
from the town itself
so are you may i ask a question mr chair
yes are you asking
if the community has a trust fund
or
you know private sector trust fund no
this is the town trust fund that would
i'm sure be be carried categorized as an
asset to the town yes and therefore if
it's listed on the
the ms form
then i'm quite certain that it would be
subject to review and if any
irregularities were found
if you're not comfortable i'm very
comfortable with you adding a proviso
that would say maybe specifically
stipulate municipal trust funds to be
audited
maybe separately but i don't see them as
a separate component as long as they're
incorporated within the town's
governance
any other questions
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my um
in section
2 line 20
it as well as
line 30.
the language in the bill lists
municipality political subdivision or
county
my interpretation of that is that this
bill would pertain to
the county level as well
as far as audits are concerned
is that a correct interpretation that is
thank you again he's got taxing
authority dispense lots of funds to make
sure they're in compliance you know with
gaap and the other the other accounting
principles
representative davis did you have an
additional question
i i'm sure this is in the bill somewhere
and i'm just not seeing it but is this
an annual requirement i think it is an
annual audit requirement say that in the
bill correct
it says that in the bill it does not but
it's already an existing statute yeah
thank you
seeing none i think
thank you senator i appreciate your your
attendance and your uh testimony thank
you chairman dolan members of the
committee
so we're going to stand in recess until
wanted to speak to this this bill
when i asked if there's any additional
speakers or whatever just
get my attention like this
thank you good morning
representative dolan and members of the
committee it's nice to be back i haven't
seen you in a while so nhma is here to
oppose the bill in part
we are not in opposition to performing
an audit and following the statutory
compliance recommendations and
requirements and rsa
21 j 19 and 20.
it's also best practice of course to
perform the municipal audit and do it in
a timely manner to make sure there's no
weakness and deficiency however we
oppose any penalties being levied
against municipalities as in many cases
that could be a heavy lift for some of
our communities especially the smaller
ones we do understand that
the dra would give proper notice a
90-day notice to levy such a fine
however we do think that
in most cases our municipalities are
willing to be compliant and follow the
rules as long as they
have ample warning and understanding
of what the new law would entail
so we do want to explain that the annual
financial audit should be part and is
required to be part of the annual
financial reporting process and is
required to be placed in a town's annual
report the audit would contain other
accounts such as libraries trustees of
trust funds and other government
activities in order to assess the true
and accurate financial position of a
community so that should be required in
an audit and that would be performed
especially by the outside auditing firms
they would of course be providing that
information to a town so libraries and
trustees would be part of that process
so i did want to clarify that as that
was asked
so the other reason why
towns
should be performing their audit and
want to be performing an audit is
because bonding requires an audit and
audited financials going back a number
of years as do tan and band notes and in
the
situation where a town might require a
tax anticipation note or a bond
anticipation no the bond bank would be
requiring those statements so it's
always in the town's best interest to be
performing their annual audit and
uploading it to dra would just be one
more step that we certainly have no
opposition to in that process so i can
take any questions that you might have
any questions for nhma yes
representative mcdonald
what do you suggest we have to do to get
what do you uh suggest
that we do to get to town to comply with
doing the audit other than find them
in that particular situation it sounds
like the dra has been
in contact with that town
i can't speak to why that's happening in
that community i do hope that it is
one of the rare exceptions certainly we
know most of our towns if not all are
performing regular audits i know
auditors
it talks about having a year and there's
a reason for that is because we only
have a certain amount of auditing firms
and audits are scheduled as timely as
possible so
auditors you know do have to go through
each town and do their tests and go in
and look at the books many times
physically certainly having a great
number of detailed reports and documents
provided to them but i can't speak to
what should be done for this particular
um community and i'm not familiar
intimately with that situation thank you
mr president
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question just a clarification so you
think
the current
statute that exists
is
uh pretty detailed or required
and this is
this bill will make it more punitive
for
if one any of the communities
does not comply with what's existing am
i correct in understanding you are
correct so um
are any other
sorry follow up mr chair yes go ahead
please um
are there any other statues or
bills that
have shown that going to the punitive
aspect of it
will not will either increase or
decrease the compliance
so i can speak to that anecdotally that
we have been assured
for the new hampshire retirement system
or the dra that these fines are very
rarely if ever levied against
municipalities so that's really
reassuring to know that they don't often
have to take that action so in my
professional opinion that would mean if
they're very rarely the ones that exist
in statute now
levied that it probably is not
thank you
see no further questions thank you thank
you very much thank you
okay
as i
uh was headed before we're going to take
a recess for five minutes
hey
tony thank you yes i'm going to turn my
stuff in after each hearing if it's okay
um
okay uh
let's check and see if
it goes okay
make the determination towards the end
okay
uh
um
okay
uh not yet
let's see the next one is 245
okay
245.
we don't have any
this is the municipal and county
government uh
committee and
our next hearing
is going to be on senate bill 245
and uh
we have senator sherman here if you like
to open the open the session for us
welcome
thank you mr chair
for the record my name is senator tom
sherman district 24
11 towns on the seacoast
and i am introducing sb 245 which is
establishing a committee to study
agreements between developers and
municipalities on municipal trash
removal fees paid by condominium owners
and renters
this was brought to my attention uh with
a request to
fix the problem um
in
a practice that was occurring in one of
my towns
i've come to understand that it happens
intermittently across the state
and what this bill would do would be to
establish a committee to study
agreements between developers of
condominium units and municipalities
regarding municipal trash removal fees
in many circumstances unit owners
have to pay for private trash pickup
while at the same time that service is
included in their property taxes
so they're basically paying for a
service that they're not getting
and the goal of the study committee
would be to examine the agreements and
determine
why fees are paid for services not
rendered and whether that's appropriate
i thought about putting in a bill that
just didn't allow this to happen but as
we all have learned over time
things that seem pretty simple
are actually very complicated and
that's why we came up with the study
committee to answer my constituents
concern i'm happy to take any questions
yes representative gallagher
so
this seems relevant to one of my own
bills
i had a bill
to
require public housing
provide
to
provide for
compost and recycling services to
tenants who live in their public housing
and that got referred to interim study
for one of the
reasons where well how's it going to be
funded and
what what are the municipalities
supposed to do
with this once they pick it up so
would
this study committee help
to answer questions like that at all
the
committee the duties in line 11 through
13 either the committee shall examine
issues regarding agreements with
developers and municipalities i would
assume those developers could be
developers of any kind of housing
the result of which that
condominium owners and renters are
paying municipal fees to cover trash
removal services without receiving the
benefit
this is the
same kind of agreement that we see
and this bill would not cover that with
things like private roads you know where
the inducements are that the
uh
are
a benefit to the developer but not a
benefit to the people who actually end
up living there for
the lifetime of that development
so
i it might be a stretch for the
committee to
branch out to that but i i don't think
it would be something that they
couldn't take up
yes for a follow-up well so yeah
follow-up um would you support an
amendment to the bill
to
um clear that up and make it a little
bit of a stretch say replacing the word
trash with waste so that way it's
broader and covers compost and recycling
as well absolutely sure okay thanks
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question so my question
has to do with um wording
of the bill lines two and three
it it specifies condo owners and renters
i'm assuming that the intention is
renters of the condos not just renters
in general like renters of apartments
right and i'd be open if you wanted to
make that more specific i'd be open to
wording change there but
as you know
the condos may be owned by
person x but person y is renting from
the condo owner
so the
the benefit of this would or or the
the committee would be looking at
basically the people living
in the complex
representative would you like to come
representative tripp
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh
since uh
you had
talked with people about this
it uh it seems that you might have
been given uh
examples of
how
the municipalities are requiring
additional fees to to remove trash
could could you share one of those
examples with us yes i believe the
constituent who brought this is here to
testify but
in one of my towns hampton actually
provides as
and it's not in my district but exeter
also provides municipal trash pickup
and so
all of the
owners of
certain condos in hampton
are currently paying municipal trash
haulage fees in as part of their
property taxes
representative tripp oh you are you done
with uh no follow-up uh
representative uh gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question uh since you
cited exeter and i represent exeter i'm
going to
ask this question i'm not sure if i'll
be clear but
our program is a pay-as-you-throw
program so
condominium owners and renters can
pay as you throw get a bag they have to
buy a bag just like everybody else
put on the curbside just like everybody
else
and they're not paying extra they're
paying what everyone else is paying to
remove the trash
thank you and just to clarify i know
exeter has municipal trash which is
was my point but i don't know of any
situations in exeter
that
would be similar to what's happened in
hampton so at the time the condo
development was put in place in hampton
there is an agreement between the
developer and the town
that
the condo association has to provide its
own trash pickup but they're still being
charged
the municipal rate uh so i i didn't mean
to malign exeter i love exeter i
practiced there for many years so um but
i know they do have a municipal system
um thank you for clarifying that yeah i
just
just followed representative manjuputi
a clarification uh mr chair i'm one of
the co-sponsors can i ask the question
yeah okay
okay thank you uh thank you senator for
taking my question and clarification for
me was that
processing that's a big important issue
in our state and across the country
uh at this time and especially
following covet where the trash has
increased
yeah and so
uh can you just
um
point out how this addresses a small
piece of that to kind of it's a
one piece of the puzzle that we are
trying to solve
yeah um
well i guess the only way i can
think that it really does address solid
waste management
is
many of the municipalities have
in fact hampton has worked really hard
on their solid waste disposal
and if they're
if all the condo associations which by
the way i doubt that's the case but all
the condo associations who have this
agreement between their development and
municipalities are doing separate solid
waste disposal outside of that system
there may not be the same level of
sophistication in that solid waste
disposal that's the only way i could
think that it might have some impact
thank you just to highlight the fact
that
we are trying to consolidate as a
municipal waste solid waste many of my
towns are really on that issue and doing
a great job with it
representative melvin
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for taking my question
uh
i'm kind of curious you're only doing
this for condo associations
correct
what about the businesses
what and and also what about uh plowing
in front of uh
on state roads that businesses they're
paying too they're paying for they're
also paying for the rubbish and this is
not included in this and why
uh the reason why it's not and thank you
for the question the reason why it's not
there you know as i mentioned private
roads have similar
agreements between the municipality and
the developer and and all of us i don't
know if you all are handling them here
but i'm on transportation in the senate
so we've had several private road bills
come through
so these are agreements that are put in
place i would have absolutely no problem
if the committee felt it was important
to expand this but the specific
problem that was brought to me by the
constituent was this one that's covered
i thought
as i looked into it i realized that
there were a lot of people impacted
including businesses
condo owners
the renters the municipalities
so finding the right answer is not
something that
or i didn't have the right answer and
i've found that committees are
a quick
but thorough way to figure out what is
the appropriate legislation
and i you know at one point i sat on 21
of them 21 committees commissions
council so i know it's a burden
but i also don't want to put in
legislation that's not thoroughly vetted
before it comes to
all of our attention so this was a very
specific issue raised by a constituent
and that's why i kept it as narrow as
possible so that if if the you know the
senate has passed this if you all see
fit to pass it
it will be i think a very narrow focus
for the committee and something that
they can easily get done
uh in a way that if i mean it may be
that we discovered that it's not
appropriate to pass any legislation um
so i don't know the answer and that's
well the way this bill is right now i
got to be honest with you i'd have to
vote against it just to let you know
that is your prerogative you know and
and i voted for it you can vote against
it that's the way we work
and and um
but that leaves us with constituents who
don't have an answer and i still think
this is better than filing bad
legislation i i think
this is the way in the legislature in my
experience after four terms here
this is the way
that we solve problems in the
legislature and make sure that the
legislation that's brought forward is
appropriate for the problem
but it's up to this committee and i'll
respect the decision of the committee
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
um the way the bill's written now it's
focusing on developers and
municipalities but would this also
include existing homeowner associations
um it certainly can it's a committee not
a commission so it's not meant to
exclude any voice um
it they
the committee
in my experience can call anybody they
want and it's a public forum so anybody
who has an interest in this
can come and speak and i pretty much
guarantee you my constituent who brought
the issue to me will be there
to testify in front of the committee if
if we move forward with it does that
answer your question uh
yeah yes it it does it's
it just when i see it's to look at
legislation
for agreements between developers and
municipalities
oftentimes the developers are long gone
and an hoa may enact
a policy for for trash pickup i know in
my community of merrimack
um
specifically there's one condo community
where they pay property tax but they
also pay have to pay
for pickup
private pickup but they're still they
always have the option of going to the
transfer station
to
maybe dispose of large items or
large metal recycling things like that
so um
it's not like they're they're not
prohibited from using the transfer
station but they
um but they do have to pay that fee for
pickup
so that that may be a component where
you know it
we don't have curbside pickup in
merrimack so
if we did that would then be
yeah i see so i think that i think the
committee is a good idea
i just think there may be a lot of
options in a lot of different situations
than just
that curbside pickup that's provided by
the municipality
and thank you you are beautifully
pointing out how complicated something
fairly simple can become and that's why
i didn't feel just filing legislation
to impact
this without having a committee to study
the issue
would be appropriate and and i also
think that uh as several people have
stated including representative melvin
what would come out of this committee
could be used as a model for other
similar
agreements between municipalities and
vendors or contractors
so that the playing field is level as
opposed to right now
in i'm not sure about merrimack but
certainly in some of my towns
and in hampton
people are paying for something they're
not getting
and it's simply because there was an
agreement at the time of the the
construction
so from then on everybody is paying for
something they're not getting and
rather than being
passing judgment myself i thought it
would be appropriate for the legislature
to look at the issue
and there are many other examples where
this happens in municipalities and
this could potentially be a template for
other issues
okay thank you very much
next we're going to go to
representatives davis then
representative tripp then representative
trello
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so i want to
ask you specifically about homeowners
associations
of which there is no
state law in new hampshire so how can
you possibly look at homeowners
associations
within the penumbra of state law if
there is no state law governing hoas
that's one question and another question
specifically goes to the issue of trash
collection of why
this particular issue there are lots of
things that condominium owners and
renters
and hoa owners and and renters pay for
that they
quote unquote do not receive
yet they are able to receive them if
they so wish to receive them so my quest
my specific question is
are the
owners or renters of this specific
condominium of which this
idea came to fruition
able to access public trash collection
if they so wish
no is the answer they are not but
they're paying for it
okay
so they have to do exactly what
representative wrong described
they are paying for public municipal
trash collection but they have to pay
separately to actually have their trash
collected
my presumption is that they could go
down
to the
transfer station and drop off their
trash
but their neighbors who live in a single
family home
next door
don't have to do that and everybody's
paying for it and just to answer your
question about why this was the issue
that was raised by my constituents so
that's
i was trying to address that issue i
homeowners associations you know
manufactured trailer parks there's all
sorts of groups
out there manufactured home
groups and we've seen those bills come
through as well but this is specifically
to answer the constituents concern that
was raised to me thank you
i thank you chair thank you for taking
like many people here i think we're all
struggling to understand what the
problem is
municipal trash pickup at no cost is
provided by hampton
is that correct
not to the condo owners
follow up
but it is provided
within the town yes but it's not at no
cost there's an actual fee that's
attached to your
municipal
can i have another follow-up so so so
it's actually not free then because
say the homeowner
has to
register or sign up for this trash
pickup and he has to pay or they i don't
assume people's gender uh
they have to pay
an additional fee to get pic pick up
on their tax bill
yes in the sense that they have to pay
that fee
everybody pays that fee every homeowner
every condo owner everybody pays that
fee it's the condo owners who do not
have
let me i i'm sorry if this does sound
complicated
yeah and that's why making any change
essentially what's happening
in this setting
is that the developer and the
municipality have come to an agreement
that allows the municipality to charge
that development
which is a condo in this case
a fee for a service they don't get
forever
i don't think i can i'm trying to be as
clear as i possibly can that's what this
is
and it is not simple it it seems like a
simple problem and and it is but when
you start looking into it it gets very
complicated very quickly which is why
uh i don't think it's necessarily right
for somebody to be charged for something
that they're not getting
but we do that and so the question is
whether this is right and i'm i don't
feel qualified to make that decision by
myself or file a bill based on that
without having a legislative study
committee
well thank you very much thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for coming to testify before us just to
be clear
i'm hearing people solving a problem
that or problems that your
bill is asking that we establish a
committee to study
these specific problems
and i see when i read the bill it's very
clear that we're going to we meaning
whoever is on the committee is going to
meet within 45 days what will constitute
a quorum and by november 1st
the committee shall report the findings
any recommendations
to the senate the clerk the governor and
the state library
is that correct
so all we're voting on right now you're
asking us is to create this committee
that's it let's do it thank you
any other further questions for the
senator
yes representative mitchell
it just came to me thank you mr chair
thank you senator for taking my question
i'm thinking in northampton we have
hydrant fees
not everybody has hydrant service but
your in your testimony it says the
question the committee the study
committee would tackle is should you be
paying for a service that you are not
receiving which we're hearing a lot here
but we are focused on trash for
condominiums i'm afraid of pandora's box
right no this is not opening pandora's
box okay because there are tons of
services that we understand
we pay for and and
but this one in particular was brought
to me by a constituent okay and
i felt
um that
it was complicated enough as we've
as we figured out together today
that it's not something that once one
state rep or one senator
should be filing bills on before it's
studied
where's oh there we are okay
thank you for taking my question sure
i lived in hampton and i was on the
trash committee oh good and everybody
could have trash pickup that wanted it
they got two cans one recycling and one
for trash
uh some people and some businesses
didn't want it some condo association
didn't want it because it'd have 40
trash cans in front of it
now
whatever deal they made
is fine but they can go to the town and
pick up two of those cans for free
anytime they want
thank you
i'm i don't know if you served with dave
hartnett or others but
the
constituent
brought this to me and i talked to the
town manager and in fact
some agreements were made between condo
developers and the town
and it's not just hampton this happens
in other municipalities but
where
those people in that condo association
have to contract out for their trash
pickup
so they don't have
i believe if they made a deal with them
what are you looking for tax break for
the condos
not necessarily i don't know exactly
that's why i put it in a committee was
to understand if we if we pass this bill
they get the 40 trash cans in front of
their building no if we pass this bill
we look at it and we see what is
one
is a solution needed
and
two what would be that solution
and three as we think through those
solutions
what would be the downstream impacts and
is that worth it
if
the study committee the study committee
may come back and say
this does not need any intervention
so no there's
this is just a study committee this is
not
the answer to the problem and the answer
may be that there is no answer or that
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question unfortunately i'm
still a little bit confused with regards
to um
these condo owners and condo renters
having to have to pay for a service that
they're not receiving so could you
clarify is
the payment of this trash pickup that
they're not receiving
is that a line item on their tax bill as
an add-on or
is it being
raised and appropriated through the
property taxes
and therefore it's just a fine item on
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question i'm trying to frame
my thought in the form of a question
um isn't that isn't it true that
uh
as different communities are facing some
have landfill
that can extend for next 50 years some
have
that no space in the landfill
and like you pointed out one community
came to you
and there are other communities in the
state that are facing with municipal
solid waste and how they deal how they
charge what it is isn't that one of the
reasons that this commission
uh approach was taken
um
well yes and no
this is a committee which in my mind is
the
if you've got
a very straightforward question which
it's getting less and less
straightforward but
if if you have a pretty straightforward
question like a very specific question
i've always found that a committee
rather than a commission moves
with alacrity
and can solve
direct questions and this
that's why i
went with a committee rather than a
commission which might be unwieldy and
as
representative said it could you know
that could go for years and and this i
don't think this question
i think this can be answered much more
quickly with a targeted committee but
that being said i think there will be
some benefit
towards our solid waste discussion
just a quick follow-up
yeah so i'm just trying to rephrase my
question and say
a committee with very specific focus and
a dead short timeline to answer a very
specific high-density dwelling
in communities and the trash
management thank you
thank you senator for lending your time
and your clarity in this bill and uh
i hope i've lended my clarity
i came in feeling pretty clear i'm
feeling a little muddy now
[Laughter]
our next speaker
and you're in support of the bill i am
okay it's on now thank you
um
i have notes uh because i don't speak
very often in front of people and i'll
be a little nervous i apologize for that
i'll try to go
off on my own here um
i i
first lived in new hampshire in
merrimack
a long time ago i was a child and i grew
up there and we had private trash pick
up and everything worked great it was
fine i
lived there after i went to college as
well and participated in
things
and then i bought a house in manchester
that i lived in for 30 years and in
manchester they had public municipal
trash pickup very different than what i
was used to in merrimack but that also
worked quite well um everything was fine
i got close to retirement age and i
started looking to downsize from my
house of 30 years
and i've always loved hampton and so i
moved into hampton and i bought a condo
and that was a bit of a dream come true
to be
in hampton near the seacoast and all
that
and after i got involved i started
realizing some things that were
surprising to me
i of course downsized got into a condo
in order to save costs as many people do
retiring
etc
in manchester i worked a little bit to
help with some people to help kind of
organize some workforce housing and
affordable housing etc it was always a
challenge as we all know in the state
and one of the things i recognize is
that in any large building
any condominium building any apartment
building any workforce housing building
there are enormous number of costs
associated with those buildings that i
never experienced in a single family
home in merrimack or in a single in my
home in uh in manchester
and one of those costs which seemed the
most kind of egregious the most odd
was that
many of the condos built and apartment
buildings built in the last
number of years
the
the planning board and the developer the
planning board basically said look
you're not going to get these plans
approved so i've been told unless
you sign away the rights for all those
future owners
to not have their trash picked up
hampton like manchester provided
municipal trash pickup
so in order to get the plans approved
the developer agreed that that building
would not have
so i moved into the condo and i after a
couple years i started looking more
carefully at the budget and getting
involved to help run the run the
building
as i moved into it at first i owned both
for a little while then i moved into the
condo and i recognize well
we pay in our tax our taxes
um
and we pay for private trash pickup but
i thought man i thought hampton had
municipal trash pickup so i investigated
it and learned that our building was
excluded from municipal trash pickup now
the truck goes by it
um
you know it picks up my neighbor's trash
it picks up some trash at some other
older condo buildings but i also learned
it didn't pick up trash at a bunch of
other newer condo buildings like in the
last 10 15 years
um i called some friends in manchester
where they also had municipal trash
pickup because i was most really
familiar with
private pickup
and i said what goes on there and they
said oh yeah we've had this problem
lately um
with the same thing i mean
the developers are signing away the
rights
for this municipal trash pickup for
signing away the the feature um in order
to get their plans approved
and i said well i don't understand any
of that so anyway i called it i talked
to some selectmen
and
probably about three years ago i started
this in hampton and i said hey what's
this about it doesn't make a lot of
sense to me they explained to me well
the developer signed away the rights i
said well that i get that but
how is that just or fair or even ethical
i mean for perpetuity now
you're going to skip this building and
here's the real irony in the building
i'm in there's a few commercial units
they get their trash picked up
so the trash truck comes to the building
takes some trash
but won't take residential trash that
was i guess part of the agreement i
in in our case there's no fee in the tax
bill it's part of the budget you can
look through the town budget you see
trash uh pickup and disposal is quite a
it's not an insignificant amount and
it's a rapidly growing amount as we all
know due to the trash
and recycling uh cost increases
um
so i investigated it the selectman
basically said this is how it's always
been um and this is how it's going to be
i talked to
new selectmen a couple of newer ones and
they said oh that doesn't seem right at
all that doesn't seem just and i said no
then let me look into it get back to you
both cases they're looking to get back
to me and now all of a sudden no no this
is how it's been forever this is how
it's going to be and they're not going
to pursue it i thought all right well
i didn't know what to do after about a
year and a half of talking with the town
i also talked to the town manager and
the town manager said we're very
familiar with the problem other people
have the same
uh grievance uh but unfortunately he
said uh he he said first you know we're
not going to do it it's a developer
agreement i said well i get that the
developer is long gone um and then i
explained that uh
you know
he said well it's on private property we
can't come on to private property and
pick up the trash i said well that's
fair but we can put it out in front of
the building i mean we can do exactly
comply with whatever rules you have for
anyone else and he said so i said so if
i comply with those rules will you pick
it up and he said no
we won't pick it up even if you do
exactly what everyone else does to have
it picked up i said all right and he
went on to say that
unfortunately the selectmen
are fine with this the way it is
the uh that we've been doing it for a
while and there's no state law
or regulation that that
that doesn't allow it and i said what do
you mean by that does there have to be a
state law to do the right thing and he
said well i'll give you an example in
education we can't do well first he said
well you know it's like education if you
don't have kids
you pay for it but you don't pick it up
and i said well i don't have any kids
and i pay for it that's perfectly fine i
get that i don't necessarily use the
library but i pay for that that's fair
this is different
i have trash
they won't take it it's like having a
kid
but not allowing him to go to school
because of some
agreement the developer made makes no
sense to me and he said well the state
law we can't that can't happen
i said but it can happen with trash and
he said yes he said oh it also can't
happen with sewer
hampton also provides sewer service like
manchester
if the town chooses not to or
decides it's not economically feasible
to send a line up a certain street or
develop it into a certain area the
people who have
they're not obligated to pay for
everyone else's sewer
so the town manager explained this to me
and i said all right well it doesn't
seem like we're going to do anything in
hampton he said no
so that's when i started writing letters
to my
senators
sherman and representatives and senator
sherman was gracious enough to call me
back or talk to me about it and i
explained the situation
um
and he said well it doesn't seem just on
the face of it i said no it isn't i said
it's not really an issue most towns deal
with because they don't have a municipal
trash pickup
you know that's all private and i said
that's fair
if you have uh
pay per throw like exeter does
that's fine but in this case
they're not coming by to pick it up
anyway so we would be obligated to bring
it to the
transfer station the interesting thing
is if you try to private if you try to
contract out your trash service
the municipal transfer stations don't
allow a dump truck to go in and dump
without paying a fee
so our the guys who come and pick up our
trash not only do we have to pay for
them to pick it up we also have to pay
for them to get rid of it
they can't say well this part of this
truck
is from your residence to go into that
transfer station so you're paying not
only for the pickup but also the
disposal to the town
and then you're also paying a private
company for both the pickup and the
disposal
um and that's really what i i love the
more i looked at it i thought
i don't understand i love the state of
new hampshire i've been here my whole
life i find it to be generally quite
just and a good ethical place and i said
this just seems egregious this is i
don't understand this in the least as to
why this can happen
and i i
express that to a number of people and
the only people who seem to think it's
fine are the people who've just become
accustomed to it
it's just like their life now but
anybody you talk to who's not familiar
with this looks at it like well how can
this be allowed makes no sense
and so that's what caused this to uh i'm
almost done sir
um that's almost you know that's what
that's what that's what brought this to
my uh for here and and it's the planning
i think the reason the bill's written is
we've discovered it's the planning
boards kind of holding
the building hostage you know the
development plan hostage to
signing this away i don't know
the motivation exactly other than the
fact that
it's an issue in it it also impacts
apartment buildings
uh they often suffer from the same thing
so that owner ends up paying and it
adversely impacts along with a number of
other things i've learned since i moved
from a house into a condo it obviously
impacts workforce housing as i've
learned mr sorrentino would you be
willing to take questions absolutely yes
yes representatives davis
thank you very much sir for testifying
and thank you for taking my question
so i'm looking at the hampton new
hampshire
city government web page right now
and it states that
trash containers will be issued to
apartments condominiums
residential or business
up to 10 carts combination of trash and
recycling as requested
and it does not mention any fee it says
this is a public service under all the
other public services
so what
can you help me understand why
there's a contradiction here
the
there are a number of condominiums older
condominiums there where they pick it up
and the bins are out front and they do
that uh but in the last i can't tell you
exactly the date because frankly i've
talked to the selectmen and the town
manager nobody quite new but this
practice came in to be
of
not just forbidding apartment buildings
and new new development uh condos et
cetera not not uh single-family
homes they are all they they allow that
but they basically tell the the
developer hey look you've got a you've
got to sign this away
representative ron
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
serrantino for taking my question
first of all i think you did an
excellent job thank you um
you you can come to our committee at any
time very clear explanation and you're
always welcome back to merrimack um my
my question is what do you do with
large things like a sofa do you still
have to does the town come and
pick that up or
um or do you have to have are you forced
to use your private contractor i believe
in hampton i don't know i haven't got
rid of it myself but i think it's all
about you can bring it to the transfer
station yourself i know you can do that
in hampton that's what i've done
um i don't know if there's some
arrangement whereby they'll come and
pick it up for you i know that in
manchester where i live for 30 years
they you can make an arrangement for
them to come and pick it up for a small
fee
uh depending on the item there are
certain items there's no fee there are
items or there's a small fee they'll
come and pick it up
of course you can always bring it
yourself okay thank you thank you mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh
previously
it was mentioned that uh
the trash pickup is a line item on the
bill
of your property tax bill do you get a
property tax bill
is there a line item on on the property
tax bill that says trash pickup not on
my bill no
thank you it's uh built into the
uh one more question senator majipu i
mean uh representative manager putin
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question i'm just trying to
clarify one
aspect and you did mention that isn't it
true that there are some condominiums
all the condominiums and apartment
complex that have
grandfathered in
in the terms that get the municipal
trash pick up
and it's only the new developments that
have this issue
that is my understanding i've seen there
are condos where you can see the bins
are the totes are out front and they get
picked up and they're older ones um so
my i've been told that and my experience
is that yes
and it's not you say grandfathered in
it's interesting because there doesn't
seem to be any set of uh regulations
around this it's really just this
informal thing that seems to happen
between the planning board
and the developers
then they get together for a new
development it's and when i say that i
mean a building never a single family if
you're doing a single family subdivision
there's never talk of this it's only for
condominiums and apartment buildings
uh question i i have uh have you ever
been to your your local planning board
to to
advise them of your concerns about this
issue i've talked to people on the
planning board and the zoning and the
the zoning before i recognize it was
more of a planning issue yes sir
representative
follow-up
have you
found out that
does it reflect the number of units the
density
versus
the
uh time of you know the
in the last 10 years or 15 years is that
is there any correlation from your
informal thing and
the reason i'm asking is
what this bill is a study committee
so to look at what the
specific issue is with this trash pickup
so have you done any of those
um we haven't done an exhaustive search
of this but it doesn't seem to matter
there are some very you know
six very large condominiums with lots of
land it's just happening built as a
condominium for whatever reason and
they're excluded because they're newer
and then there are some that are much
smaller
uh much more densely packed that are
also excluded it seems to have more to
do with the timing as to how old the
building is basically
thank you uh is senator birdsall in the
audience
yes would you like to come up and
testify
okay
sorry
i have a pink card and i saw your name
uh
right thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for hearing me thank
senator birdsale would like to introduce
yes
welcome senator
thank you
chairman and thank you committee for
hearing my bill for the record my name
is regina bartzel state senator for
district 19 which encompasses the towns
of hampstead windham and derry
and i am the prime sponsor of senate
bill 246 which pretty much dovetails
with senator carson's uh bill
this this bill basically um is a private
another private roads bill and it
regulates qualified private communities
this bill was a request from a number of
constituents of our senator carson's in
mind
where there are a lot of condominiums
and homeowners in new hampshire that are
located at what are considered private
roads and what this bill basically does
communities it's not
going back but what it does is it
requires either one of two things it
requires that if a builder is planning
on building a
condo community or a homeowners
association that is going to have
private roads they either put money
aside
to into a trust fund to allow
a kind of a seed
trust fund for any road repairs
or it requires the
developer to go ahead and build the
roads up to the municipal
municipality standards
what we've been finding is and you'll
hear i think from one of
our constituents is
within two or three years because these
roads are built not to the standards of
the communities these roads within two
or three years are actually starting to
degrade so within two or three years of
a new community coming aboard you're
having assessed fees of i know in our
condo we were assessed a fee of 3 500
each condo to try and repair our road
but
we were lucky that our roads lasted
almost 20 years but in some of these new
communities they're not lasting
and when and there have been instances
where the
condos or the homeowners association or
the private roads requested that the
town take over the roads and the
municipality said no we're not going to
because they're not built up to the
standards of the municipality so that
puts them at a really
strong disadvantage because they it's
like a hamster in the wheel they can't
get out of it they either have to build
the roads up to the
municipality standards to have them take
it over
or they have to just keep repairing it
so with that i will entertain any
questions i know you'll hear some
some of the condo and homeowners
association
members are behind me
thank you representative guthrie
thank you thank you senator
for
taking my question
uh
in the
uh on page
first page uh line 25
to uh through 29 or
231 you
uh require that they do either
set up a trust fund or bring
the roads up to standards why did you
give them a choice
instead of requiring that they do both
because if i could it would seem to me
that if they don't do the bee which is
bringing the roads up to standards
you're going to have trouble down the
road automatically well that's what the
seed money is for is to help
help the community members to
alleviate some of the assessment fees
that they're going to be having so
they
the developers either
yeah either have to build the roads up
to the standards or they're going to
have to put money into a trust fund to
help the communities build those roads
but the question is why didn't you
if they do just one of them they don't
they're all set they don't have to set
up the trust fund
so that's it
that is correct and if they do build the
roads up to the standards the
municipality if they want the
municipalities can take it over for the
maintenance
so they don't need the seed money
another follow-up if i could i'm not
clear that
if they build them up to standards
then the the towns or cities would take
over the responsibility for those roads
but would have the
50 percent
over here on the side to
expend on those roses no it only if the
condo and homeowners association wanted
them to take over see what that
building the roads up to the
municipality standards
typically allows a 10 in our case a 10
to 15 year time frame where they can
start putting the reserves away which
are required
in condo
condo associations you're supposed to
have i believe it's 10 percent reserves
for cases like this
oftentimes they don't have that built up
into it by the time the road repairs
happen so that gives the seed money
gives them the association some seed
money
okay does that help
well i don't i'm not in the convo so i
really
i'm still not clear
who has the responsibility
of the trust fund
oh the condo association should have the
responsibility of the church once the
builder
puts the development in and if they
choose to put the money into a trust
fund
then that trust fund in my i believe
gets transferred over to the condo
association or the homeowners
association so the town hasn't if i
could the town doesn't have any
responsibility for doing the repair and
spending that money all right thank you
thank you senator
representatives
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question senator
i'd like to follow up on what
representative guthrie is saying in a
way
it seems to me that
all it
seems to me that all a developer need do
to fulfill the terms of this
law should it pass
is to provide the city or town with an
estimate of what it would cost to
replace the road
that that could be
it says
at least one of the following options
right in the bill and one of those
following options is just provide an
estimate of what it would cost and
i guess my question is what good would
it's not
um it's
it's actually putting money aside
because
the condo owners and the homeowners
association are responsible for
maintaining those roads but if they're
not built
appropriately then they're going to
start degrading earlier i'm not
uh yes and can you point out to me where
it says that
that they must provide this escrow
account
it seems to me that the bill is written
in such a way that they can choose one
of these options to provide
they can't doesn't put money in an
escrow account for future residents
well it says on line 25
uh i met as amended by the senate no
city or town shall approve plans for a
qualified private community unless the
declarant agrees to at least one of the
following requirements for such
qualified private community a the
declarant will establish meaning the
developer will establish a capital
reserve fund of no less than 50 percent
of the cost to replace all roadways
within the qualified private community
based on the cost estimate as described
in paragraph two
and b the declarant will build all roads
to design standards for public ways for
the municipality that is approving the
project
so they either have a choice of putting
money into 50 percent of the cost of
repairing that road into a capital
reserve or they can build the road up to
the standards
in my apologies i was reading it
incorrectly so my apologies thank you
representative
thank you chairman and thank you senator
for taking my question uh is it not true
that one reason that a developer might
choose not to build up to
the town standards is because the town
standards require a road wider than is
necessarily best for the community and
therefore they might choose to do
option one of putting the money aside it
could be
it could be there um there are a few and
i think you may hear a couple of the
stories that
um
when the builder
when the builder goes in to put the
plants together in front of the planning
board
um
they just they just want to get the the
homes built and sold
um so
they're going to build the roads um
however they feel is best at that point
not what's best for the community as far
as i'm concerned
representative pimante oh yes thank you
mr chairman thank you senator thank you
for your question
what's the scope of the
units involved in this procedure i'm
sorry oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry i apologize um i'm looking for
the scope of
the condominiums that will be involved
in something like this now
and if so would it not have been the the
cause of the builder
trying to uh
maybe save money to make the roads not
wide enough
possibly
okay
all right do you have a
follower
the first part of my question was a
scope of the
the condominiums involved in this
what i'm what do you mean well how many
actually have fallen under this category
is it widespread throughout new
hampshire or is it
secluded in certain areas my
hey representative ayer
thank you for taking my question
i was on the planning board and all
subdivisions have to have a 30 foot wide
road
that's code so fire trucks can get down
it's a private road
because the contractor or the developer
wants to sell the lots cheaper if we do
this
the
developer's not going to pay this money
you are the person that buys the house
it's going to say you buy a house there
you're going to pay an extra 200 000
over a 30-year mortgage to pay for that
road
he's not going to lose money that's why
they make a private road but the private
road still has to be 30 feet wide by
code so you can get a fire truck and an
ambulance down here at the same time
but you also have keep in mind first of
all that a lot of these condos
within three or four years their roads
are starting to deteriorate so now
you're you're they're looking at 3 500
or more
assessment to their their
home
and there are some condominiums and i
think you'll hear it especially the one
in londonderry where they built the
homeowners or they built the homes now
they're talking about putting a business
the the road comes to i think 102
if i'm not mistaken and then they're
talking about putting a like a little
village district and the way the
entrance into that village district is
on the homeowner's road
so they're going to be responsible for
maintaining that as well and they're
they it's used as a cut through as well
the public uses it as a cut through so
there is some responsibility
follow-up follow-up go ahead
it's it's a private road
so that means the planning board you
know was involved in putting in that
little
store or whatever it is
uh as far as the road goes it's a
private road
so the town has or the contractor has no
no responsibility in taking care of that
that's built in
you know to build a private road it's
still got to be 30 feet wide and but
they don't have to hot top it
unless they want to but you'd pay for
that it would be tacked on to the lot
it divided out if it was 10 lots
whatever that extra road cost
that 50 thousand dollars would be tacked
onto that lot and then if you have a
mortgage and you're paying for you know
say 25 000
for 30 years it comes out to a lot of
money representative do you have a
question for the senator
what's that do you have a question for
the senator
no i'm done okay i i just want to remind
everybody
that uh we should be
speaking in the form of questions for
those who are testifying
yes
representative matt giori
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question senator
it says in the in the bill and the
amendment that no city or town shall
approve without so does that mean and i
think i'm following up on my friend's
comment about being on a planning board
which i am also
that this automatically has to be a
condition of approval for that site plan
that is my understanding so there are
it's follow-up chairman why i never do
that i never do follow-ups that felt
funny
so when we read off in our planning
board meetings the standard conditions
for approval this would then be included
in that a standard condition of approval
is
what is in this bill for only for
homeowners associated only right and
condominiums okay thank you that was a
very good follow-up
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
uh for private roads are there any
standards do
engineering um associations have
standards for building private roads or
is it purely up to the decision of the
developer
there's there's various types of private
roads as i found out when i i did this
because there are actually private roads
where there's only four or five homes
and they have to maintain it dirt roads
so
it's not it doesn't um private roads
isn't specifically for homeowners
associations in condo um but these are
for any
future development of the homeowners
associations or our
condo associations
representative
manchapuri does this
distinguish between detached condos or
high-density condos or single-family
homes
it pertains to anything that is either
in a in a condo association whether it's
townhouses
or
home owners associations where you have
various homeowners associations that
have full homes
in a private community
representative tripp
thank you chairman thank you for taking
i notice that you specifically
state
that
this
so
you mean to maintain them in the future
only if the home homeowners requests it
and they don't have to the town doesn't
yes
so given that's the situation
this is essentially just requiring that
they plan to replace their votes
yes
yes representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking another question
am i correct in saying that this does
not
stop the developer for bringing these
roads out to the town standard if the
planning board requires it
little i know about the planning boards
responsibility but i think that many
planned wars even our town your town of
my town
have a responsibility particularly
they're very tight on making sure that
there's
enough
space on the
roads for fire and
an ambulance service so
there are many towns that
would do too
the second
option but still do the first so you
even though you don't require that
both
putting down the 50
and the town standards isn't correct
that you the
developer could do both
if they would like to yes
um and keep in mind too
because i do live in a condo and a few a
number of years ago we had looked into
possibly getting a it being a public
road
and the requirement was we would have to
remove the the force that was behind our
condos so that the
um fire station could have an egress
into it and we chose not to we chose to
keep the um the private road private
because we didn't want the um
the force removed from behind our condos
thank you senator we really appreciate
you taking the time to explain this bill
to us and thank you we have a lot of
people behind you that i think are
wanting to speak to it oh boy
for those of you who are in the audience
and want to speak to this bill
i ask that you'd be brief
and that consider what's already been
discussed and if it's been discussed
already i would just say that yeah i
want to do what senator birdsall said or
john's uh
idea over here rather than
going through it
and i only mention that because we only
have so much time today and
i know many of you may have driven quite
a while to get here so i i do recognize
that
so next we're going to have
to to speak is edgar uh bourgeois is
that right did i pronounce that correct
almost correct all right
you asked for three minutes go right
ahead
members of the committee
uh
as a homeowner in a
economy association in manchester i'm
here as vice president of the
association and we are madison heights
unit owners association
we've been in existence since 2004
and speaking
road maintenance and other issues that
the city then
does not provide for services such as
following our streets garbage collection
and of course the maintenance of the
roads
now our association has been in
existence since 2004
however we've already had to repave our
method that they used to to construct
we don't have many issues we've been
very fortunate that most everything was
done um
in a good
high quality manner however again to go
to some of the points of
why some of these
development
developers
choose to go private roads is that
it's a cost savings
but it also increases density
the owners do not get any benefit of
that
increased density
the developer chooses to
keep all of those additional profits
so
as part of our example here today
is in 2028 our 18 members
had to pay 4950
for snow removal from our streets
we choose not to have that person clear
additionally we have to pay 5170
the cost to replace our road
was 30
in a mere 13 years
i know some examples that i've heard
is that
roads deteriorated sooner than that we
were fortunate we got 13 years
our concern is
without forcing the developers
to either improve the quality of these
roads
or set aside some kind of
reserve
we are left to have to pay that
and 30 000
in 13 years
is
it's illogical from from a homeowner's
perspective
we are not a multi-story condominium
association we are detached condos 18
individual owners
and we are made to
suffer the consequences of
whether it's the municipalities or
whether it's the developers alone that
are making these choices
it's kind of irrelevant i think we need
some protection mr bourgeois
your three minutes have expired
i'm sorry your three minutes have
expired
okay uh
we have questions will you take some
questions from the committee i will
representative tripp
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh
did the developer disclose these uh
future costs to you when you're looking
to buy a uh
your condominium
i wasn't one of the original owners
almost 10 years ago
and nothing in the declarations the
bylaws or any of the declarations
yes follow up
where were you aware that you would have
to be paying uh
trash pickup costs
uh plowing costs
and other things that was made
abundantly clear that we would have to
pay snow removal
so so the only uh disclosure that uh was
not apparent was that uh there would be
road road replacement costs and that it
thank you mr chair and thanks very much
for coming to testify before us today mr
bourgeois
um
my question is in regards to this bill
my understanding is this is
for communities going forward
this is not a retroactive
action
that's my understanding as well
so follow up please
go ahead
my understanding is then you're you're
coming forward based on your experience
to save some future homeowners
the current pain you have
exactly
the reality is we
almost never have the opportunity to go
back and retrace ourselves
however
if we if we don't understand some of the
drawbacks of the way things are done
currently
you know additional people additional
citizens will be forced to be paying
these costs and
let's face it when we're looking at a
new home all we see is
the colors and decorations and whatever
we don't necessarily
take the time to look beyond that
and
i'm surprised how many people do not
even read
the
kind of my laws and declarations it's
in so many cases
i'm part of the board of directors now
uh in our association and i'm always
amazed how many people do not even
realize they've got a copy
at the time of signing they purchased
themselves
it's
kind of disconcerting to hear that
you don't know what it is that you're
signing up for
but again it's it's the reality and
we're hoping that through our
presence here today that
somewhere somehow future owners won't
have to pay the same price we did mercy
miss you
thank you mr blizwell for your testimony
appreciate it very much all right thanks
for having me
hope everyone has a great day
next is uh
matt
nieswender i said i don't know if i
welcome
you've asked
for two minutes
yeah two to three minutes i think is i'm
going to try to make this brief bullet
and just go through the points right
ahead
so basically um i'm the president of our
road association in barrington my name
i'm also is of the new hampshire private
roads
care alliance and
i've been
on a private road for 22 years when i
first moved in there was no road
association there was no money seven
years later our road's a mess i decided
to create a association and start trying
to
hit the road taken care of and
i'm in support of this bill and
i think that
in situations like this if this bill had
existed prior to me
uh buying in to a private road without
any
uh association or rules or anything not
knowing all these hidden costs
i think this is a good start to kind of
make a difference in the state of new
hampshire
it'll also keep the roads in better
shape that are private roads for
emergency vehicles and
for buses and for kids walking
you know to their homes on the street
it'll keep things safe
it also will help keep up property
values for the home so that towns can
collect higher
taxes or regular taxes
and it will also
make the towns more desirable if the
roads are decent and they're not
falling apart or in disrepair
so in that case everyone wins
this bill there's no cost to implement
it
for the towns you know they just have to
basically put it into their
zoning and cleaning board
rules to have
these two
items
in the bill
adopted to either create a capital
reserve fund or
build the road to town standards and
to answer one of the earlier questions
somebody asked you know if it was one or
two houses the bill says four or more
houses
so um
hopefully that will help
um
also
there is a
problem in new hampshire around
cyanobacteria in our lakes and there is
a house bill
which is coming up next week
for
um discussion and
basically it's about cyanobacteria
being formed on our lakes and the cause
of this cyanobacteria basically is from
road runoff and poor drainage and that
typically that's typically um where a
lot of these private roads are they're
around these lakes and waterways and it
causes pollution and brings foreign
materials into the lakes which
brings the cyanobacteria to start
blooming
and
the des is
being asked to have a plan to address
sign open movements and we feel that
this bill can actually help with this
issue because
if you do private roads town standards
you're going to have proper drainage mr
nice one could could you wrap oh you're
about three and a half minutes just just
about there and
it will protect our wildlife our fish
our loons
and all that so
in summary basically
um you know it's it's a win-win for
everybody it protects future people from
getting into bad situations
and
it allows the towns to
look better and be able to
you know not be
adversely affected by
poor road conditions for
getting fire trucks at hand winces or
police down some of these roads that
might be in the atmosphere
so i thank you for your time and i'm
willing to take questions yes so
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question sir
so i received a lot of email with
regards to the
the totality of the bills we're hearing
today and i do read all my emails
so um
you did send a letter via mail as well
as follow-up by email and i looked at
the website that was referenced so i'm
hoping you could answer this question if
my
citation is correct
i believe that i saw on the website a
statement saying that there are two
northeastern states that currently have
statutes that address this issue with
the roads being built to proper standard
did i see that on your website and if so
could you please
share with me
somewhat
recognize that this is an issue
and um
there are probably more than two that um
exist
in talking with some of the people that
i actually
made phone calls to here um last week
they informed me that you know their
their town actually does
um
require
to be built to
town standards so when a new road is
being put in
so that you know they can last last
longer and have less problems
early on
i don't recall
the name of that town i do know that the
town of barrington does
have
some stuff in place for
private roads and
they realize it's an issue and they give
a five percent
break on the land
property value
evaluation
because you're on a private road and
they know that you have to
pay extra money to maintain your road
go ahead
so i i was interested in looking at
model legislation from other states
um to compare it to what the provisions
are in this bill so
if the state of new jersey has
some
documentation on
private roads that
is similar to bill
sb 250 which
basically
to be given
to private roads
and each private road would have to
submit a portion of
or
they would have to submit what they
spent and they would get a portion of
that back as a credit
towards
houses that are on that part of it
in a nutshell
i believe also the state of maryland
also has
some statutes in place
and
i don't have the exact details but i
believe it is on our
website and it is on the letters um the
website is on the letter that i sent and
it's also on the bottom of my email
so
thank you mr chair um i'm over here in
this corner
um
a quick question
how many miles of private roads exist in
new hampshire do you have any idea
well i know that the majority of private
roads in my town of barrington is over
i don't know the number of private roads
within the state i know that there are a
lot of private roads within the state
and as i said many of them exist around
lakes and rivers and ponds and things
like that where
you know had these roads in place for
many years and
a lot of them were dirt and probably not
built to town standards you know many
many years ago
and um
so
i don't have an actual number as far as
how many there are and i'm not really
sure if there's a way to
really get that data and provide how
many roads are out there versus you know
public
private
okay uh
that being said
oh one more question
thank you mr chair really quick i just
want to clarify something that i think i
heard before you said if a town approves
this i don't read that the bill that
okay i just want to make sure okay
thank you
thank you for your testimony and uh
appreciate it very much
who
well thanks for having me can everyone
hear me
my name is arie pollock i'm an attorney
at the law firm of gallagher callihan
and gartrell in concord
i'm also a registered lobbyist for the
new hampshire home builders association
i've got written testimony coming around
the home builders association opposes
this bill
and
i've had 25 years as a land use attorney
here in new hampshire
and i
certainly agree with what senator
sherman said earlier today with respect
to his separate bill that what might
seem simple on the surface certainly can
become very complicated and i think this
subject matter fits into that category
quite well
what this bill would require is any
private road system built upon any
nature of waiver any
kind of waiver whether it relates
frankly to the structural stability of
the road or things like lighting
landscaping signage
any type of waiver the bill does not
distinguish would require a cash escrow
of 50
of the road replacement value so let's
just put some examples out there
if the replacement value based upon the
cost to install in the first place was
something on the order of a million
dollars and that would not be a surprise
for a private community infrastructure
road system
five hundred thousand dollars into
escrow let's assume there are ten homes
in that development that would be a
passed cost to the buyer of each of
those 10 homes of at least fifty
thousand dollars
significant amount of money it as was
mentioned earlier the bill is designed
to apply to any development with more
than four units if your example is a
million dollars spread over five homes
one of the items we want to make sure
the committee is aware of is that home
owners associations are designed to
govern these types of issues and so at
the same time as the question was asked
earlier whether or not the buyer coming
in has taken time to understand their
obligations relating to infrastructure
it's also incumbent on these governance
boards to be planning ahead for these
types of expenses and i'm not suggesting
that there aren't horrible examples out
there where infrastructure has failed
far
ahead of its planned obsolescence far
ahead of what those capital needs and
improvements may have been scheduled for
or when they would have likely occurred
but those governance boards are required
by
statute and by declaration of
association to be planning ahead for
these expenses and i know the sponsor
made reference to her experience in a
condominium
in the state of having received a
special assessment of thirty five
hundred dollars to do road repair work
that would be
number one i think that might be the
unusual occurrence and number two it
would be significantly less than what a
buyer would be paying to help a
developer fund this escrow we we've
already heard testimony that there is a
significant network of private roads
throughout new hampshire this problem
would occur in many places
and as
this committee has focused on on a
number of bills this year the hou the
state is already in the midst of a
historic housing crisis
this would result in the passage of
costs from developers
to buyers and exacerbate the
affordability challenges
i won't restate what's in my letter
but i did want to go through a couple of
items in the bill language itself as
passed by the senate
and just point out for you the 50
number
as i mentioned applies to any type of
waiver whether that waiver relates to
the structural stability of the road or
not the road might be narrower than a
public road would require or the right
of way might be narrower there may be no
provision for sidewalks and it might
simply be the style of community that
they don't need those attributes doesn't
mean what's underneath the traveled path
of the road is any different or lesser
than what you would find on a public
road and some public roads fail
prematurely as well it depends entirely
upon the circumstances of what was there
in the existing condition and how things
were constructed
to identify 50 regardless of the type of
right of waiver that may have been
applied
it's a very arbitrary number
there are many standards that have
nothing to do with structural stability
the other item is
there's a portion of the bill at the end
on page two line five talks about the
expiration or sunset of the capital
reserve fund once it's put in place
it causes it talks about a number of
triggers that might cause that to occur
the interesting omission there to me is
what happens to the money when the
sunset occurs
who gets it does it get paid back to
somebody is the developer still involved
in some fashion which likely would not
be the case what role does the
municipality have in policing the return
of those funds these are not questions
that are easily answered maybe this is
the subject of a study
maybe it's just not a good idea or not
ready or applies only in particular
examples that are not statewide problems
and so as a result of that the home
builders are asking that you find the
bill itl or at a minimum
send it on another track where it can be
worked on with more detail thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
pollock for taking my question
um i understand from your letter and
your testimony that you are opposed to
the uh the one of the two options the
capital reserve option are you also
opposed to the language and the bill
that would require those private roads
to be built to town standards
right so i'm not opposed to roads being
built to town standard but i am opposed
to
circumstances that would
punish or disadvantage a developer from
coming in with a different idea
something that
may be more appropriate in a private
community setting that again
requires a waiver that has nothing to do
with the structural integrity of the
road system
representatives
can you educate me as to which new
hampshire rsa protects or pertains to
homeowners associations i am not aware
of any that do
homeowners associations um i know
condominium forms of government which
also are similar to homeowners
associations i think is chapter 356b
um and there are also
our provisions relating to private
infrastructure under chapter 674 the
follow-up
can you hear me now no
so
i don't know that it's specific to
homeowners associations but i do know
there's significant governance relating
to condo forms of government and for uh
land use planning road design planning
board regulations and specifications for
development but i just want to be clear
that in your testimony you did state
that there were laws governing and
protecting homeowners associations
perhaps i misspoke what i'm talking
about is the declaration that forms the
homeowners association and that
typically would be a document referred
reviewed rather by the planning board in
the municipal subdivision process and
placed on record for any home buyer to
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question are you concerned
um
are you concerned that the first home
owner pays
a number fifty thousand dollars in
sells the home before
any work is done on that road and now
there's fifty thousand dollars in a fund
left to
good afternoon
my name is catherine heck for the record
and i represent the new hampshire
municipal association and i will be
brief
we are here to comment on the bill we
have no position
however we did want to
thank the senate for including a
provision that would define capital
reserve fund not to have the same
meaning as in rsa 35 however we still
are concerned that the use of that
language combined with the fact about
the escrow account and it being held by
the homeowners association along with
the developer there could be a gap in
time in which the subdivision is
approved under the provisions of this
bill and the homeowners association
isn't fully formed and we don't want the
municipality to think for some reason
because it says capital reserve that
they would have some responsibility in
holding it and our previous suggestion
was to kind of just
change the term infrastructure fund any
other term but the financial tool that
our
cities and towns are so used to using
just to keep any confusion out
i'm not
sure under the um
d.o.t road standards town standards
are not mandated by state law
however many towns most towns do follow
the d.o.t road standards but there could
be variations in road standards and that
we also did express that concern
in the senate so there is no standard
statewide for road construction it could
be town by town and we just wanted to
make sure that was also
addressed so that's all i have if you
have any questions for me
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
anecdotally i have heard that part of
the
issue with the
associations like condo associations or
whatever is that
the developer will hold
multiple
units and therefore have multiple votes
i'm a little concerned that
the
as you said the the escrow fund or the
escrow uh money is is controlled by the
uh
the association you know in a situation
where uh the developer holds multiple
votes he can he can uh
improperly
maybe use the money do you think that's
a concern
um i i don't think we want to get
involved between the homeowners
association and the developers i think
we want to stay
clear of that
outside of the municipality approving
any other questions seeing none thank
you catherine i appreciate
next we have uh john goglia
from londonderry you uh support the bill
yes i do
i'll try to be
very brief because i got to be somewhere
can you hear me now
i have lived in londonderry for 38 years
i've lived in an over 55 community right
now with private roads for the last
almost seven years now
and um
i'm here to speak on behalf of myself
the 98 units in in my community and i'm
also a director and the treasurer for
the new hampshire private road taxpayers
alliance
uh
you know
our organization is a statewide
nonprofit that was formed probably two
and a half three years ago now
for this you know in part for the
purpose of
ensuring that
you know
the security the durability and
reliability of private roads
uh we have
uh over 500 supporters throughout the
state
uh everywhere every portion every part
of the state of new hampshire
and that covers about right now
about 100 little over 100 cities and
towns
people all live in different types of
communities not restricted to over 55
communities
they're they're
residents with families
they all live on private roads they all
have their
own uh stories to tell and it's
it would be virtually impossible for all
of them to be here and tell this story
so i'll tell you a little bit about my
situation and
you can
figure out how many times the story is
we're here today because myself matt who
testified a little while ago and a
member of my board of directors invited
senator carson senator birdsale to come
to our community
and we wanted to show them the private
roads and educate them about what we
know what we've learned over the two and
a half years we've been doing this
we showed them our roads we have five
roads that probably about
a mile and quarter worth of roads it's a
very condensed uh property
the stand-alone condos they're not
attached or anything
and
we
probably about a year and a half ago now
we had to spend about four thousand
dollars to seal
not seal coat crack fill the roads two
of the roads because they're falling
apart
these roads you know my understanding as
a layperson is that
public roads last 20 25 years
ours are falling apart we don't get that
much traffic even though we are a cut
through uh from
state highway 102 to a main road that
goes out our back entrance and a lot of
people use it
because they want to avoid traffic
lights
we showed them that we have uh or told
them that we have three commercial
easements on our private roads
it's kind of baffling that you have a
private road with you know easements to
commercial properties uh on our private
road one of those commercial properties
is is in the process of being
planning for development we don't know
what's going to go in there but we don't
want to spend what we've been told is
about eighty thousand dollars to fix our
our private our two roads that need
repair
until we know what's going in there
because we'd like to try to do a good
neighbor thing where maybe they'll help
us pay if they're going to use our road
to get entrance to their property
maybe they'll help us with it um
but
you know
there are there are
a lot of people probably a couple
thousand people as we estimate that we
haven't been able to reach it that live
on private roads that have issues for
whatever reason that they haven't come
forward yet and the reason why we're
here is to
uh prevent
future private road owners from falling
into the trap that we fell in
unknowing until year three or four what
you're really up against
when you're when you move into a private
road community
um
i i think i might be in a position to
answer a lot of the questions that maybe
haven't been answered representatives
do you have any idea how many miles of
in my community there's about a mile and
a quarter
i've measured that myself as far as
statewide i don't know that anybody has
those figures i've contacted a lot of
towns and asked
you know how many private roads they
have what the names are the prime so we
could
reach out to these people through
mailings or whatever
some towns have
can identify private roads and some
can't
that answers your question follow up
um
so
you have in your community 1.5 or
whatever
and do you have any idea what
londonderry has how many private roads
how many miles of private roads i i have
no idea um
londonderry has
11 or 12 over 55 communities and several
other communities
with family residences that that have
private roads
any other questions for mr goglia
yes representative power
thank you
thank you this is not working
just
speak loudly we'll get it looked at it
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question in your testimony you
had stated that with regard to the
condo development that you reside in
that there are three commercial
easements
my question is
does your homeowners association
and perhaps as well as the organization
nhprta
do they have a seat at the table with
regard to the planning process and the
approval by the planning board
with regard to approval of any of these
commercial developments
and the reason why i ask that is that so
the wear and tear
of the private road
gain access to these commercial
developments will that be taken into
account when that plan
exist none of us live there
and now
i know our board is monitoring
the development of these commercial
thank you
mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
and uh
the homeowners the whatever association
you're in had had no part in granting
them
were was there disclosure that these uh
easements
as existed else previously said you're
concerned with
other things your lifestyle
you know the color of your house this
stuff you're not looking at
uh any other questions
for
mr goglion
seeing none thank you very much
next uh
person we're going to hear
[Music]
is
judy bastian from laconia
and judy supports the bill and judy
supports the bill yes
i'm judy bastian i live in the lakes
region
and i don't know the answer to how many
groups there are they're private
i do know there are over 30
developments
that are private
and i do live in a private community i'm
here in support of this build which has
no effect on us
weather in new england as we all know is
all the taxpayers participate in the
repair class
some private street developments have
resumed funding for street maintenance
however
when a private street is of such genetic
construction
it may mean that the funds set aside or
insufficient to accomplish those repairs
before the repairs occur much earlier
than expected
in this case each homeowner in the
development is charged a special
assessment
and they have to pay the cost of the
repairs
it could be said and i'm sure it is
that the requirements of this bill
it will be built in to the cost of the
homeowners of the future
based on that requirement sure it would
cost more because the builder is going
to pass it on
but most of the buyers start off with a
garbage so the extra cost is built into
the mortgage
and the construction
would be part of that
and when it comes to special assessments
that catches hold on as my surprise when
you go into a private development
you're not really thinking about am i
going to be assessed a big fee because
all of a sudden my street needs repair
you don't think about that but when you
this bill would provide some assurance
that your private street was
constructed from
or provide some funding for future
perhaps early needed maintenance
and doesn't maintain public and private
sectors
for the witness yes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i hope that you can
answer it uh the question that i that
just occurred to me is
even if a a a private road
in a condo was built to municipal
standards
does that
then therefore
require or necessitate that the
municipality will accept that road just
but we have a lot of delivery vehicles
now particularly in the last two years
we've seen more of the ups and we've
seen more fedex and we have seen more of
amazon crime
any other questions for
miss
excuse me i just got a text from the
okay we're gonna we'll address that uh
okay thank you very much for traveling
and our last speaker
is robert
frescura
from hudson new hampshire and he
bill you for letting me speak to the
committee
we didn't have our roads finished until
last year
our roads deteriorated over that period
of time we were concerned
that our declarant would not finish the
roads
so in 2019 we decided to take him to
court to seek legal action
will you suspend for a minute the uh
the microphones seem to have kicked in
all of a sudden as you walk through the
door
please continue after a two-year legal
battle
we settled with our declarant
out of court to have him vacate the
property
so we could bring in a new developer and
finish our roads
for us
fortunately we struck a good deal and
our roads were finished in 2021
there have been questions here about the
homeowners association's responsibility
a new buyer coming into a 55-plus
community
he receives the condominium documents
which are the declaration the bylaws and
the rules
they're to the best of my knowledge no
disclosure in any of those documents
about the development being on private
roads
the homeowners association doesn't
communicate with a new buyer because we
don't know who the new buyer is
until they close on the unit
so again it's the buyer beware they
should be aware of it but this bill
would definitely help protect buyers
coming into 55 plus into any development
with private roads going forward
mr goldwater is it i mean um
robert bob for skier bob's fine but is
it do you have evident any evidence that
the
uh
realtors that are
moving the property are helping disclose
the requirements
i do not but they are required to
provide any prospective buyer
with the condominium documents
and i thought at one time they are
required to get the
buyer to sign a document that says they
have received the documents i don't know
if that's the case or if that is still
happening but until the buyer closes on
the property the homeowners association
isn't involved we have one of the top
realtors in the state that wants to ask
thank you mr chair
i don't necessarily want to ask you a
question i want to clarify that that you
are correct
as a real estate agent in the state of
new hampshire you are required to give a
disclosure to any buyer of the property
that is filled out by the seller
which details
the material facts of the property
some sellers will write down this is the
homeowners association this is a private
road
some will not just based on their
awareness not on any wanting to be a
falsehood and you are correct it's
usually not in a declaration of bylaws
or rules
oftentimes you can see it when you turn
onto the roadway though because it will
say the name of the street and then it
will say private road not in our
development okay i understand i live in
dover and many of our private roads
do say
and i think that that's a forward
it's happened
maybe since your
community has been developed thanks for
your testimony
i just would like to leave you with this
and i'll take any other questions you
may have
my last meeting with our declarant
he had agreed to finish our roads
our lawyer said that's fine but would
like to have him inspected to make sure
that done right his response was the
homeowners association has no say in how
i do my work
it's my responsibility and i'll do it
the way i want
that's why i think this bill is
important i think it sets a standard
going forward that helps protect the
public representative manchapudi
thank you mr chair thank you mister for
taking my question so just a
clarification you said
your community was built over a period
of time or
in 2017 to
around 2007 it may have started a little
bit before then uh a follow-up yes uh is
was it in phases you knew it was in
phase two so
the roads were not built until
no the roads were finished in 2021 i
think the last uh
we had one phase remaining but there are
six phases five phases were completed
probably
2016 2017
that's why in 2019 when nothing was
happening to finish the roads we be
became concerned and that's why we
decided to take our declarant to court
we thought that was the only remedy that
we could seek to get our roads finished
thank you thank you very much for your
testimony i appreciate you coming up
from hudson
one more
okay she waves
off all right thank you very much thank
you
okay so logistics uh right now we're
gonna go into a recess to give the
committee a chance to grab a bite to eat
i'm gonna ask the committee to be back
i'm sorry uh 1
110 i made it
110.
10 minutes 10 minutes plus one and
we will we'll pick up with
senate bill
249 at that point
which is about planning and zoning
ordinances
so could i ask you for your attention
and uh take your seats and
just so you know i have a deck of cards
here
that
represents those of you who want to
speak to this next bill so i'm going to
ask you
to try to consolidate your words or
okay i'm going to open the hearing on
which is pro prohibiting planning and
zoning witnesses that prohibits
so do we have is this senator french yes
it is
welcome senator you're going to open the
the hearing and
and introduce the bill thank you mr
chair good afternoon to you and the
committee
it's so nice to put in a bill that you
even if a little bit of it's negative
so i'm my name for the record is harold
french and i'm senator from district 7.
i'm here to introduce to you today
senate bill 249
in various communities in new hampshire
towns are currently suing their property
owners and property owners are suing
their towns
over the homeowner's ability to rent
their property on a short-term basis
recently a judge presiding over several
of these court cases pleaded with the
state legislature to step in and set up
some statutory parameters
for both property owners and
municipalities
the headline of the union leader
article read judge who will weigh in on
conway's regulation of short-term
rentals would like to see legislature
set statewide property
policy
this came out after i put in this bill
i encourage each of you to heed the good
judges plea and pass senate bill 249 it
passed the senate commerce committee on
a 5-0 vote and on a voice vote on the
senate floor
senate bill 249 is modeled on accessory
dwelling unit bill this legislature
passed several years ago
in that bill the legislature mandated
that towns had to allow a property owner
the ability to construct an accessory
dwelling unit within their home
however that bill also granted towns a
great deal of leeway on how they would
like to regulate these adus
same idea was put forward with senate
bill 249.
towns would be prohibited from using its
zoning power to eliminate the use of a
single or two family structure from
being used as a short-term rental and
that's the rub for most people
however
towns would retain all existing
authorities to regulate those rental
properties
towns could regulate parking
noise sanitation health and safety in
the same manner they can currently do
they simply
simply cannot ban
these from being
used in this manner
additionally senate bill 249 grants
municipalities to new rights
first they can mandate all short-term
rentals register with the town
and charge a fee for doing so
currently state statute requires
long-term rentals to register with
accounts but does not grant similar
authority on short-term rentals
i basically copied that statutory
language on long-term rentals and made
it applicable to the short-term rentals
and if a rental property becomes a
problem then sb 249 grants the town's
ability to rescind that registration
senate bill 249 also grants towns the
right to inspect a single and two family
home something which is currently
expressly prohibited in state statute
i am a big supporter of private property
rights and granting the government the
right to enter a home is not something i
particularly like
senate bill 249 even grants towns the
ability to charge a fee for that
inspection
however this bill is designed to balance
the rights of
private property owners in the needs of
towns to regulate for health and safety
of residents and visitors
no one is going to like everything in
senate bill 249
including me and that's the point
no one's going to be fully happy but
it's going to do what is necessary
please let's listen to judge
ignatius plea and pass senate bill 249
the issue with short-term rentals is not
going away
the result of inaction by the
legislature will continue litigation
costs for municipalities and property
owners both
both sides need to give a little to
create a common sense compromise
now there are folks here that
from the new hampshire association of
association of realtors who are very
familiar with the intricacies of this
bill and i would ask that the chair
would call on them to answer your
questions in detail thank you mr chair
thank you senator uh are there any
questions for the senator while he's
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question so my question is
a little bit multi-part and it
pertains to
the wording and the meaning of words
used in this bill so in particular i'm
interested in understanding better what
is meant um
lines five through nine on page one of
the bill
structure and short-term rental
um as well as conforming or
non-conforming so those terms so when i
read this bill structure it's not clear
to me what it is could it be a barn
could it be
a permanent tent
and what is exactly meant by short-term
rental does that imply
like a residence at which a person would
you know sleep or domicile
and also on lines seven through eight it
is specified um
clarifying language but i find it still
confusing
single family or two family building or
structure so that there again it's i'm
not clear what is meant by a structure
and then lastly what is meant by
conforming or non-conforming online nine
thank you
thank you for your multiple choice
questions
i'll answer number one
the uh
this is for single and two unit
properties
and
that's that's what the intent is it's
also
short-term rental is
i think it's anything under
six months
because i think
anything over six months i'm not exactly
sure the board
the association could answer that
uh does not have to pay rooms and meals
tax so it's anything that rooms and
and your last question was
conforming and non-conforming on line
nine
structure is conforming or
non-conforming i asked that you'd hold
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
so um just to be clear
you said that a um a structure that
therefore cannot be like a like a a barn
or
like a
a portico type thing where somebody
would rent that for a day
for an event a party a wedding just to
be clear so i'm not exactly sure to tell
you the truth because
a mini home or a
i don't know what kind of structures
would be
precluded from this i don't i don't
think it's intended for you to put a
tent up in your yard this is not for
commercial use
such as weddings and all that
this is for
are there any other questions for the
i'm sorry
representative
thank you mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question
is there anything in this bill that
would allow municipalities to restrict
short-term rentals in areas of their
town
in certain neighborhoods or zones or
would they have to allow short-term term
i'm pretty sure but not
exactly sure i think it would um
be open
throughout
go ahead
so just to be clear let's say there's uh
i'll just take hampton beach for an
example right
short-term rentals could be would be
allowed throughout the town
so maybe
neighborhoods that are far away from the
beach maybe near schools or something
they would be allowed to have short-term
rentals there
they wouldn't be able to just be
restricted to that beach area so laconia
restricted them
in
areas because we've had short-term
rentals historically for ever in the
state
and it's only until recently where
municipalities have been
have been
restricting them
so
i don't know if this would allow
because i'm not an attorney even though
i look like one
um i don't know if this would allow them
to restrict in certain areas with the
verbiage here or not to tell you the
truth i would ask
yeah
other questions for the senator mr
sir
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
i i just have a quick question and it's
kind of like what what uh certain words
mean what does i know what's an
unorganized place on line four
what is that i think
unorganized that's uh
i believe that's what's considered
uh way north of here where
it's not either a town or a city
it's like three hour drive for you to
get to one of them places so i drive
three or three hours north and then i'm
there and then you'll be there okay
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question
how does this um delineate
airbnb which is a newer concept
and
would that come under short-term
those would be short-term rentals there
would be airbnbs or short-term rentals
so that would be part of this included
representative
thank you mr chair thank you senator
taking my question um
uh do you feel that a short-term rental
is an expansion could be an expansion of
a non-conforming use
i don't uh
so a short-term rental is for staying
over in someone's property
i currently
have the right anywhere
if i own a home to allow anyone i want
to stay there for any period of time
correct
it's only when i
change it and decide to collect money
for doing so that i have a problem with
the municipality
correct
okay so
what this bill is trying to do is say
that i can do it
for compensation
what i have the legal right
i i absolutely understand i'm just
as a representative to the planning
board if we have a non-conforming use we
have to grapple with whether or not
there is an expansion of a
non-conforming use and i'm unclear about
whether or not the the
rights that you have to do that
create and create the condition of
expansion which then requires
in my town planning board review right i
i don't think it does i mean but that's
my opinion um
so use is for residential is for staying
there it's for living there
so the use doesn't change it's just
okay uh
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
um the the the local
planning board ordinances that
representative banjori referred to
are different for every town and city
across the state
wouldn't you agree yes
and isn't it the point of those local
ordinances to
best meet the needs and demands of those
local places and not the job of the
state to determine what is proper for on
a local basis in some instances yes and
in some where
um
some people feel it's an infringement on
property rights
then the state might step in and say no
you you have the right to regulate this
but
this goes too far and we're saying
you don't have the right
so just to be clear you're saying that
local
towns local municipalities
should not have the right
to regulate
uses
under their ordinances so
so what i'm saying is there's a point
where no government no section of the
government should infringe on the rights
of
on certain rights
thank you
okay thank you senator for coming thank
you and thank you for the wonderful
next we're going to hear from
sure
are you on the spot now representative i
would say and i have nothing funny to
say so
sorry
do you have any amendments
yes i do
uh thank you very much i'm uh
representative karen umberger
and i am
i represent carroll county district 2
the towns of conway
eaton chatham
and the unincorporated
let me start
by saying
that in conway
we had on the ballot
to see if the town of conway
and the vote on that
warrant article
was
in favor
opposed
so
in essence
the town of conway
has said
they do not want short-term rentals
there was also another article on the on
the warrant that said
if we have short-term rentals do you
want them regulated
and the answer to that was an
overwhelming yes
but there but people
voted for that particular amendment
not knowing
if in fact the ban on short-term rentals
was not going to pass
so
that was kind of belt and suspenders
on the
i did not i'm sorry i didn't run enough
copies of the amendment
for everyone but
i noticed that someone was going to get
them this is a
a huge amendment
it simply says
the kearsarge lighting precinct
established in 1957
per
408 colon one
is exempt from the provisions of
paragraph six
and paragraph six is what was just being
discussed
in regards to
short-term rentals what are they and so
on so it's basically saying that
the kearsarge lighting precinct is
exempt
from this whole
mess
so i know that there's probably no one
sitting at this table
that's ever heard of the kearsarge
lighting precinct
it is located as one of the small areas
we were granted
zoning
rights
by the legislature
in 1957
so our little precinct has had
zoning
ability
since
1957.
in most cases our
zoning
ordinances are stricter than the town of
conway
but we believe we we we actually live in
a very
although it's called residential it's
it's pretty wide open
and looks more like a
a little country town
than it does like part of conway
so
we also
i think it was
passed a zoning ordinance that said
if you wanted to rent short term
the house had to be owner occupied
so
this was long before
airbnb
vrbo home away
whatever it is
we recently had a court case
that was
uh
it was ruled in our favor
by the same judge ignatius
that uh the senator was talking about
and by the way she's a very nice person
um
and so
that court case supported
our ability for
owner occupied short-term rentals so
the first thing i ask
is that you support this amendment based
legislation that ruled we could zone
ourselves
and we didn't have to pay attention to
what conway or
bartlett and by the way we spread over
two towns what conway and bartlett had
that's number one
the second thing is as the bill is
currently written
there are holes that you can drive a
one of them is that it doesn't talk at
all
about declarations and covenants that
homeowners associations and condominium
associations have registered with the
register of deeds
so for example
in the uh the covenants that
that
are on my homeowner for my homeland
association say that we cannot have
they have to be i think i think it's
they have to be 30 days or something but
there's a
a thing like that but you can't have
just a weekend guest
whereas the condominium association
that is located within the homeowners
association says you can have short-term
rentals
so each homeowners or condominium
associations in their declarations and
covenants
have made
a decision
about short-term rentals
and
again to me
if we are
if you want to fix this legislation
you need to say something about
condos and homeowners associations and
that their declarations and covenants
rule
the other thing that is a little
interesting and i didn't read it this
way before
but it says short-term rental
means any single family or two-family
building
so guess what
that eliminates about 98 to 100 percent
of all condominiums
because i don't know of any condominiums
in the state
that are only two people or
to um
a two-family building
so you need to think about that
because i
don't think that senator french
wanted to eliminate the possibility of
condominiums
being excluded
from
short-term rentals
i have some additional testimony with me
uh
for people that could not attend today
and i will
provide these copies of this to the
the chairman but one is from
one is from
vicki and john mcdougall
and the third one is from
chris
werner
and uh yes they are all residents of
conway that just in
case you were wondering so i thank you
and i will be sure to answer any
questions you may have
any questions for the representative
yes representative manchakudi
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
again you mentioned
in the in your testimony about airbnb is
more a recent
um
phenomena and this you know whatever was
before didn't include or think about it
but some of the communities have made
accommodation
for airbnb
because they have a different it's a
short-term rental it's a different
way of
offering opening a home or a community
up for short term
so how
have you considered
if there is any policy that has worked
in a community
to
still give the local communities an
opportunity
to be able to do this at a community
local control
versus the state
no i have not
because uh
for example i i mentioned that conway
had voted on this the kearsarge lighting
precinct also voted on whether or not
they wanted short-term rentals
and the answer in both cases as i
indicated was no
and i think the other thing that
is probably quite unusual
is that our zoning ordinances have been
around since 1957
and
the uh the change for owner occupied
occurred in
1982.
so you know
and i'll just tell you the reason that
the kearsarge lighting precinct
came to the legislature for zoning
is because
the fathers in the town of conway wanted
nothing to do with zoning in 1957 so we
said okay fine
will just go around you and that's what
we did
a quick follow-up
yeah thank you so coming back to that uh
representative don't you think as we
have always done local control
enhancing local control
it
might thank you representative
appreciate you oh i'm sorry
representative tripp
thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question uh
i want to follow up on a previous
question you know being a
planning board person
uh
the uh
the question previously was about
non-conforming use
you know it uh
i'm just trying to get this whole thing
in my mind
apparently
short-term rentals
are
structures
that
exist in residential areas versus
commercial areas where like uh
well you know it's interesting there are
a lot of motels and hotels and airbnbs
you know her every bed and breakfast
that all advertise on
any one of these platforms
so
you know they're
it's another
media medium for
what we
think of as
a place to stay it's just another medium
follow-up
thank you uh
but uh
like i said it it seems to me that
what this bill is speaking to
is
uh
short-term rentals
that are in residential areas and not in
commercial areas like motels would be
so that so that would be essentially a
non-conforming use
i am the one place i've never sat is on
the planning board
okay
and uh
i would uh i would think that what you
just said is correct
all right so i have one one last one
that's this is more of a statement than
a uh question but uh uh have you ever
heard of duplexes
yes those are two unit condos
which is you said that you've never
heard of a two-unit condo so
i call them duplexes not condos
thank you
this is an opinion question i can't hear
you
this is an opinion question
in your opinion do you think we should
get involved
with the planning boards and the zoning
boards in the whole state
to decide what they should do with their
town
no i don't
thank you
i would if there if there are no other
questions i would
i would strongly urge the committee
to think about
uh
putting this bill into interim study
because i think that there are plenty of
questions
that need to be answered
prior to this
going to the
house floor so
thank you
thank you representative appreciate you
coming and offering a testimony
thanks
[Music]
thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
i'm representative robert t berg from
coast district 3 representing the city
of berlin
i have to make it easy for the committee
i've written testimony which has been
distributed
and i'm out of respect for the clerk
because i know what the clerking is like
on a committee
okay
okay committee members i oppose senate
bill
not only as a representative but as a
member of the berlin city council
i have given you a letter informing the
committee that the berlin city council
voted monday april 4th unanimously to
oppose the legislation before you
a gross assumption is made in the bill
that the legislation presumes
erroneously that a one-fixed solution
fits all municipalities
not all towns or cities are alike
berlin for example only has 37 units
for a city of its size yet the north
conway area within a smaller with a
smaller population has greater than 600
units
the bill will do away with berlin's
ordinances already in place
if passed senate bill 249 would prohibit
local zoning ordinances from regulating
the location of short-term rentals
in brief
the issue is one of local control
and i encourage the members of the
committee to take into consideration
the latter when deliberating senate bill
to 49
i thank you for your time in
consideration
and also
in closing i will not entertain any
questions
not out of you know disrespect for the
members of the committee but i believe
that any a number of
individuals testifying behind me will
probably answer your your question
and also
i concur with the
previous speaker that
there are issues in the bill which i
think would be
advisable for the committee to take into
consideration
and not itl the bill that perhaps put it
in interim study so i can see pros and
cons on both sides of the issue thank
you
thank you representative
next we have
senator rebecca perkins quoca is she is
and while we're finding her how about
welcome
thank you chairman dolmen
and thank you to the house municipal
and county government committee
uh the best part about being mayor
as with a name like dagla macaron it's a
lot easier uh for folks in portsmouth
just to refer to me as the mayor mr
mayor
so that's that's been great i've i
passed uh testimony to representative uh
power um i hopefully that you've you've
got it i'm not gonna read that but i
will highlight the following mayors who
join me in opposition to senate bill 249
mayor boulais of concord mayor brown of
littleton mayor carrier of dover
mayor craig of manchester mayor donchius
of nashua mayor gerard from claremont
mayor grenier from berlin mayor hilliard
of somersworth mayor hosmer of laconia
uh mayor mcnamara of lebanon and myself
daigle macaron of portsmouth
i
i was compelled to to to come to concord
uh today and and it's great to be at the
municipal and county government uh
commission it feels like i'm at home
it's nice to know that you guys have
problems with the mics up here we have
problems in portsmouth um but you guys
are in the weeds of what affects
everybody in new hampshire on a on a
day-to-day basis and that's what i get
to feel like i get to do in portsmouth
is really hear
from constituents
and there's a lot that has been said and
will be said on on local control i
believe in local control but what i want
to point out today
is is really how this bill is an
anti-affordable
housing bill
and it is so
uh because i think in the the senate
testimony there was a discussion of two
markets
a short-term rental market
and a long-term rental market
and one of those markets is more
lucrative
than the other
and as we've seen nationwide as airbnb
has been allowed to happen in
municipalities the price of rent has
increased
and our own assessor believes the cost
of housing both for purchase of housing
and rental units in portsmouth will
increase if this bill is passed
and it's and it's precisely because
there is no provision in it for owner
occupancy i i think it was senator
french who said he believes in property
rights
i believe in property rights if this
bill was limited to
the ability of a homeowner say for 180
days a primary resident from renting out
their home
or as it was pointed out in in in conway
that there were requirements um i i
might be supportive of this but what
this will allow
is speculators llc's corporations to
come in
buy houses
and then flipped them into short-term
rental units thereby exacerbating an
affordable housing crisis
the opposite well the the other point
that that might have been made was well
there'll be more room in meals tax
revenue that the cities can enjoy
but that's not true
and it's not true because as you know
the calculation for the roman meals tax
is based on residents
it's not based on tourism believe me i
would love it if it was based on tourism
in portsmouth
but it's not
and so the more that we
promote long-term rentals at the sh at
the uh promote short-term rentals at the
expense of long-term rentals we will
reduce the money that portsmouth and
many other municipalities would receive
from uh the rooms and males revenue
and then
finally you know um oh just one quick
point on the uh expansion of of
non-conforming use uh this bill is
pretty interesting in that it calls the
and actually states that it's going to
uh raise a room and meals tax but
somehow make it not a commercial use so
the idea that you'd be expanding a uh
non-conforming use i think you'd be
expanding it to an actual commercial use
but they state that it's not and i don't
know
if you can just state that by a
commercial use and since it's simply
stated as a non-commercial use it's not
a commercial use and i think you know
there would be
there'd be questions and maybe legal
challenges to that but the real reason
a lot of people
visit portsmouth
a lot of people have a perception of
portsmouth
mine is a little different
i was born in portsmouth 38 years ago
my dad is from portsmouth his
grandfather graduated the third grade uh
worked for the city all his life and and
his grandfather or his father my
great-grandfather came down from nova
scotia and worked at the morley button
factory
and he
and he was called the lawyer not because
he had any formal
schooling but because he could read and
the other folks in the button factory
brought them the legal documents that
they saw or the paper and he informed
them so they call them the lawyer maybe
inspired my father to become an attorney
there is two portsmouths there's the
portsmouth that that gets you know put
all over mur
and there's the portsmouth that that
comes into my office
that asks me what am i going to do
when a property changes hands to an
outfit out of massachusetts and the
rents go up 200
a month and they've been given 30 days
notice or 45 days notice that that's
going to happen
i worry that this bill is going to throw
gasoline on the affordable housing
crisis that it's going to tear
communities apart
not out of any ill intent of the bill
but just a lack of understanding of what
this will truly have on impacts of
communities when we don't have
long-term residents any longer
and so with that i'd ask you to oppose
this bill
or study it and figure out how you can
make it better so that it could actually
benefit the residents that we have in
new hampshire now and not favor outside
development
and investment that is simply going to
uh turn our
turn our communities into
a giant hotel
thank you mayor uh
happy to answer any questions
any questions from the committee yes go
ahead
um hi thanks for taking my question um
so
the
possibilities you listed
that you said you'd be in favor of would
be
um
killing it or putting it to further
study
to find something else that would work
can you think of i'm wondering if third
possibility would
um
rep representative umberger had an
amendment for us for example could you
think of
any other
ways we could possibly
amend this to address the issues
described or is it just too much to well
i want to stay in my lane and turn you
know you guys are doing hard work of
legislating here um and i have faith and
confidence in uh in this committee
putting their heads together with what
i've addressed i think uh residency
requirements um you know i understand
that portsmouth we got a lot of work to
do in a lot of land
use and and study we've changed a lot in
the last
well 38 years certainly but in the last
10 years we've changed a lot
i wouldn't want to pretend to be able to
to to do your job
i do understand that the expectation in
new hampshire is that you know our
houses pay our taxes the property tax
they can't work for us
this could you know provide ability so
that homeowners could meet that
challenge i wouldn't want to take that
away from them and will work in
portsmouth to understand that this bill
as it stands right now is not close uh
to doing that so anything that would be
centered around residency requirements
is one person and i don't know if i
speak for any other mayor but myself
would be something that i would like to
see
out of this
thank you for mr chair i have a question
oh you do okay go ahead
thank you mr chu thank you
mayor for taking my question
would you believe that this
if it's a short-term rental versus
long-term rental
a
homeowner or anybody that has a property
to rent
can make more money with the short-term
rental
than our long-term so which
precludes that person to
not use it for short term so it
encourages
like you said the affordable housing
option
in your community versus if it's
no short-term rental
yeah i think that the
the studies that have been done have
been pretty clear that rents will rise
when short-term rentals are
unregulated new hampshire is a you know
it it doesn't pay to be fast especially
or first when it comes to municipalities
most municipalities if you look at
whether it's in texas or california or
even internationally they've recognized
the air in their ways in in allowing
this to happen unfettered for any number
of days of the year because it takes
it simply takes uh rental units off the
market i understand the private property
rights exist for residents i just i i
want to weigh them in the balance of the
community against those
those would be rights that would be
granted to llc's corporations outside of
the state of new hampshire and certainly
outside of portsmouth to come in and
raise the the property values and then
our taxes because we use the comparison
home model in terms of assessments
i just don't see the benefit to new
hampshire in this
thank you
thank you chairman and thank you mayor
for taking my question
mr mayor is it your
assumption
that
most
units which are used for short-term
rental
would be
long-term rentals
were they not being used for short-term
rentals
well i i
i don't know if if we precluded
short-term rentals from
happening
somebody might not want
to rent out any portion of their home i
could i could certainly assume that um
but i i could see that
at least in portsmouth
and it's more shadow because there's it
happens outside of our
of our of our jurisdiction
and the ability to enforce is is limited
um i think some of those would you know
i've seen people simply buy houses to uh
to to convert them that we're actual
tenant paying houses and this is
anecdotal and not maybe super helpful
but convert those it's not as hard as as
one might think to convert a long-term
rental into a short-term rental it takes
a couple of towels maybe soap management
company um they're gonna come in and be
able to do that and where the desire and
the the
the uh you know the
the market is there and it is there in
portsmouth it is there in some other
tourist locations it certainly is a
great incentivization uh to do that it's
also a great incentivization for people
that do not live uh in the community to
hire an outside firm um that would be
managing many dozens of these properties
um so i i couldn't say that you know if
there if short-term rentals were banned
in the state that uh we would solve our
housing uh situation i'm sure some of
them just would not they'd just be
absorbed um in and they wouldn't you
know they wouldn't like the idea of
renting them out long term uh but i
wouldn't say that's universally true
either
okay thank you thank you mayor for your
thank you mr chair you've had some tough
questions i worry about this one
not to worry
as a mayor
overseeing a large new hampshire city
if if if you have um
a hedge fund
out of dubai
that owns several blocks
in downtown portsmouth
where there are many many short-term
rentals
and under the bill's provision
you reserve the right to regulate those
short-term rentals by inspecting them
and responding to complaints etc etc
what recourse would you have if
something really went sideways if you
couldn't locate the owner or if the
owner was a corporate entity and wasn't
really a person at all
you know
i've i've steered clear of the
i think there was an effort made
to give some towns
it's difficult i think our primary
responsibility in government and in
local government is to maintain safety
for you know that's why we come together
in in government that's why we choose
you know uh it's it's safety
among numbers and we realize that we're
we're safer together
if there was not the ability to locate
the owner for any number
of reasons and they're not just simply
you know um
uh you know noise violations and that's
a big part of you know as a mayor you
get a lot of complaints on a lot of
things but to the true health and safety
the way that is written uh in terms of
you know
representatives not actually being
you know on site or anywhere or
designated there
that is a
that is an issue
um because i certainly wouldn't want you
know our chief of police to be put on
hold as they work through a management
company um that is dealing with you know
30 or 40 of these in portsmouth
thank you for taking my question
uh seeing your list of mayors
in your opinion do these mayors know
what's best for their town
without you would have to ask that i
would say to uh to a mayor they all
believe so you'd have to ask their
voters um but i would agree that they um
as i do uh think that i
i know portsmouth and i would think that
mayor donchess would know nashua and and
mayor craig would know manchester um
uh i i think that it is a um
i think that the idea that this is a
problem that that needs solving on the
state level uh doesn't under uh that
that maybe um undermines
the amount of work that we try to do to
bring people together in a community and
to promote that community
so
follow-up so do you feel that
your zoning and planning board can't
make these decisions
without without us
i believe that our zoning board uh and
planning board uh and city council can
make these decisions without
the state of new hampshire making them
for us thank you thank you
representative
i'm going to uh just
a little commentary thank you may i
appreciate it
am i free to go thank you
representative dolan and chairman
we still have uh over 20
folks that want to
address
this issue
and so i would ask the indulgence of the
of the committee
and those people still to speak to be
aware of the fact that
we have a lot
to get through here in the next uh
several hours
so
so please keep that in mind when you're
speaking and and when you're
asking questions
okay next up we have uh representative
burrow
senator
thank you representative thank you
chairman for having us um
and thank you for listening to all this
input today i uh will try to respect
your time
um
for the record my name is senator
rebecca perkins quoca i'm here
representing district 21 which is the
city of portsmouth and the towns of
durham newmarket newfields madbury lee
and newington
i am also here in opposition of the bill
as written and i just have a couple
things that i'd like you to consider as
you
work on the bill although i understand
the purpose behind 249 and that there's
a role in our state's economy for
short-term rentals i'd like you to
consider carefully some of the points
that have been raised so far today i
know the changes made in the senate were
a big improvement to the bill
but i still think that after many years
of debating this issue on a statewide
basis we are still not quite there
on this bill
my mayor from the city of portsmouth
quite eloquently and powerfully made the
case on how short-term rentals
hurt long-term housing supply or have
the potential to do that and so
some models that we've seen work
successfully nationwide are to allow
short-term rentals for example through
permit conditional use permit or special
exception with a capped number of
permits allowed per municipality in this
way local control can allow for the
balance of long-term housing supply and
short-term housing supply
for those of you that don't know me i've
been a housing advocate for over a dozen
years now i've worked very closely on
this issue since 2008 or nine and so
it's something i'm intimately familiar
with and especially the role that zoning
has in our housing supply and so
if you do decide to move forward with
this bill i'd like to raise a couple
points that i think will be important
for you to incorporate
one is really to think about inc
including a provision on owner occupancy
i think that if we had um
language in this bill which allowed us
to address homes that were
only homes that were occupied by the
owner at least for 180 days a year
then the bill would be silent on these
corporate landlords who
are really the concern
we do want to let our homeowners in new
hampshire have control over their
private property property but we also
need to allow municipalities to balance
those rights
with other policy concerns which we let
them do on a regular basis
i also think
if the bill were silent on these
corporate landlords that would allow us
as a state and as a civic body to make
sure we're maintaining
um homeowners who are present in our
town they're part of our civic life
they're our neighbors they run for
office
and so we need to make sure that this
doesn't become a governance issue
on top of everything
secondly
i'd like you to consider adding the
option into the bill of
allowing a municipality to require a
conditional use permit for this use
i don't agree with the new hampshire
association of realtors that this is a
residential use i think it's done for
compensation if you have high turnover
there can be
traffic there can be people in and out
it starts to act more and more like a
commercial activity and the reason that
we have zoning is to allow
municipalities to
place commercial activity in logical
places it's to allow us to have
neighborhoods it's allow to allow us to
plan and create cities that are livable
and um
and pleasant and so
um if you allowed in addition to the
current registration and certificate
that are in the bill
the ability for municipalities to
potentially also require a cup
they could set the parameters for those
to happen and
it would still make a policy statement
that we want to see short-term rentals
as a part of our economy in new
hampshire but and yet strike a balance
with our municipalities being able again
to balance that not only with nuisance
issues but also with long-term housing
supply and quality of life
it's my opinion that nobody here intends
to
run roughshod over the careful and
dynamic work that our towns and cities
have done to zone
zone all of our political subdivisions
and municipalities but
if we move forward with the bill as
written it does allow what is in my
opinion a quasi commercial used to move
into all of our single-family
neighborhoods and i think that's a
discussion that's best had at the local
level so
i will wrap up my comments there and i'm
happy to take any
questions yes representative power
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question i'm
taking notes
and i missed your reference to a cup
could you explain that yes yes
representative thank you so much for the
question so a cup or conditional use
permit
would
would be a tool that municipalities have
to essentially permit short-term rental
as a use and by
enabling that option in the legislation
municipalities commonly
can allow cups for certain uses in
certain zones for example so in a
downtown commercial
district you know short-term rentals
could be allowed by conditional use
permit whereas in other zones they could
potentially be excluded
thank you senator
we greatly appreciate your ability to be
patient with us as our schedule drags on
here a little bit of course i appreciate
all you guys work and i actually will be
back later today to see you so
good luck until then thank you very much
thank you mr chair and thank you for
having me here today and i will be as
brief as i can um first off this is a
happy day for me because representative
umberger and i are in complete agreement
on this bill
um very happy about that
i am strongly opposed to this bill and
i'm strongly in support of short-term
rentals and let me explain that um i
come from a district where it gets i'm
in i represent jackson bartlett and
hart's location
our the mount washington valley gets
about 6 million visitors a year so
short-term rentals are integral part of
our economy
they're a disruptive innovation that are
not going away and i think all of us up
in that area understand the values value
that these units bring to our community
so i'm not here to say that short-term
rental should go away
the issue for me and the issue for most
of my constituents who i've heard who do
not support this bill is whether um is
whether the issue is who should have the
legal authority to regulate short-term
rentals and zoning laws in new hampshire
have gone back almost 100 years and they
have deleted the state has delegated
authority to the towns to make their own
decisions their own zoning con decisions
that are consistent with other states
throughout the country
and
and as we said previously
our valley and as the mayor said the
seacoast are probably the two areas that
are most impacted by this and
i believe that most granite staters
believe that the residents of the town
should have the legal right to make
decisions about short-term rentals and
about how their communities are zoned
and regulated
um we believe that the state shouldn't
be telling municipalities whether or not
there should be short-term rentals
those should be a decision left to those
who live in the communities to determine
the kind of communities and
neighborhoods that they want to live in
and the the mayor also alluded to uh
out-of-state invent investors and i want
to say this isn't a far-fetched idea
because if you look over in neighboring
vermont which has some similar dip
demographic it's a tourist area they are
being heavily um invaded by out-of-state
investor groups so
it's not a far-fetched
fetch neighborhood that's just going to
happen here and that you're going to
have neighborhoods controlled by
out-of-state investor groups
um so i will just again i'll cut this
short because a lot's already been said
um but i'd say for those people in this
community in this hearing who value
freedom um i say let's let's keep our
communities free to like regulate their
own land and i'm hoping that you'll
either amend the bill or um study
committee either of the above so that we
can enable local citizens to retain the
right to create the kind of communities
that they wish them to be thank you i'll
take any questions i'm sorry thank you
thank you
uh next we have uh
carol wallace who is in opposition to
and you have a
a guest with you that is uh actually
it's vice versa
i have carol is my guest thank you so
if you would please intro both of you
introduce yourselves so we can get it
written down
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
i am representative sue gotling from
sullivan district 2
the towns of sunapee and croydon
and i am also in my 11th year as a
member of the select board in sunapee
the emergence of short-term rentals in
sunapee first came to my attention
when our police chief about two years
ago appeared in front of the select
board and said
sunapee we have a problem
he related then the increased calls he
was getting about parking problems and
arguments with our young staff who were
trying to manage the town beach and most
of these were coming from people who
were using short-term rentals and really
did not understand
some of their obligations
the chief had done his research and he
shocked all of us with the number of
short-term rentals in our small town of
3 200 people which at that time was
he
centipede has always been generous to
our homeowners who want to rent and
we've granted those homeowners an extra
beach sticker and a transfer station
sticker
for their renters and usually those
renters in the past have been for two
weeks or for a month that is no longer
true
our overloaded
art well the increasing number of
short-term rental properties plus the
fact that they are generally seriously
overloaded
is putting tremendous pressure on all
our town services
and just as the town began to address
the emerging issues sb 249 was
introduced and i would say stopped us in
our tracks
i will introduce my
fellow member of the select board carol
wallace who will talk to you about those
issues
welcome thank you i am carol wallace and
i am a new member of the select board in
sunapee
and most of what i have in my testimony
has already been said so i'm going to
spare you all the redundancy of it thank
you
yes
what sue did neglect to mention about
our police chief was that he was
assaulted in his own driveway
by an
inebriated guest
of one of these short-term rentals in
our town
that certainly got
the town
put the town on notice
about the severity of the issue when
uncontrolled
you've heard that
large hotel chains are entering the
short-term rental market
again begging the question as to when
does a residential property become a
commercial property
that's a determination in my mind and in
the mind of the select board that
determination should be made at the
local level by zoning officials who live
in the town
and not by a one-size-fits-all approach
which would be legislated by this date
um
i'm looking through my redacted
the enforcement of public safety
measures such as occupancy
limits and parking restrictions would
also be limited by this bill
in summary the residents of sunapee
deserve a safe
orderly
town
in which to live
and they expect their town government to
protect their rights please let us do
the job that we were elected to do
and vote to oppose sb 249.
thank you very much thank you for being
here and thank you for being patient
with your waiting to give you a
testimony oh
my pleasure thank you for hearing my
testimony yes representing your question
thank you mr chair and thank you both
for taking my question to me directed to
both of you you said your police chief
went out to
to address some issues were they local
land use issues were they what were they
local land use issues or ordinances that
adopted by the town or were they
other issues um
they were places where there were folks
who thought that they should be able to
get to the beach even though we might
have said that at that point it was
already at its maximum and they couldn't
understand and they argued a lot about
that and uh and then we had the infamous
uh
incident of harvard sending up a busload
to a
short-term rental right near the harbor
and there were 30 of them in a place
that had what
six bedrooms or something like that and
although they were not drinking and
carousing nevertheless young people
don't want to go to bed early
and so there was a great deal of uh
noise and uh conversation and they're in
a place where they're very very close to
many other residents and one of the
things you might address carol is
that we do have an ordinance
organization now
in centipede
which are people who are short-term
rentals and want to do it right
and so
i'm
very pleased with that and
we don't have any group that is saying
we can't have them
what we're worried about is the
proliferation
almost anywhere and particularly i would
thank you for your
representative power
thank you mr chairman and thank you
ladies for taking my question so is it
true that
a municipality could through zoning
prohibit
a commercial
entity or enterprise from
purchasing property and
using it as a short-term rental
well we we do have zones in in our town
from village commercial to village
residential to
residential you know so
yes i would assume that we that we could
but these are not
called
commercial
the
the short-term rentals are not at
present termed thank you very much for
your testimony and have a safe ride back
home thank you very much next we have
paul mayer
from bartlett
he represents the mount washington
valley association of responsible
renters
hello representatives thank you for
letting me speak today
i'm excited i'm the first one speaking
let me just say that the um short-term
rentals have been part of our community
for forever in
new hampshire
um
the
question that we have
is
you know are they legal
and the answer today is yes
i don't know of any town that says that
renting your house is illegal
on the question of conditional use
permits
um a conditional use permit it takes a
high standard and allows you to
do something it grants you a a lower uh
restrictive level
uh to to do something so take a
residential neighborhood want to put a
gas station in it get a conditional
permit you're allowed to do something
that wouldn't normally be allowed
with a conditional use permit
that's not the case with a short-term
rental
i can let anybody i want use my house
today for a day for an hour it's legal
therefore how can you issue a
conditional use permit for something
that's currently legal in the vast
majority of towns in our state
the other problem with the conditional
use permit
is that it becomes grandfathered once a
conditional use permit is issued
it runs with the land
you don't renew them every year
otherwise no one would build a gas
station in a residential neighborhood
knowing that they would have to renew
every year
there's been a lot of talk about
commercial versus uh residential
and it's easy to pull out the fact that
well someone's getting paid therefore
it's commercial
well
i rent my houses seasonally i get paid
for those those don't become commercial
properties in a neighborhood
long-term rentals
receive compensation for renting their
residential properties that's not a
commercial use under any
stretch of the law
and if i rent the house for a day
and charge a hundred dollars does that
make it commercial
we have two core court cases one in
portsmouth
where in the 16 page
judge's statement at the end of the case
never mentioned the word commercial once
judge ignatius and ruling in
conway clearly stated
this is a residential use in a
residential neighborhood
so
i know people are grasping for straws to
say we need to ban them you know because
you know they're noisy and they're loud
and they park on the streets and
our association totally agrees regulate
them
do whatever you would do with any other
house on the street that was not
performing properly causing problems
having fireworks having you know late
night parties
we have rules and regulations and that's
where local control comes in
sp 29 does not take away local control
in fact it grants the towns additional
control
that they currently don't have in rsas
the the right to register the property
the right to actually walk in and
inspect a property for health safety
that is banned
in new hampshire no one no fire chief
can knock on my door and inspect my
house for life safety issues
um currently and we're granting that to
short-term rentals so we're actually
giving towns more local control not
taking anything away
the only thing that sb249 does
is it says just like we did with
ancillary dwelling units you can't ban
them
you can regulate the hell out of them
you can't ban them
um so i i just think that people need to
you know slow down look at what the law
says
and look about personal property rights
on the final issue
some of the addendums and
i'm sorry amendments that are being put
forth and
the the the wish lists added to this
bill they're all interesting they're
great
but out of one side of the conversation
we hear we want local control we don't
want the state telling us what to do
and then on the other side of the table
people are adding on pages and pages and
pages of
regulations and controls
that the towns are going to have to deal
with that are going to come from the
state
i think the beauty of french's bill was
he kept it clean he just said you can't
ban them
you can do whatever else you want with
them but just like ancillary dwelling
units
you can't ban them they're part of our
community they're part of our
neighborhoods they're part of new
hampshire
so that's all i have to say thank you
well thank you for your testimony
appreciate your patience representative
thank you uh mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
one of the concepts that i'm kind of
grappling with with all this testimony
is
um short-term rentals
um
they're rented let's say by the owner
and let's just say it's a homeowner
let's say it's you
but the intent is that they're rented
for occupancy not to be a home for
someone where a long-term rental is
someone's home
so do you see that a community should
have the interest in
helping to craft their community
and delineate between a home and an
occupancy
it's an interesting question but every
seasonal rentals month-to-month rentals
j-2 and j-1 visa rentals were a huge
part of the new hampshire economy just a
few years ago prior to covet yet
nobody's screaming we don't want
temporary workers to come to new
hampshire and live in these houses on my
street
because they're not full-time residents
i think one of the beauties of america
yes thank you mr chair
um so along those lines do you see
there's also a difference between
somebody a short-term rental let's say
of a few days or a week and a short-term
rental of six months
i think there's a
place for both of them in our economy
obviously short-term rentals are very
positive or
popular
way to vacation nowadays
i'm a little concerned when people talk
about owner occupancy
and vacation rentals
like you know you take a three-bedroom
house on a side street that i own
and a family wants to come up and go to
story land i don't think they want me
yeah um
one more mr chair
well i think with owner occupancy would
would you say that it could be
interpreted that the owner would occupy
that building at some time during a year
not simultaneously with the person
renting it
that is a that's a that's a
comment that has not gotten a clear
answer yet um i obviously think nobody
wants me sleeping in that extra bedroom
that's for sure
but the the nuance of it that needs to
be thought of is if anyone in this room
had a house in bartlett where i live a
ski house or a hiking place
are you really going to spend 186 nights
a year up there
when you have a full-time job
in another town
those those are vacation homes you spend
weekend here a week there whatever and
if you were to set a standard that the
owner has to live in at 180 days is that
realistic and how would you even track
that
okay thank you
representatives davis
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i think you stated in your testimony
that short-term rentals are legal all
over the state is that correct
then why do you need a law
we we don't what the reason that um well
it brings up a very good point obviously
there i live in the white mountains and
we have
four towns currently
with either
severe restrictions on the planning
severe restrictions on short-term
rentals or an outright ban on short-term
rentals
our association is part of the lawsuit
that went towards uh to uh in conway and
we were able to knock that down it's now
at uh superior court
um and we hope to win there
um in madison they had a petition
warrant article to totally ban them in
the town of edelweiss
we intervened there and the town agreed
to rescind the cease and desist orders
there
freedom just voted to
restrict them to 90 days per year
obviously a question of illegal taking
without compensation on the 5th
amendment
you can't just take my property and tell
me i can only use it for 90 days a year
so those are the kind of issues that we
think 249 is going to solve and i think
one important thing that the legislative
branch needs to look at is if you don't
deal with short-term rentals with a bill
like sb 29 that empowers towns to
regulate them you're leaving it up to
a dozen
superior court judges to make a decision
on their own
you guys lose the ability to legislate
follow-up follow-up mr chair well towns
and cities already have the ability to
regulate for all kinds of issues what
what is this bill giving us again it
gives you the right to insist we don't
already have you do not have the right
to come into my house and inspect it for
health and safety
you would have if it was a short-term
rental in the town of bartlett
if sd29 passes
you don't have a right to regulate my
house and ask me who to contact in case
of emergency with sb229
you would have that right and you would
be compensated i would have to pay you
to register my own house as a short-term
rental which allows you to have the
staff
at the town level to regulate
representative matt jury
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i first want to say
that i own
i have properties that i rent out and i
do use
airbnb and others quite often when we
travel so i'm a supporter i'm just also
a big supporter of local control and
that and the responsibilities that
planning boards and select boards have
and my my question goes directly to what
uh representative stavis was just saying
what the bill says is that a town may
may
require
that you meet the minimum housing
standards under rsa 4810
or
the standards for carbon monoxide and
alarms under 153 correct may correct if
you do not what am i inspecting
what
and again
everyone screams local control that's
your local control if you want to do
those things you may
um we're not telling sb you know senator
french isn't saying every town in new
hampshire needs to inspect every
short-term rental for uh
you know carbon monoxide monitors some
small towns might not have the staff to
do that i mean it might be a major issue
to say we're going to go in and inspect
towns again the the the beauty of sv 29
is it gives towns the local control they
may do
what they need to do
everyone asked for the right to inspect
and we gave it to them but we're not
forcing anybody to do anything
okay uh uh you have a follow-up no
representative tripp
thank you mr chair and thank you for
i was scanning through the bill once
again and uh
a question that had been asked
previously by representative power
uh said the i believe this uh
senator french said oh somebody else
will answer that so
on line nine of the first page it that
talks about the building or structure is
conforming or non-conforming do you know
what that means
i am not an expert on on that
statement i believe that was pulled out
of existing legislation
and i believe conforming and
non-conforming would be based on the
fact of if i had a 1820s
farmhouse
it would no longer be conforming to
current code
but since it's a residential property
currently even though it's
non-conforming i could use that property
as a short-term rental and that's simply
a guess from 25 years in real estate and
zoning well it's a much better guess
than i have thank you
thank you
okay representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this is an easy
question i missed your name could you
okay it's a message to the committee
we're we're on pace right now to finish
up around seven o'clock
so uh if you need to take a break
and call somebody to tell them you're
gonna be late
uh don't don't hold dinner for me or
whatever uh
would you i can take a we can take a
five minute break to get that done if
anybody need a break
okay i'll drive on thank you
and thank you for your testimony
next we have john and i'm going to be
having trouble with this name
and john's gonna speak to us uh in the
um
good afternoon i'm john canceller from
madison new hampshire um
i'm going to adjust everything i wish i
went first but a lot of people covered
what i was going to talk about
i i do oppose sb 249 not because i'm for
or against strs the us in them but that
the sp
sp 249 is essentially a statewide um
kind of takeover of local zoning laws
which
is believed to resolve the issue
but the sb-249 being promoted does not
take an account it would not allow local
officials to consider the character of
the districts
several towns are charming each of the
221 towns and 13 cities have different
historical districts environmental
sensitive areas
and established neighborhoods
just recently
i looked up and found online american
strategies this was a 2019
survey
that took vote in new hampshire people
the voters as i stated as it says voters
feel cities and
counties know best when it comes to
creating rental rules and regulations
for their own communities 41 percent
strongly agreed 70 percent totally
agreed
they're also considered by
the argument that local governments
already have the tools to protect public
safety and deal with bad behavior
um
a lot's been talked about so i'll tell
you about um from madison we dealt with
it it's been mentioned before
not the whole story from paul from meyer
we had in madison a lot of debate about
the sb 249 i mean strs and renting on
one side we had article 4 which
essentially what sp249 is
you can rent anywhere you can have up to
16 people in any zone
on the other side we had article eight
this was
what it said is just long term no short
term renting in residential areas
two opposing bills sb249 what happened
the voters voted both down
they didn't agree with the total on
uncontrolled
s you know rentals and the other one
they didn't believe that we should ban
them
what do we do now
well
we all had a meeting and what we're
doing is
like local uh countries local ordinance
we have another meeting we start again
the next year
what we've done too is um it's been
mentioned that we're going to have
potentially form a subcommittee that'll
include not only residents but actually
out of town owners trying to get
everyone together
to talk about it they have every meeting
set up we'll be talking about strs
they're going to handle it
also in june they set up a six o'clock
meeting they're going to have actually
six hours they hope it's done by 12
o'clock to talk about all these issues
what we see here
during this
year before the voting for these two
articles we had more people in our one
town
talking about it than you have here
talking about the whole state this is
just one town the towns need to hear
what the local people are talking about
they need to hear what the local
problems are
they're the ones who can handle it
what's beauty of that is as a
person and as a people there these town
officials are the referees
these town officials
are the therapists for these people
this is a good thing that this has
happened this year we have more people
who went to vote in madison
almost as much as the highest number of
voters that they ever had
so what's it doing it's causing
communities to work together
in the end we're all working together
we're fighting we're arguing we're
debating we're laughing
we had been people held up signs we we
talked to each other we're talking about
the issues we're getting together we
will handle it if we don't hang out this
year what happens
next year we try again these issues can
be resolved on a local level and i do
not think it should be handled on the
state level for
zoning
that's what i have thank you for your
testimony
and your
your patience with us with our schedule
today next we're going to hear from
louise webster
welcome
please be brief
i'm going to be um
i actually have a cleaning service and i
clean for airbnbs
short-term rentals
bvr vrbos whatever you want to call them
and
anything to help
keep short-term rentals around in new
hampshire is going to help my business
because it's based
on short-term rentals
i don't get as many
small
you know
some people want once a month
that's not going to pay the bills
i need something that's going to be
a flip so i can make as much money as i
can to pay my bills and without this i
would not have been able to buy my house
last year
so
it's a little further away than i wanted
but i still work in
north conway bartlett
so
great mr jim yes
go ahead
thank you mr chair thank you for coming
and thank you for taking this what i
hope is an easy question are most houses
well cared for by the people who come
into rent or
i've had some issues
usually when i
tell the owner they take care of that
and
i'll use this for an example okay so i
had a rental that i was uh due to clean
but um airbnb actually stopped it
because they will ban
people that destroyed people's property
um or does something he's got a lifetime
ban he can never rent again so she had
an opening for almost a whole week
because
they do take care of
that for people
thank you you're welcome well thank you
for your testimony ms webster and
have a safe drive back home thank you
next we're going to hear from
she is a
bed and breakfast association
member
good afternoon chairman and fellow
legislators and community members
sitting behind me
my name is tais sinclair i am the owner
nine years now of a bed and breakfast in
little center harbor
i'm also president of the lakes regions
bnb association
and i'm also the owner of two long-term
properties long-term rental properties
i am the neighbor of a seven-bedroom
short-term rental
and i am also the neighbor and
part-time property manager for a
five-room bed and breakfast a
short-term rental right next to my
property
back as far as 2018 i realized that
short-term rentals are
a growing part of our communities
at the time i felt like well if you
can't beat them join them
so i also got listed on airbnb and vrbo
so i'd like to clarify for everyone here
that
vrbo and airbnb are not properties they
are software platforms that allow
homeowners
or property owners
to
list their properties
they do offer significant insurance
programs as an incentive
and when we use the term airbnb it is
the software platform it is not a
property
the term airbnb
uses
the letters b and b in their corporate
name
they are not necessarily bed and
breakfasts
so
most properties short-term rentals
they allow the use of a kitchen
and they are for vacationers staying
short-term
[Music]
they do not provide breakfast like a bed
and breakfast does
so i wanted to clarify that because i
hear these terms used all the time and
90 of the time they're misused
so i have only 10 copies of some
testimony which i will
get distributed somehow here
but i'm not going to read it
i'm going to save time and i'm going to
[Music]
so
and i also brought my business cards to
representative guthrie will take them
oh
so as i have described my role i am very
much in the trenches of this short-term
rental situation
i'm on both sides of the fence
and it impacts not only my business my
livelihood my neighbors my community
which i cherish very much
so
um
from this perspective
um i am
advently against this bill
as it started out as banning short-term
rentals
or not banning short-term rentals i'm
totally against that
now this bill has been sugar coated with
a lot of amendment changes variations
but we're still not there yet it is a
very complex issue and it's not limited
to just new hampshire the whole world
that books through these online vacation
rental platforms
is coping with the same issues
all over the world
in every language
so
the complicated related issues do need
to be further studied
and the gentleman before me had proposed
that there be further
meetings discussions with all parties
represented
i think is the way to go
we cannot pass this bill as it is
currently stated it is going to open up
a can of worms for more problems than it
solves
ultimately what we do end up with though
has to
cover
the following five items
registration has to happen
even as a b b owner i would like to
refer guests that i can't accommodate
myself because i'm fully booked i'd like
to refer them to other places
especially with all the weddings that
castle in the clouds
i can't book any more than i already
have i don't know where to send them
there are no other accommodations
between my place and castle in the
clouds for example
all i can do is refer them to short-term
rentals well guess what i have no idea
where they are who they are
how many people they can accommodate
and so towns need to have registrations
they need to know who the short-term
rental owners are where they are
and how many people they can accommodate
i'd love to have access to that
information
safety and parking in the four plus
years that i've been
neighbors to short-term rentals and
owning properties that i rent out myself
i have to deal with
the following types of issues
underage sex
opioids
drug overdose ambulance that cannot get
to
the residence of my own sister because
the neighbor's property has
about 30 cars parked on the shoulder of
the road and the ambulance can't get
through
that house is only supposed to
accommodate 10 people but there's 30
cars
my sister almost died
fortunately i was able to run up to my
sister's house and save her life before
the ambulance and the medics could get
there
this is reality of what i've had to deal
with
we've had fireworks go off four o'clock
monday morning
the town in dated with phone calls about
what happened with these fireworks going
off
at an ungodly hour
some people thought there was a crash
some people thought a bomb went off some
of my neighbors thought that
we were under attack
somebody had a heart attack because they
were so shocked by the loud boom of the
fireworks at that hour
children were late to school because
their night was disrupted and so forth
other problems include
parking sewer sewer overflow
because there's too many people
in a house that was supposed to only
accommodate
and so
on and on it goes
with the safety and the parking and yes
authorities in town should be able to
conduct an inspection just like bed and
breakfast is i think part of whatever
future law we end up with to take a page
out of what bed and breakfasts have to
qualify for we are inspected we follow
fire codes
we have to have carbon monoxide
detectors smoke detectors we need to
have fire extinguishers we need to have
two
forms of egress from every floor of our
properties
some b and b are some vacation rentals
do offer breakfast or other meals well
why would they be able to offer meals
where b and b's have to have a food
service license
so this is another aspect that has not
been discussed before but if meals are
being offered
water temperature water well testing
dishwasher temperature refrigerator
temperatures ovens and stoves all need
to be inspected in order to get a food
license
noise and events has been discussed
before so i'm not going to
reiterate that
community housing needs have also been
mentioned earlier today
but another aspect is the impact of so
many vacation rentals on the existing
accommodations that our communities have
personally i'm very much in favor of
every type of accommodation being
available to visitors and residents of
new hampshire but there has to be a
balance right now the bmb
community is suffering from the vacation
rental
properties popping up all over the place
and i am particularly worried about the
most recent acquisition where bayside
rentals in meredith is now owned and
controlled by marriott homes
so that means
that the large corporations the big
hotels can come in and operate through a
third party and take over neighborhoods
this is not okay
this cannot happen in new hampshire
now
i'm sure my five minutes is up however
there is another speaker
um who
was not able to stay because of the
schedule change
so i am now representing heidi mildred
millbread
she is currently owner of a b b in
bristol
she's president of the new hampshire
statewide b b association
and she also sits on the board of the
new hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
she asked me to read her statement which
will only take a few minutes
in keeping has been around since before
jesus birth
we innkeepers have a long and storied
history but thanks to a few senators
they want to see our livelihood pushed
to the side
so
much of new hampshire being a great
place to run a small business it seems
not to be the case
sb 249 says that anyone with a single or
double family home may rent it out for
money with no regulations license or
enforcement sure the bill includes
language that towns may
adopt an ordinance require owner
residency who wishes to utilize the
property for
vacation rental
and to file registrations with the town
the town or municipality may adopt an
orient an ordinance which
inspection of property is determined if
the property meets the minimum housing
standards
the town or municipality may enforce and
regulate and may collect a fee for
enforcing this
the municipality may establish a
reasonable fee to cover the cost to the
town
but it's doubtful that all communities
can actually be able to do this
many small towns make up tourist areas
the whole state is a tourist area
can we really believe that small towns
are going to be able to come up with the
money so that they can hire somebody to
enforce zonings and codes over and above
what they're already doing
a person that lists their house for rent
does not even need to be on site
they can be in another town state or
country
how's that going to work when the police
show up for a keg party
according to the definition found in rsa
chapter 1
bed and breakfast means a building or
buildings regularly used and kept open
as such in a bona fide manner for the
feeding and lodging of transient gas a
bed and breakfast shall have at least
four rentable rooms an area for dining
capable of accommodating the number of
guests
it is housed it is the primary residence
of the owners and is our operators
and
has posted room rates that includes
breakfast
to become a legitimate b b in new
hampshire one needs to hit certain
benchmarks we have to live on site we
we need to register the name with the
state
we have to collect the 8.5 meals and
rental tax with a tax license number we
need to have our kitchens inspected and
licensed on a side note many airbnbs
vrbo short-term rentals are serving food
and it's just not regulated
we need to carry commercial insurance
rumor has it that airbnb offers hosts
we need to be hardwired to the fire
departments we have alarm systems we
have sprinkler systems these are all
required
some b and b's have to get their boilers
inspected as well
so if this bill passes rsa 175.1
becomes obsolete i simply i will simply
stop paying for all fees license taxes
and become a short-term rental
under this law
and
i'm out of the b and b business
so it will impact
an industry that's been here in new
hampshire for a very long time is very
much part of our culture
sb 249 is cloaked as allowing a person
with a second home to rent it for a week
or two to help pay their property taxes
if passed the bill is going to be a
nightmare for towns and neighborhoods
under this bill
anybody could buy up property anywhere
and turn them into short-term rentals
and
the towns really can't do anything about
it unless they violate
potential registrations inspections
and ordinances
this bill would give me an absolute
right to rent my three bedroom house to
twenty thirty 100 people unless it's
regulated or worse every affordable
house
i'm on the last sentence i promise my
colleague who has attended many of these
meetings that i would read this
or worse every affordable house that a
working family might purchase will be
bought and turned into short-term
rentals by a group with a pool of cash
sort of makes you wonder what kind of
so i reiterate the example of the
marriott
now owning bayside rentals
and buying up properties in the lakes
region
and it's all business it's all money
making nothing to do with the
communities
yes thank you mr chair i have a process
question um i appreciate
members of the public coming to provide
testimony are we able to
ask questions of the
person
[Music]
who provided this written testimony
are we able to ask questions here today
uh you can but the person that wrote
this testimony is not here to ask a
question there were two testimonies
passed out i'm the author of the first
one and i'll gladly answer any questions
and i can help facilitate my point is is
there are people here present who have
waited and are here there is a process
by which if someone is not here they may
submit their written testimony to the
committee so um i'm just confused about
what i just heard
okay thank you
is there
are there any questions regarding the
testimony that i submitted the first one
okay
we have no questions for you i
appreciate your patience and your
testimony thank you very much thank you
next we have bill
dempster
if i say that right yes you did it
i have coffees here sure
mr chair
i have my phone here that has a
three-minute timer perfect
so if you bear with me for three minutes
i have a statement to read
my name is bill dempster i am from
madison new hampshire
there's been a lot of testimony here but
i'm just going to reiterate some points
and i bring up some new points for you
airbnb and vrbo are two multinational
corporations they brought short-term
rentals to the mainstream america making
it easier to invest in transient
vacation rentals
according to industry
statistics the average annual
revenue for an str unit located in
that's a significant amount of money
that would certainly help explain the 16
conversion rate of recently sold
single-family residential homes that
were not strs that went over to str's
this is over a 14-month period starting
in january of 2021.
interestingly the greatest fear of
owners operators investors and realtors
driving this multi-billion dollar
short-term rental industry is not
parking tickets it's not registration
fees not misdemeanor fines or even
property inspections
these are simply considered the cost of
doing business
according to the 500 discussion boards
that i went and reviewed in many str
forums such as airbnb community bigger
pockets and tripadvisor
the greatest fear is two words local
zoning
new hampshire rsa 672-679 enables
municipal government to more effectively
meet the demands of evolving and growing
communities these rsas permit local
residents to be actively involved in
directing the growth of their community
with a workable framework for fair and
reasonable treatment of individuals
on a personal note prior to living in
madison my family lived in the same
national home for over 35 years
our budding residential neighborhood of
12 homes
was heavily involved in determining the
redevelopment of a brownfield site
and preventing a 106 unit conor
development on a postage stamp lot using
local zoning ordinances
regulation via local zoning ordinances
work
sbr 249 sidesteps the state statutes i
mentioned above and removes local
residents from the decision process
using the most powerful tool local
zoning
one size does not fit all the 235
municipalities must remain autonomous
and allow the local residents to control
their own community's destiny i
encourage you to vote no on sb249 thank
you thank you for your testimony uh two
minutes and 45 seconds excellent nice
job you you win the prize
i don't know about that but
any questions
since there are no questions i'm gonna
thank you very much i'm going to call
kathy
coziel
i've got my coffee here you can correct
and i can change good form
and you oppose the bill i do and i'm
going to change this from good morning
house committee members to good evening
yes so thank you again house committee
members for allowing the public to speak
um
i had a two-page
written testimony but i think i'll boil
it down to a couple of points
i've read sb 249 numerous times i
watched the whole four-hour senate
hearing and for clarification when they
talk about the rights that they're
giving to the towns to regulate
short-term rentals one of them is to
allow the towns to have a contact
the contact is only for legal service
it's not a contact where you can call up
the phone and say hey look dude there's
15 guys at your house throwing beer
bottles out the window so that contact
person is not allowed under sb 249 the
inspection that they so graciously allow
the towns to do is only the initial
inspection when they register if a year
down the road the house's decks are
falling off and windows are broken you
have to take the owner to court in order
to do an inspection unless they agree to
do the inspection so those two things
advantages that they give to the
municipalities but they're very limited
the biggest problem with sp 249 and with
short-term rentals is occupancy the
problem is that it does not allow you to
limit the occupancy
in a home the the the stories that we
heard from sunapee where there's 35
students singing a seven bedroom house
um
we have a thread three bedroom home up
in our neighborhood that advertises for
16 occupants without the town's ability
to limit occupancy that's where all the
other problems stem from is is over
occupancy
commercial use versus residential use
been a lot of discussion about that
someone came up with a great analogy and
i believe it was margaret so i might uh
step on her her story here a little bit
but as a quick example when you invite
six people to your house and you serve
them dinner and wine and dessert that's
a residential use when you advertise in
the paper that you're going to be
charging them for those meals to come to
your home and you bill them per person
for those meals it is now a restaurant
that is how an str is equated you're
charging a per night rate to come and
sleep in your home you are now creating
a business
um
the average str in north conway 39
500 is the average amount of money that
those str's take in
what retail worker restaurant worker or
teacher could ever afford 39 000 a year
in rent that's why the conversion from a
home that was residential and
potentially rented to a short-term
rental
the commercialization of short-term
rentals there is a company it's called
re-alpha so just like alpha male
re-alpha they're a
public company they're amassing money
and they have a plan
they're already in the process of
purchasing 15 000 short-term rentals
they're starting in dallas they're going
to miami they're going to chicago then i
believe they're going to colorado so our
little town in new hampshire will have a
target on its back in no time so if we
don't put local regulations in place to
control that we're just rolling out the
red carpet and trying to deal with
something five years down the road that
the town should have dealt with
currently
that's all i have to say thank you very
much
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for this witness
i see none thank you thank you
how do you okay good how are you doing
good thank you
uh thank you for taking
allowing me to speak
today
a lot of the stuff that everyone's been
is most of the things that i had already
thought you know was in my
rep what i wanted to put ahead
but i'm going to say some of the things
to
get the points across of what
i feel is
hurting and why this bill should not be
passed
the towns that have the
towns that are having this issue with
the boom of short-term rentals have been
regulated them using the existing
ordinances and master plan guidelines as
we all know each town has zoning
ordinances in place for a reason
a century ago the u.s supreme court
ruled
in favor of zoning
in it stands today
that alone is the reason not to put this
bill through
the boom going on with str's and
vacation areas are taking away the
affordable housing
the cost of renting and purchasing
a home
the mount washington valley
area businesses
have been reducing hours of operation
and closing midweek due to lack of
workers caused by the lack of affordable
housing
63 percent of identified str owners do
not reside in our town
or our state
don't be fooled by the millions of
dollars they will be telling you
that we're going to lose
most of the lodging income already
leaves the state
the entire process of pushing the senate
bill was most disturbing some of these
senators are involved in real estate
businesses and it seems that they are
the extension of the new hampshire board
of realtors on top of that
the final vote was done by roll call
this way the public would not know how
the senators voted
one
personal experience
last summer my wife asked me to go down
to the garden i walked down
opened my door
and right in front of me
was a complete stranger in my backyard
i asked him what's he doing here
he said i'm just taking pictures
then
i said where where you from he says well
i'm renting the house across the street
only for a couple of days
i said this is private property you need
at that moment i paused for a second and
i thought about
what would have been
if my
young granddaughter was sent down by my
how do you think that made me feel how
this bill will take away the housing it
will take away the ability for their
towns to control their own environment
and on top of that it'll take the
availability
of making me feel safe
and comfortable in my own backyard what
about my
property rights this bill should not be
passed the way it is right now
thank you for your time
thank you
appreciate it
any question
okay
bob quinn and sarah holland from the new
welcome
thank you very much good afternoon thank
you
so my name is sarah holland i am a
can you hear me now yes hi
my name is sarah holland i am a realtor
i own a company in plymouth new
hampshire and i am a landowner property
owner as well and i'm here in my
capacity as the vice chair of the public
policy committee for nhar to share our
support in this bill and to answer any
questions that you may have about it and
its
well thank you for
making your comments brief
we're in a little bit of a schedule snag
okay so my name is bob quinn i'm the ceo
of the new hampshire association of
realtors thank you for uh
listening to us this afternoon excuse me
so
rsa the first part of the bill deals
with rsa 674 so that's the power
that has been granted to municipalities
for zoning
we think of zoning most of the time you
think of the use of a property or
structure
so if
a someone wants to put a restaurant or a
barber shop
into a residential neighborhood
the municipalities have complete
authority to dictate that that's not
permissible
it's a commercial activity and they are
clearly given regulatory authority to
prohibit or ban those
so when we come to short-term rentals
and i'll use um justice ignatius
comments in her case when she overturned
conway's ban on short-term rentals
she indicated those are that a
short-term rental is a residential use
of the property
therefore because it's a residential use
of the property municipalities do not
have authority
to prevent someone who owns a
residential property from not using it
in that way
so
and it's not just judge ignatius who
came up with the decision that these are
residential uses of the property
this issue has gone to a variety of
state supreme courts around the country
texas washington idaho wisconsin
colorado and georgia
have also ruled that it's a residential
use
why
what i'm going to do when i go home
have dinner
i'm going to talk to the kids talk to
the family
watch some television go to bed maybe
invite some friends over for a beer
that's exactly what someone who's using
a short-term rental is going to do so
it's a residential use of that property
now whether or not you agree or disagree
and be honest with you it doesn't even
may not matter what judge ignatius's
ruling is because this is now going to
go to the state supreme court
and if the state supreme court rules
that it is a residential use of the
property
then all the municipal authority that
we've been talking about now
um they're not going to have any more
you're not going to be able to register
you're not going to be able to inspect
in the same way that my private property
the government can't come in
and say i want to inspect your house
you know after it's already been built
so
the the
the consequences of doing nothing
unfortunately and we would say
unfortunately
is probably going to lead to a sort of a
winner take all decision here they're
either going to be residential municipal
authorities gone or they're going to be
ruled commercial
in which towns cities and towns can do
whatever they want to them
what we've tried to do with this piece
of legislation is to try to come up with
some sort of middle ground here that
everyone can try to agree with
and i just to go over a couple of points
because we hear a lot about how the bill
is removing a town's ability to regulate
short-term rentals
specifically in the bill on line 12-14
it says nothing in this paragraph shall
limit a municipality's existing
authority to generally regulate parking
noise safety health sanitation or other
related municipal ordinances
now every time someone brought up a
different potential ordinance we
included it
all right so if there's anything else
you think we missed that wouldn't be
included we're more than happy to put
into that so that towns have authority
to regulate
now
it what we're saying on the the rest of
it which is rsa 31 which grants towns
different regulatory authorities under
the police powers
is you can require registration that
language is pulled directly from
statute that exists currently that if
you many people don't realize this but
if you rent long term
you are mandated actually this is a may
that you're mandated to register with
your town so that they have someone who
they can reach out to uh if they needed
to
to provide service to so it's the same
concept and a town can
initiate a fee in order to do that
registration excuse me mr quinn uh some
of that testimony has been mentioned
before if you could if it has been
mentioned before could you please uh
sure go on further because so then the
second piece is also new it has to do
with it with an inspection so that's
specifically prohibited in rsa 153 i
noticed the fire marshal was here
earlier i had a conversation with him
several months ago
about that issue and we ensured that
and came up to an agreement on this that
uh inspection would be granted they
could look for the same things you would
look for in a long-term rental that's an
rsa 48 a14 in addition there's existing
requirements that if you do a rental you
have to have a smoke detector and a co
detector so you can do the same thing if
a town so chooses it's not a mandate if
town chooses they don't want to inspect
it they don't have to
and then just as importantly
what i think the question was what do
you do
if a large someone does something a
company or
an owner of a property were to do
something
what recourse would the town have the
town has the recourse under legislation
to revoke the registration deny them
that opportunity to continue to
short-term rental right so that's again
something that we do not believe towns
currently have the authority to decide
and to dictate
quickly um you guys passed a law um last
year that mandates airbnb vr bureau and
all the other platforms have to collect
and remit
their rooms and meals tax
what that has done is increased rooms
and meals tax revenue because now
everyone does it
in this budget cycle that's going to
mean directly from short-term rentals
about 40 million dollars
so if towns are allowed to ban them
those dollars are going to start to
decrease and if it becomes widespread
it's eliminated
judge ignatius in her case in her
decision
wrote
that
this question
cries out for legislative direction
based on statewide policies promoting
commerce competition regulatory throat
control and municipal oversight she was
basically pleading with the legislature
to do something if not
it's not just going to be portsmouth and
conway it's going to be town after town
after town that's been embroiled in
these lawsuits
there's an opportunity here to clarify
once and for all
very few communities in the state of new
hampshire ban short-term rentals
it's very few
all right
so what we're just saying is it's an
important private property right in the
past this legislature has made decisions
on rsa 674
you did it on housing affordability
workforce housing accessory dwelling
units
you then won a couple years ago and
involuntarily merged lots there's a
whole host of them where the legislature
has stepped in on 674 altered that and
put mandates on the town because there
was some overriding uh principle and the
principle we're trying to protect here
is private property rights when you
purchase a property you get a bundle of
rights it's the way law school they
might describe it
one of those
sticks that you get is the ability to
rent out your property if one of those
is removed the value of that property is
decreased
so we would encourage you to support 249
[Music]
excuse me one second i may want to let
sarah speak first and she might answer
some of your questions
i may
okay please make it brief if it's
already been covered just skip right by
it sure so there were a couple of
questions that were earlier that i'd
like to clarify um brought before this
committee and the first
relative to condos and
ccnrs so the covenants and restrictions
and whether or not this is going to
remove their right
to regulate short-term rentals within
their community
currently the ccnrs those are things
that are presented to potential buyers
ahead of time they're very transparent
everybody knows what is going to occur
in those communities what the rules and
regulations are and then they opt in so
this is not taking anything away from
that they've already made that decision
that they are okay with those
regulations when they move into that
right now
well
in in that same vein
everyone in that community has a right
to vote on any changes to those ccnrs
currently in our private communi in our
public communities
the voting rights are only for
primary resident owners
only so
these changes that are being made on a
local level are being made not by
everyone who has a stake in that
community
such as condo associations and the
transparency with the ccnrs they're
being made by the few that are there as
the other thing is um we had talked
about
the housing crisis and we're all going
to get into that a little bit more later
in the day probably around dinner time
but
banning short-term rentals are not going
to bring back the number of houses in
the inventory that we need
a lot of those short-term rentals are
owned
in contradiction to what has been said
today by individuals like you and me so
if they are not able to do short-term
rentals and they use that in some form
throughout the year they're just not
going to rent at all they're going to
keep the property the property is going
to stay vacant until they decide to use
it whether it's for the summer holiday
or for vacations or whatnot so
by banning short-term rentals that is
not going to help our
housing crisis
and also there was a comment made about
the ownership types of llcs and
individuals like you and i can own
property in an llc a trust or many other
forms and that is not an indication that
they are owned by large faceless
corporations
okay thank you for your testimony
appreciate it
mr
gallery so um
the there's a point made about
fiscal impact from the um
from the rooms and meals tax
that
might be had here
i'm wondering if you know
why
that figure isn't included as a fiscal
note
to
well
if if
short-term rentals are banned in
communities um
it would i think
lead to
less rooms and meals revenue but that's
not what this is we're trying to protect
short-term rentals so it would protect
those dollars
um
and getting into the issue of sort of
local control um
i guess the only i leave you with
because if if you do have that well
local controls supersede private
property rights
if town a
makes the determination that they're
going to ban short-term rentals
that does not eliminate the desire and
demand for visitors to come to new
hampshire to vacation they're still
going to want to come to our lakes in
our mountains seacoast
so what that's going to do now is
someone who lives in town b which is
adjacent to say okay
i think you know if
now because a won't allow it i used to
be able to get 1500 a week now i can get
2 000. that's going to incentivize me to
say okay now i'm going to put a
short-term rental in my town
and i think that the state role is to
ensure at least minimal private property
protections
for everybody if a town wants to
regulate them have at it
go for it
inspections registrations
if someone is
consistently violating noise ordinances
remove that registration and ban them
from doing it
all we're trying to do is ensure that an
individual private property rights are
protected
thank you okay
one question
from everyone and then we're finished
okay
you mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um mr quinn at the beginning of your
remarks you said how
you go home you have dinner you talk
with your kids whatever and that's no
different than
someone who's
using
a short-term rental that it's the same
but do consider the whole topic of
domicile to distinguish between those
two
you mentioned also individual property
rights but what we've heard testimony
already is that there's a lot of big
corporations buying
homes and using them for short-term
rentals so i'm having a hard time
seeing
i i see there is a difference between
short-term rentals long-term rentals
short-term rentals owned by
someone who makes that place their
domicile at least part of the year and
and one that's owned by a company so i'd
appreciate you clarifying that
so um
i guess i can answer that question by
saying again
i guess my opinion doesn't particularly
matter what we're trying i'm trying to
get is
the the court is looking at this it's a
legal question and the legal question is
is it a residential use of the property
if it is determined as a residential use
of the property as judge ignatius stated
then municipal is a residential use of
the property as judge ignatius stated
then municipalities do not have the
authority
in the same way that your residents or
my residents that they can somehow come
in i'm not renting anything out at all
and say what we want you to register
your home with our you know register
with the town or we're going to come and
inspect your property
so the key question is residential
versus commercial everyone might have an
opinion but the only opinions that going
to really matter are the supreme court
the folks across the
river
i would also say
that laconia in 2019 banned short-term
rentals in parts of that community
there are more short-term rentals now
than there were before the ban
portsmouth was in earlier talking
portsmouth banned short-term rentals
there are more short-term rentals now in
portsmouth than there were before the
ban portsmouth has stated the only way
they enforced
the ban is if a neighbor complains and
then they go investigate so imagine
you've been renting out your home for 30
years
all your neighbors think you're great no
problem whatsoever now a new neighbor
moves in
and they don't like it
and they call the town now what you've
been doing for 30 years might be taken
away from you and you need that income
in order to keep yourself in the home
or
potentially pay for your college at your
kids college education and that's what
you're relying upon for your retirement
that's the reason why private property
rights are so important in this issue
and the reason why we believe the state
needs to step in to ensure
that at least
brief question please
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question pertains
to page two
line two
with regard to the um
the phrase proven violations of
ordinances and my question is what
exactly constitutes
a proven violation of an ordinance
what is the due process and what body
so if a town for instance has a noise
ordinance
and you
violate that news or noise ordinance
and you receive a summons and
usually when you get summons you either
plead guilty or you go into the court
you try and plead it out you argue it if
the court deems you are guilty then
that's a proven violation of an
ordinance
so it can't just be a complaint you
can't just have a neighbor saying hey
they were loud and the police show up
and say they weren't loud
that wouldn't be a proven violation
any other questions
mr maturi representative maturi thank
you so much mr chair thank you for
taking my question my question is
do you um
do you see any
problem with the town putting
conditions on the registration and i and
and i the example i would give
if
they are allowed to do an inspection
and they go in and determine this house
has
five bedrooms the septic is sized four
therefore your registration comes with a
limit of x number of people over the
course of a year do you see where that
could uh that could be permitted could
be allowed that's a great question so
first of all
and that came up earlier i think someone
said oh you have 20 people if the town
nothing in this legislation restricts
the town from le from regulating the
number of people who are
utilizing a property and if a town
wanted to put that as part of a
registration requirement
i think that they would have the
authority under the language currently
written if you feel more comfortable in
putting something specific in there
that's fine that's
that was certainly
seeing no further questions i'm going to
uh thank you both for being here thank
you
paul mckenna are you still here come on
up
paul is going to speak against the bill
and i'm going to ask you paul to please
i'm going to read a letter to the editor
of the conway sun maybe you could swing
that microphone closer sorry
can you hear me now okay i'm going to
lead read a letter to the editor of the
conway sun
it's by mr dave van noyt
from kearsarge
to the editor
realtor paul mayer writes in this paper
that he's worried about potential lies
being spread about sb 249
regarding short-term rentals
well
no need to lie
as all one has to do is read the bill
to see what would deprive all voters
in every town in new hampshire
of their right to govern strs
in their community
if mr mayor is concerned about someone
spreading lies
he need only look at his own words and i
quote
it doesn't take away a town's right to
regulate vacation rentals
it most certainly does
the analysis of the bill that mayor
provides states and again i quote
this bill prohibits municipalities
from adopting ordinances
read the actual bill and it's clear
it absolutely strips voters of their
rights to limit short-term rentals in
their communities
mayor also states
it's a bipartisan compromise that the
vast majority of the locals have been
asking for
utter nonsense
we are these where are these locals
who have been asking the state to strip
away the rights of the registered voters
to determine how to govern their
communities
i certainly do not know any do you
in the 1920s the united states supreme
court ruled that voters in a community
have the right to establish residential
and commercial areas in their towns to
determine what commercial activities are
permitted in these residential areas
this ruling has been reaffirmed by the
courts countless times
in the ensuing decades
sb 249 would strip every voter in every
community in new hampshire of that right
and turn dwelling units house condos or
townhouses into a potential str
that's correct
if this becomes law every dwelling unit
in your town could be a potential motel
like sdr
jackson residents voted to allow
non-owner-occupied ncrs in their
residential areas
conway and kearsarge voters required
strs in residential areas to be owner
occupied and
operated while different in every case
it is cl clear
expression of the voters will
if sb 249 becomes law it will block and
deny and disallow
that honored and revered right for
voters to choose
so who benefits from sb 249
the tiny percentage of new hampshire
residents who own and operate stis or
service them
some realtors and a lot of people who
don't live in new hampshire
no need to conjure up lies about sp 249
as written
i personally have had a home in madison
for 34 years
we're surrounded by sdrs
in the village district of idaho ice
there are 84.
there's 171 that the town knows about
the str that's beside me catered to pets
people would come
they'd leave four dogs in the house
and go shopping for four hours the dogs
would
bark like you wouldn't believe
i have had
fireworks going off at three o'clock in
it's it's definitely a business people
here say it's residential the portsmouth
case
said
it's not residential these are people
making money
okay it's a business
and
i ask you all one question
would you like one of these beside you
that are uncontrollable frat houses
i had a hockey team come
next door
18 hockey players 10 cars
in a four bedroom house
you can't control these things
thank you that's all i have to say i
appreciate your time thank you for your
testimony appreciate it
thank you
mr chair my point of order is
should we ask or can we ask
people who are here
and testifying before us if they have
written testimony
whether it's written by them or written
by someone else that they turn the
written testimony in and just testify
before us did you all hear that if you
if you have written testimony you could
just pass that testimony in rather than
read it to us
we'll make copies and uh and read it
ourselves and
and can i add it doesn't mean i don't
want to hear your testimony i want to
hear your testimony we all do
i don't need you to read me your
testimony i want you to speak to me
thank you
okay next we we're going to hear from
[Music]
road in north conway and she opposes the
bill
you've asked for five minutes because
yes
to cut that weight back
i will my name is lynn
as mrs umberger said earlier in
1957.
in 1957 the kearsarge lighting precinct
adopted zoning we were the first zoning
in the state of new hampshire for the
purpose to preserve our rural charm and
natural beauty associated with our
village
i've been a commissioner since 2013.
our zoning ordinance as we said earlier
does not it
allows short-term renting but it must be
owner occupied i did bring copies of our
zoning ordinance
it's article five
on page five and it's letter d
um
we were sued in kearsarge by um a
short-term renter where hui
sent them a cease and desist order um
actually they live across the street
from me and living next to a
short-term renter is your worst
nightmare
it took three years to go to court
we spent over a hundred thousand dollars
defending our zoning ordinance not to
mention the aggravation of having to put
up with these commercial establishments
[Music]
patiently
we have waited the three years for judge
ignatius to hear and rule
on this case
and she did she ruled in our favor and
we had a second lawsuit brought against
us and she ruled in that favor as well
um there's just one thing i do want to
read off the back of this
i've lived in our current home for 25
years with my husband and raised our
children there my parents purchased land
in the 60s saved money and when i was 10
years old they built their dream home in
in a wonderful neighborhood in the
kearsarge lighting precinct
there is no other place i want to live
and my neighbors share the same sediment
our neighbors have relied on our local
government to protect our community
so far we've been able to preserve our
surrounding and commun surroundings and
community and our victory in superior
court proves the dedication to the cause
it is the will of the people who should
decide
not the people who don't live here and
not the people who only want to profit
thank you
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony do you have a paper you could
leave with us i can leave you a copy of
our next uh
we'll next hear from
matt johnson
from bedford new hampshire that happened
he met matt left okay
he supports the bill and i know you want
to speak for five minutes but i'm going
to ask you to try to hold it to one i'll
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
theodore bolson from berlin
i am an attorney licensed in
massachusetts i have an mba know
something about business and economics i
came back to my family's home state in
new hampshire
eight years ago i took over a dormant
dairy farm turned it into a short-term
rental and i raised goats and chickens
there
i'm probably the number one taxpayer in
the city of berlin
the short-term rental provides fills
those coffers i
am paying the room and meals tax to the
state
i understand from prior testimony
there's 40 million coming in i'm
part of that
i want to let you know that in six years
of doing this i've never had a complaint
from a neighbor
no complaint from anybody has been ever
filed with me or the or the city of
berlin why because i responsibly manage
my short-term rental
what 249 does
is require responsible management
you cannot have more regulatory power
then requiring a permit and having the
ability to revoke it
it's
on two violations
and you're gone
think about that i don't care whether
it's a marriott corporation or a small
business person
or a homeowner
if there are two violations in the city
or town wants to yank that permit you
are gone that
i was i will tell you that virtually
every single complaint you've heard here
today
and everyone you're going to hear
relates to violations of ordinances and
bylaws in the town that relate to noise
public activity curfews trash
sanitary code violations all of which
are regulable
and if you have the power in the
municipal municipality to revoke that
permit
on two violations you can stop it and if
you can summons into a legal proceeding
even in the town or city
somebody
is not going to
say no to that you can send a civil
process have them
grabbed and hauled in of course they're
going to respond and be responsible you
can take you can charge a permit fee to
pay for this monitoring and the
inspections this is tremendous power at
the local level the only thing it does
not allow you to do is an outright ban
on this activity lastly i will tell you
that we
short-term rental people are driving the
economy
in the tourist economy in new hampshire
right now we're the goose that's laying
the golden egg
if you do not pass this bill in some
form what's going to happen is the
message to all of us is we are fair game
for the big high rollers because we are
the affordable housing
of accommodations the accommodations
industry families who can't afford
several hotel rooms and going out to
restaurants for every meal they're
coming to us
that and and they come to us and and
they
nonetheless spend their disposable
income in our communities and
we
are generating a tremendous
economic boost to this state that's
going to go away if we don't have the
assurance that we can invest safely
without tomorrow the big moneyed
interest who often control the boards
and get their people on the boards in
every town and city
turn around and say okay we've had
enough for you and they can drum up all
kinds of excuses but the real issue is
we compete with them and they want that
business attorney boson uh i appreciate
your passion i'm sorry and uh
i'm hot-headed greek what can i
congratulate you on running a
complaint-free business uh i wonder if
we have
we could take one question i'll take as
many as you want
diane power
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um my question pertains to page two
roman numeral three is there anything in
the framework of this bill that
prohibits an owner of this short-term
rental from reapplying and re therefore
re-registering
after the registration has been revoked
i think that that's up to how the town
the town or city can craft the
permitting
ordinance as they see fit
i think this leaves certainly room for
that
so if in
if you've been revoked and the town of
city gives a certain
um
you know period
for which you cannot reapply i don't see
any reason that this is prohibited by
the by the uh the bill i'd also add that
non-conforming use which there was much
debate about is not even in here if you
read it it talks about non-conforming
structures that's a whole different
ballgame that simply means that a
building that hasn't been used and the
zoning is changed or maybe requiring
more of a lot coverage or a different
setback regime that that cannot be used
to
prohibit the
the use of the building as a short-term
rental it's not about a non-conforming
use at all
um
thank you for the question
thank you uh attorney rosa bozen are you
headed back to berlin
i'm actually uh heading back to
massachusetts to see family i figured
i'm halfway there have a safe drive
thank you very much thank you very much
for your your time
okay next is allison
rose
she's not here
uh
nathan fennessy
right here
i'm going to just talk about one
thing because it's a it's a relevant
issue and i hope you'll read my
testimony because i spent a lot of time
on it we certainly will i am
the chair of the freedom planning board
i'm entering my 15th year in that
position
freedom is a small town just about 1700
people
southeast of conway if you've never
heard of it or been there
and we are on ossipee lake and over half
of the homes in freedom
are second homes
so we started a year ago to try to
address the issue of what to do about
short-term rentals
and we set a goal
same thing to try to strike a balance
between the people who said
i don't want a stream of strangers as
neighbors
and the people who wanted to rent out
their houses as short-term rentals
and we wanted to pay
particular
attention to people who have had summer
homes and freedom
sometimes for generations
who wanted to rent out their houses
so that they could pay taxes and keep
these homes in their families
we also wanted to figure out a way to
avoid having investors who wanted to buy
up homes rent them out at a profit
from
coming to freedom and creating many
hotels in our residential neighborhoods
we chose and the voters approved to
limit short-term rentals to 90 days a
year
we don't
we talked about whether we would do only
owner-occupied rentals that's not our
market the people who are renting their
houses out
as short-term rentals and freedom are
are not living in freedom they're second
homeowners and we looked at the
taxes the assessed value in town what
people were getting a night for
short-term rentals
what the mortgage rates were
and running the numbers we figured out
that at 90 days people could pay their
taxes their insurance
and a decent sized mortgage
over the 90 days
it's profit and we wanted to stop
investors from coming in and if you look
at the numbers
at a home that's rented at 250 dollars a
night
for
300 days
after you pay
the cost of your
mortgage you're making a huge amount of
money
50 70 000 a year every year
we we took an approach that's different
from the one that you've been asking
about which is we'll just make them
owner occupied
we said let's find a way for our
property owners who are
second homeowners who want some revenue
but we did it by
restricting it and we did
have it passed
and
i hope
you will consider among other things
grandfathering
the
regulations that towns already have in
place
when this law goes into effect
because we have worked for a year and we
i think we have a good plan i'm sure
their people are going to tell me
they're going to sue us about it
but
if it's going to pass i hope you will
weigh the interest of
all of the people in the towns
and and give us a break thank you so
much for your testimony and thank you
for being patient with us
john i know you've asked for five
minutes i'd like to yep
shorten that as much as you can no i
don't repeat what everyone has said
thank you for allowing me to speak today
um
just like several of the previous
speakers i have a airbnb that started
next door to me
it was rented out every weekend
different people coming for a couple of
days there'd be 12 people it's a 2500
square foot branch there'd be 12 cars
so someone's saying this is just a
normal house next to you it's not this
is not how normal houses are you don't
have different people piling in 12 cars
every friday night making loud noises
having their dogs running your yard
going to your back door when you go to
answer it
walking through your yard those are
things when you have neighbors you work
out you say
yeah you can walk my dog or not
i'd love to see my back door or not but
if you have different people every
weekend you have no relationship they're
not part of the community
they're just strangers
they're there for their two days they're
there for their party they're there for
their grandmother's party they're there
for their bachelor party they're there
for their girlfriend's party they're
there for their whatever party it is
and one of the reasons there is because
it is affordable
there's 12 of them there they spend 20
and they get to spend the weekend
so there's it's not a competing with a
hotel it's it's bringing in large
numbers of people to take advantage of a
neighborhood that's quiet
and totally disrupt what's a normal
neighborhood
in dublin we've passed an ordinance two
years ago
we have uh
cups we have special exceptions and we
have a minimum of two week rentals for
non-owner occupants
so what we call a short-term transient
rental is under two weeks and that's
banned for non-resident
and that has controlled the problem
entirely the problem here is
these weekend kind of overloaded visits
with tons of people piling in
it's not people renting out their houses
it's not people doing vacation rentals
it's not a family like you see on tv in
the commercial it's a business it's a
function hall it's an event center
thank you
thank you for your testimony and
especially thank you for your patience
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you mentioned the
dublin pass and ordinance and it's been
successful is that available on their
website
yes our zoning ordinance is available on
the website okay thank you
okay thank you very much and thank you
for enduring the
thank you for the delays that we had
so that's going to end the
i think that's what happens when you
hand your card in at 10 30 for an 11 30
hearing all right i also have a card for
for
good morning good afternoon i almost
said good morning i'm margaret burns i'm
the executive director of the new
hampshire municipal association and we
are here in opposition to senate bill
249.
there is no doubt that short-term some
short-term rentals operate responsibly
and there is no doubt that short-term
rentals can play a part in new
hampshire's economy but that's not what
this bill is about this bill presents a
very simple question to this committee
and the question is whether one
particular use of land
one industry in fact should be totally
exempt from fundamental principles of
zoning
senate bill 249 would allow short-term
rentals everywhere to representative
rung's question earlier this bill would
not allow a municipality to allow
short-term rentals in some districts but
not in other districts that is the way
the bill reads
to this end it would be an unprecedented
incursion on the most fundamental aspect
of municipal authority which is local
zoning authority
other than the tilling of soil and the
harvesting of crops there is no other
land use that is allowed in every
district and every area within a
municipality if senate bill 249 passed
it would be growing your own food and
renting properties as short-term rentals
that would be exempt from zoning
authority
why is this such a fundamental piece of
zoning it's because zoning at its most
fundamental level is the separation of
different types of uses there is nothing
surprising or different about this
residential uses are separated from
industrial uses from commercial uses
indeed even single-family homes can be
prohibited in certain areas because we
have districts that are dedicated purely
to industrial and commercial but under
senate bill 249 again short-term rentals
would have to be allowed everywhere
senate bill 249 does not even allow
municipalities to distinguish between
owner-occupied properties and properties
that are purchased by investment
companies properties that have no intent
of being used as residential properties
are not for people to live in as
long-term residents and are operated as
short-term rental businesses with no
regard for the local community the
residents or the local ordinances
as a result this bill is not about
what's good for local residents it's
about what's good for absentee landlords
who buy up properties
i would also point you to the very
language of the bill as conflicting and
deeply problematic on the one hand
short-term rental and vacation rental
is defined as a single family or two
family building or structure
however the bill also clearly states
that any building or structure must be
allowed as a short-term rental
regardless of its classification use or
occupancy and regardless of whether it
is conforming or non-conforming
this means to representative powers
question earlier on yes not only must
residential properties be allowed as
short-term rentals so must any other
structure a barn a shed a pool house an
office that is how this bill reads
for that reason this bill is also not
modeled after the adu statute that was
passed several years ago the adu statute
requires municipalities to allow by
right
by special exception or by conditional
use permit accessory dwelling units in
zones where single-family homes are
allowed again this bill allows strs
everywhere in a municipality
proponents have also claimed that senate
bill 249 grants new authority to
municipalities but this is not accurate
rsa 4717 for cities and rsa 41 section
11c already grant cities and towns the
power to require regulations relative to
obtaining municipal permits
municipalities already have the
authority to require health and safety
inspections as a condition of granting a
special use permit or a conditional use
permit and the part of the bill that
talks about regulating noise parking
health sanitation and enforcing other
town regulations merely restricts
authority that municipalities already
have
proponents of the bill have also claimed
that this bill is necessary to ensure
there is not a ban on short-term rentals
however i would offer to you that senate
bill 249 is a ban on local residents and
their ability to enact local zoning
ordinances to deal with issues that
affect them locally
furthermore bans on short-term rentals
are not what we are hearing about and is
not what we are seeing and hearing
municipalities doing instead
municipalities are working to enact
regulations to properly incorporate
short-term rentals into their
communities without letting them overrun
their communities to that end in about
27 municipalities there are various
regulations and zoning ordinances that
deal with things such as limiting where
short-term rentals are allowed limiting
them to owner-occupied air rentals in
some areas limiting days of the year
they may be renting requiring
registration requiring safety
inspections imposing limits on occupancy
and parking for the health safety and
welfare of the community
many of these local ordinances would
simply be preempted upon passage of
senate bill 249.
i know you've heard a lot of speakers
today and this has been a long hearing
so i will close by saying that i in my
time of nhma have not only are hearing
from local officials in strong
opposition to this bill but i have
perhaps never heard from so many
residents asking me why this bill is
happening and what they can do to stop
it and to ask legislators to hear the
issues that they are facing in their
communities and that will only become
more significant if short-term rentals
are required to be allowed everywhere
and if basic fundamentals of zoning are
overridden by senate bill 249. for these
reasons we would ask you to recommend
this bill as inexpedient to legislate
thank you
representative mcdonnell you have a
question
thank you good afternoon
just a quick question we've heard a lot
about that court case in conway
if that would come out that a short term
renter was a use for a residence how's
it going to affect the communities
conway's case is about conway's
ordinance conway's case is about whether
their zoning ordinance
adequately or sufficiently or correctly
regulated this use that they are trying
to regulate it wasn't about a statewide
definition of residential versus
commercial so i can't agree with the
classification of the case as i've heard
it here before by prior speakers
thank you
margaret thank you for your testimony
thank you appreciate it appreciate it
cut your mic
okay that was our last speaker on
bill
and so
no
we're going to end the hearing
on
sb 249 and move right into sb 251
which is relative to an advisory board
of a
tiff or a tax incremental financing
district
senator birdsall welcome
[Music]
back sure
thank you mr chair thank you committee
um i'm proud to be back and i am still
senator regina bertsell from district
19. the um
i support the towns of hampstead windham
and derry and i'm the prime sponsor of
senate bill 251 and hopefully this is a
much simpler bill than the one you just
heard
um 251 senate bill 251 was brought to us
a request brought to us by a few
constituents
and it basically adjusts
membership of advisory boards of tiff or
tax increment financing districts to um
hopefully to ensure a little bit fairer
representation of business and compute
community interests uh rather than just
the properties inside so basically we're
just trying to i we're just trying to
open up tiff
advisory boards to allow a member of the
business community as well as property
owners in that district
that is the extent of my testimony
thank you senator any uh questions for
the senator while she's here
not seeing any questions thank you again
for your patience
and with our schedule thank you good
luck
is there anybody in the audience that
has a comment about uh
sb251
elizabeth
i did put in a card i hope you received
it
good afternoon my name is catherine heck
i represent the new hampshire municipal
association and we're here to just
comment on the bill
we wanted to thank the senate for
amending the bill to include
a member of the advisory board who has
an is an owner and occupant of real
property within that community so we
support the bill as amended with that
language however we did bring up a
concern early on and we're going to
reiterate that concern that the bill
uses the word community rather than
political subdivision or municipality
and the word community is not defined
anywhere in rsa so it would just be in
my opinion a simple amendment to just
change the term community to be more
befitting so it's consistent through the
rsas and that's all i have for you today
unless you have any questions oh that
was facial representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking mike my question it's a dumb
question but i'm a loud one
and i haven't used it yet so
if you bear with me
uh
it doesn't say how this committee is
going to be set up was going to be
elected appointed
is that is that somewhere else
that i'm missing or what it's defined in
the other aspects of the rsa so that's
that's already in the statute yes all
right thank you very much thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um i'm noticing on
lines
six and seven
um
it the
or adjacent to the development
district
so this this is describing the members
um has been struck does that refer to a
butter and my question is
is it a butter not um a community
interest stakeholder why would a if it
isn't a butter why would they not be
part of this this membership
um it doesn't preclude that from
happening um the prior version of the
bill prior to amendment was there wasn't
anyone who owned real property as part
of the committee so i they struck that
language because it doesn't preclude
other people from being and it just
requires that one member be an owner of
real property
okay
thank you very much thank you
and i did have a
and that concludes the hearing
on
senate bill 251.
yes
you did submit a card um
a little confused it has a different
committee name on it
did i put the wrong committee yeah
election law
oh
this is municipal and county right i got
it you know you're way around senator
yeah thank you
uh
floor is yours thank you uh chairman
dolan and members of the committee
my name is david bouton
i'm a town councilman in hooksett new
hampshire
i'm the chair of the tip advisory board
and have some other
involvements but
i used to be in the senate and i was in
the house at one time so this is kind of
a i haven't been back here for several
years but it's enjoyable to be here
the issue at hand is membership of the
tip advisory board
currently statute limits it to
someone who lives in the district or
adjacent to the district
what we're trying to do is widen
because we find over the last three
years that i've been on the committee we
find that we have vacancies and we have
a hard time to fill those vacancies
so what we're trying to do is expand
the pool
of individuals who might be interested
in serving on the tip advisory board
and that's
generally
in general that's only what this bill is
doing
not changing any other aspect of the
statute
that ends my testimony mr chairman okay
thank you take any questions
representative tripp
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh since you didn't say i assume you
support the bill yes i do
thank you and thank you very much and
thank you for your patience as we go
through this extended schedule well i i
have to say
you folks deserve a lot of kudos for all
this time you're putting in and welcome
back to uh your old
stomping ground thank you very very much
oh and
it goes without saying that i hope
and that ends the
hearing on senate bill 251 we're going
to move right into
senate bill 273-a which is relative to
broadband
welcome
good afternoon chairman dolan and the
other warrior committee members you guys
are amazing
my name is carol alfano from exeter and
i'm also the communications director for
the state senate it's my privilege to
introduce senate bill 273 for its prime
sponsor
senator jeb bradley inclement weather is
impacting the senator's travel so he
could not be here today
this bill permits towns to authorize the
bonding for broadband infrastructure at
special meetings new hampshire is poised
to receive
122 million dollars in federal funds for
broadband upgrades and sb 273 allows for
the funding process to be expedited this
bill is sponsored on the behalf of the
new hampshire municipal association
senator bradley appreciates your support
for senate bill 273 that concludes my
introduction of the bill and i will
defer any questions to the people who
know best from the municipal association
thank you for your consideration
thank you for introducing that and
representing senator birdsell
are there any questions
bradley i'm sorry senator bradley
okay we had also uh intention to testify
welcome back well thank you i'll
introduce myself again for the record my
name is catherine heck and i represent
the new hampshire municipal association
and we're here to support senate bill
senator bradley's representative so
wonderfully introduced this bill this
bill would allow towns to authorize
bonds at special meetings without court
approval so it could expedite the
process for moving these federal funds
forward that do require some kind of
match because the size and scope of
these projects are so significant a bond
issue may have to be
taken up by a community
this legislation is also supported by
bond council
so i think you might have received
written testimony from bond council on
this as well
and over the next several years we have
122 million dollars in the capital
projects fund that came in through arpa
we have another hundred thousand dollars
coming in through the infrastructure
hundred million rather both millions i
apologize coming into the infrastructure
and jobs investment act so with over 200
million dollars coming in immediately to
new hampshire over the next several
months we wanted to be
ready and have towns have the ability to
move forward without having to wait till
their annual meeting so i can certainly
take any questions you might have
any questions for the nhma
will uh will some of that money be
available for counties
yes sir some of that money will be
available for counties thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much
and that is going to close the hearing
on senate bill 273
and
next we're going to hear
senate bill 312 which is
has to do with
adjusting the assessments of taxable
property
312.
we don't have we don't have uh anyone to
here
this is uh
we're gonna hear from representative
pimante
thank you mr chair
uh senate bill 312.
it's relative to the adjusted
assessments of taxable property
bill provides that the assessors and
selectmen shall as part of creating an
annual revised inventory of taxable
property correct any errors
in existing appraisals it's very short
bill
really only one sentence that was
corrected in here
and that's on line three
and basically it says
annually in in accordance with state
assessing guidelines the assessors and
selectmen
shall adjust assessments to reflect
changes
and to correct any errors in existing
appraisals
so that all assessments are reasonably
proportional within the municipality
i believe this sentence was not in here
as before
and that's the really only change
in the bill and it puts it back where
originally stated started from
thank you and that's uh any questions
you have a microphone that works yeah
okay thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
is that not done now i mean do they file
these i mean do assessors and selectmen
file
their annual
inventory and not correct errors um they
file but sometimes the the
i guess they have a uh
i guess the first of april they're
pretty busy with this stuff and
sometimes they may miss something
um
so
it it it actually says correcting any
errors
and and before it i think it just said
correcting errors or something selling
on those lines
and that's the way it was explained to
me so
thank you representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
i'm curious to understand what the
genesis of this this bill is
just basically what i said there was a
this bill was pretty much
in existence
uh before
okay
then they had it changed and now they're
changing it back because they found it
didn't work too well follow-up mr chair
yeah
i'm curious to know if it pertains to
the um
to the
um the court case involving the
merrimack premium outlets versus the
town of merrimack i'm not sure about
that and if you want to pursue and ask
senator gray
he may be able to give you more
information on that
okay
yes
thank you mr chair and thank you mr vice
chair for taking my question um the way
i look at this is that it may
decrease the number of tax abatements
that a select board may be
uh
asked for every year
um that's
possible but uh you know it comes on a
case-by-case basis thank you
okay uh
i think that's it
thank you
and uh mr grace you have uh some input
from the nhma
thank you mr chairman h graves for the
new hampshire municipal association we
support this bill
um to answer representative power's
question yes this does originate from
the merrimack premium outlets versus
town of merrimack uh decision that was
issued october 1st
2021 and i apologize to the committee i
did submit written testimony but not
until this afternoon and it reflects
what i'm about to tell you
essentially what happened in that case
is that the town of merrimack had
assessed the property they later learned
that the market assessed that property
to higher value
and a collateral for a loan process so
the town adjusted its assessment
that was then challenged by the property
owners saying you're not allowed to do
that there's a reevaluation process
every five years that's the proper time
at which you can re-evaluate
reassess the value of our property
and the supreme court upheld that
[Music]
that
or the supreme court said that
the property owner's interpretation of
the existing language was correct um as
representative piemante said the
language used to read
differently
and was basically the same as it would
be adjusted back to now and that would
allow municipalities to adjust
the assessments to accurately reflect
the market value of properties
as they learn what those market values
are
so in the case of a commercial property
like the merrimack premium outlets
unlike a housing market where you can
look at comparable values there probably
aren't many similar properties of that
type around so
for housing market the way you assess
them is you look at comparable sales um
generally speaking
you know where there are
large shopping plazas they're not
sold very frequently
and so it's difficult to figure out what
the correct assessment is but if you do
find out what that
what the private market is uh valuing
those at you can correctly
uh determine their value and correctly
set your assessment and so that that was
the issue that we're trying to correct
here
so that the town of merrimack
and any other municipality
which
has a situation where they learn that
the the valuation is incorrect doesn't
have to wait for five years or up to
five years
they can
change that during the next period
when they adjust values that they do for
everywhere around town
thank you
yes representative yes
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
grays for taking my question
um it's a little bit nitpicky but i
wonder about the choice of the word
errors
in the bill
an error can be defined as any number of
different things and what you just
described
really didn't strike me as an error
it struck me as a
miscalculation or a re-evaluation and
i'm just worried that you know could
this word be construed should the bill
be passed
in a way that the framers of the bill
did not intend
as i
recall it that was the terminology used
by the supreme court and therefore this
just
thank you mr graves thank you very much
betsy is going to speak in support of
the bill
and she's from the assessing standards
board
yes and i'll just
pass out a
copy of the rsa i don't know if you do
this anymore we used to when we were
here when i was here before it could be
that you've all got your laptop so you
can look up the rsas easy
but
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is betsy patton from concord and i am
the chairman of the assessing standards
board
and i am here in support of senate bill
312.
i ask you to support senate bill 312 in
order to ensure that all properties in
the state of new hampshire in our cities
and towns are reasonably and
proportional within each community
rsa
758 prior to the current wording
required that assessors and selectmen
shall examine all the real estate in
their cities and towns
shall reappraise all such real estate as
has changed
shall correct all errors that they find
in the existing appraisal
they should that such corrected
appraisal shall be made part of the
inventory
the current wording and if you look at
what i passed out to you one is what it
used to be one is what it is now
the current wording of
7581 requires the assessment and
selectmen
shall adjust
assessments to reflect changes so that
all assessments
are reasonably and proportional within
that community
all adjustments to be included in the
inventory and be sworn to
rsa 82 further goes on to list six
reasons
to consider adjusting assessments
while i was a member of this
esteem committee and
a representative for 18 years whenever a
listing was made the following phrase
was always included
including but not limited to
that is the little catch-all that allows
if you have missed something in a
listing then what happens is it doesn't
automatically be removed or not
considered
however the phrasing was not included in
the current statute the current statute
was
changed in house bill 170 in the laws of
2000 when the legislature was going
through
the
trying to fix the sorel case and the
statewide education
property tax and trying to figure out
the constitutionality of our assessing
process
so
uh the justices going on to the reason
that we're here is that the justices
concluded in merrimack on premium
outlets versus the town of merrimack who
you just heard from
that the statutory scheme
in its current form
does not allow for the correction of
even known errors in valuation prior to
the next
municipality-wide reappraisal
accordingly we conclude the justices
concluded that the oath in rsa 757 for
selectmen
that all taxable property they have to
swear to this every year that all
taxable property was appraised to the
best of our knowledge and belief at its
full value
that must be read as certifying that the
last legally authorized appraisal or
adjustment at the time was legal and
and fair
the asb does not agree with this ruling
and that is why we are here requesting
the change put forth in senate bill 312.
we are asking as representatives of the
public
municipal officers the assessing
community department of revenue and the
members of the house and senate that are
on the committee
that we
ask you to vote ought to pass on senate
bill 312. thank you for the opportunity
to be able to testify before you today
thank you very much and thank you for
being patient with us
yes representative gallagher uh you
mentioned something that was supposed to
be handed out to all of us um i don't
think i got a copy
or maybe i've just gone so many things
it's the rsa it's ours okay thank you
nevermind
okay
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thanks for your
testimony today i i wanted to add a
little comment to say this is a two-way
street i own a property in dover and it
was assessed by the assessors
improperly and the poor city of dover
had to wait five years
before they could uh get some more money
well the
point of the assessment is that it is
reasonable and proportional
to all of the uh
properties within that community i know
i'm sorry you have to well you got you
got away with four years right yeah
thank you at this point i'd like to
invite uh senator gray
to speak ooh
welcome senator you're already here i'm
sorry it's okay
yep yep yes that's okay i can i can take
the other chair and we can actually sit
here together i mean you just swing that
mic there you go yep uh my name is james
gray i'm a senator uh representing
district six which starts in rochester
goes up route 11 to alton bar instead
gilmanton
this bill is about fairness
as the representative said that in the
city of dover
she was
not charged what it should have cost for
her taxes but on the other hand if
she had been
charged too much she could have asked
for an abatement gone through the
abatement process
so again this to make the playing field
level
and certainly the assessing standards
board as one of your members is a uh
one of our our best attending members
right now
um that they do try to do a good job and
look out for
both the cities and towns but if you
don't charge the right amount
because of a scribner's error or
whatever reason that the the record is
incorrect
you can't do it
without the changes in this bill
and
the other people who've testified
especially the chair of the assessing
standards board has probably answered
all your questions and i can go home and
have tacos with the grandkids
well we're going to try to help get you
uh to the taco uh
all right uh yes senator power i mean uh
representative power
i
was that a promotion or a demotion when
he caught i'm not sure
i've been told i've been told it's a
demotion but you know what can i say
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
on line three
i'm referring to the word change i
assume that that
means changes to the property
is that correct
um on line three
to correct any errors in the existing
appraisal
so i guess
i'm looking at line three
um
where it says uh shall adjust
assessments to reflect changes
so changes refers to changes in the
property that part is an existing law
right now okay
and that didn't need to change okay
um if the
assessor
is called out to a particular property
because you've added a deck or you have
done other improvements to the property
those should be reflected on your
assessing card and there's people that
understand this process a lot more than
i do
but you add a bedroom
you do anything else a lot of those
things are caught through the process
where you go in for your building permit
and the building permit
you know causes an inspector to go out
and do the various things
but
sometimes there are errors
and it could be that somebody read or
rule or wrong it could be
whatever
but right now
if we discover that error afterward and
the rest of the taxpayers in that
community
pay more tax than they should have
because
whomever's card that error is on is not
paying
in a portion you know their appropriate
share
well thank you senator i appreciate you
uh it's a good bill your patience and uh
20 to nothing right all right
uh and the last speaker on this bill
is uh jim micho from hudson
is he here yes in the interest of the
hour and i agree with the rest of the
speakers i'm gonna forego my time
that closes the
hearing
for senate bill
312.
we're now going to we're going to open
the hearing rather the hearing for
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee again carol alfano senate
communications director it's my
privilege to introduce senate bill
317 for senator carson
while she is not traveling with senator
bradley she is also unable to be here
right now
this bill reduces the interest rate for
abatements of paid property taxes from
the current rate of six percent to four
percent
in 2018 the legislature reduced the late
property tax bill interest rate but did
not concurrently adjust the tax
abatement interest rate this adjustment
would save municipalities a small but
significant amount of money the
committee amendment clarifies that this
change is effective for taxable periods
beginning on or after april 1st 2022
that concludes my introduction and i
would be happy to
send any of your questions along to
senator carson are there any uh
yes uh representative
it's fair to say that it's although we
it's a bad word this is a housekeeping
uh bill
representative i i would defer to
senator carson on that i i would not
want to speak to the bill i can only
introduce it but i'll let you know you
you had your question it sounds like
your presentation if i will mr chairman
did it was it is a housekeeping bill i
will be happy to ask her and i will
write down your name
thank you very much for your testimony
appreciate it thank you and that
concludes our business for
senate bill 317. oh i'm sorry mr gray's
from the nhma
i'm sorry i skipped you thank you mr
chair uh i did submit a pink card but i
know you have had quite the stack today
so it may have gotten lost there
nhma nate grace for the new hampshire
municipal association
nhma supports
senate bill 317 it is an hma policy bill
it lowers the abatement interest rate
from uh six percent to four percent
um so back in 2018 the legislature uh
lowered the late property tax bill
interest rate um
and this is proportional to that um so
uh
in in 2018
prior to a tax lien being issued
the interest rate was lowered from 12 to
8 percent and after the tax lien was
issued um it went from 18 to 14
but the abatement interest rate was not
also lowered so it really is a
housekeeping bill
happy to take questions any questions
for the nhma
seeing none thank you very much thank
you next we're going to hear from
thank you mr chairman i'm not an
executive counselor i used to be a
i can play an executive council okay
thank you very much and i appreciate the
fact that you all stayed but i've been
against this bill
and and i understand that they lowered
the interest rate that they charged
people and i thought at that time it was
wrong
because when a business is short of cash
the best place and the easiest place to
get it is from the local community
and if you can't borrow it for for less
than what you're gonna lend it to him
then he's going to borrow it from the
taxpayers that's the reason why during
the tough times we went to 18
because the banks were charging 24
percent
so
a lot of people still chose to borrow
money from the taxpayer
it's it's not a good thing to do and i'm
i'm surprised they went that low
however
i also
fight a lot of tax assessments
on properties that i own
based on the fact that i'm political
the assessment go up
based on what was supposed to be a
visual inspection
except that when i questioned the person
who inspected it and he told me that he
had inspected through windows on my deck
i knew he was lying because my deck was
so rotted a dog's weight wouldn't be
held on it
so it went down
i've had another issue where
an assessor has gone through the
driveway handed my son a card and said
tell your father his assessment just
went up
it's because i speak up at my town
meetings
and they don't like it
i also have properties in other parts of
the state i restore historical
properties
i've appealed to to the borderland and
tax appeal
and one of both of them
problem is it costs money to do an
appeal
in that time the three years or maybe
four years that it takes you to get
before the borderland and tax appeal
you have to pay somebody to do the work
you're also continuing to pay the same
tax bill
there should be a penalty
all the times that i have won a case it
wasn't based on the people who sit as
selectmen
it's based on the the assessment firm
that they hire
who insist that they don't have to
comply with the law
i have seen an assessment firm sit there
and say
i'm taxing every emergency generator
because the law tells me i have to
yet the law explicitly states
an emergency generator is not taxable
the same assessment person who works for
a large firm
said i'm not assessing those people who
generate their own power and are off the
grid
well the law says you have to
even sola
i worked for the solar industry for a
while and we had to go town to town
so that they wouldn't include the solar
panels in their assessment at the rate
they were
because it got so that any any savings
they made actually went to the tax
dollars
but we have people who say i'm not going
to assess them because the laws and it's
in one area where i am
there's a gentleman who's very high on
the political scale who has a house
beautiful house
beautiful barn beautiful garage
a hanger for his airplane and an
airstrip
his assessment's 220 thousand dollars
i have a historical house that has no
plumbing
no electricity
and it's uninhabitable
they assess the 300 000.
so i have to fight it when i go in they
tell me oh no we assessed it perfectly
and that's not the case
so six percent
is reasonable because i have to pay
people
to keep up i have to pay people to look
at the assessments as they change what
happens when somebody sells their
property and the next guy buys it
there's one case in one community where
somebody stated to the court in a
divorce case
my property's worth 658 thousand dollars
that's it
yet because he's politically connected
he's assessed that i think 265.
so these are the things that the regular
people have to fight
and there are a lot of them if you have
money if you have political power
your assessment's not the same and
people have to fight that
the other thing is if you're not on the
wrong side of the political power
you pay dearly
this should be this is a penalty
it's not about i invested my money with
you for four percent
it's about you shouldn't have taken my
money to begin with and you knew it
now if you want to if you want to make
it so that the city's in town save some
money
put in the law that the assessment
firm has to pay it
and maybe then they'll actually follow
the law and they'll stop being
politically influenced and do the right
thing
but to reduce this to four percent
means every time i go fight a town i'm
going to take more money out of my
pocket
to fight them and i'm going to come out
the loser
so all they have to do is smile and say
yeah you sort of won but but we beat you
so i'm asking you not to do it and by
the way my town assessor's behind me and
i think he wants to speak but
he's my friend
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator uh any uh questions
from the council for the senator yes
representative
gallagher hi um
you cited some
dollar amounts
involved in some of the cases you're
concerned about in your testimony and i
kind of missed those could you
like one of them was what six hundred
thousand dollars could you repeat some
of those for me
on one property a gentleman in a divorce
case
trying to show that his property wasn't
worth much told the judge it was worth
658 thousand dollars because he didn't
want to give his wife
what it was really worth
and and he was only taxed in that
community for i believe it was 265 000.
okay thanks
thank you senator clay i don't think we
have any additional uh questions for you
thank you very much
the last uh
person i would like to testify is uh jim
michaud
from hudson
yes sir
thank you very much for the opportunity
to testify in front of you my name is
jimmy show and i'm chief assessor for
the town of hudson uh the hudson board
of selectmen uh voted to uh have uh
either medium of the town administrator
up here to support this bill
and um
many of you serve uh at your local level
on boards of slackmen and town councils
and you know that you have to raise an
abatement overlay fund
and that's the cover abatements um at
the end of uh the last paragraph and the
letter that's being handed out um by
lowering the interest amount
we'll have the net effect
of serving to lower the amount of the
abatement overlay the abatement overlay
gets raised by taxes
so in essence
by having less interest paid out that
abatement overlay fund can be reduced
um or at least
lessened the increase would be lessened
um and i agree with nhma on the changes
that were made when the interest rates
for late payments and this one going
down from six percent to four percent um
seems to be aligned with that
and
that is the uh that is the balance of my
testimony for today well thank you thank
you for being brief any questions
so that concludes
a hearing
for
senate bill
29.
317 i'm sorry our next
our next bill to take up is senate bill
329 which is establishing a study
commission
to study barriers to housing development
in new hampshire including workforce and
329 mr chair
thanks
okay
thank you chair
thank you guys again for being here all
day
good afternoon for the record i am
senator rebecca perkins cuoca from
senate district 21 representing the city
of portsmouth in the towns of madbury
lee durham newington newmarket and
newfields i am the prime sponsor of sb
329 an act establishing a commission to
study barriers to housing development in
new hampshire
including workforce and middle-income
housing
speed 29 will establish a commission to
study the declining
availability of housing
and will also provide us with an
opportunity to study what the various
barriers may be including access to
federal resources which we may have
housing is a critical issue facing our
state and our region the commission will
give us another venue to look at the
tools at our disposal to address the
housing crisis and to see how best to
deploy them going forward
as amended by the senate sb 329 now also
includes a workforce housing developer a
representative of the bia to ensure that
a holistic review of the housing
situation is taken
i am also proposing amendment
1072 s which i just circulated
which
was emailed to the committee by may 8 on
march 29th
so you guys might have an old copy which
will add a representative of the office
of planning and development in the
department of business and economic
affairs to the commission
sb 329 passed the senate health and
human services committee for nothing and
passed the full senate on a voice vote
as i mentioned earlier this morning i am
a long time advocate of affordable and
workforce housing
i think it is something that we just
need to continue to work on and work on
and work on and
i know that we have a hearing coming up
shortly for sb 400 but
view this commission as an opportunity
to look ahead
and see what else we can do
yes representative vann
thank you chairman and thank you senator
uh
so it says middle-income housing do we
we don't have a definition of that and
i'm not sure that
we might need one for the commission but
the idea is to make sure that we're
keeping our workforce healthy and strong
so
unfortunately the those that are housing
challenged keeps expanding and in our
case
this would of course include our
firefighters our police officers our
teachers but increasingly would
encompass young engineers accountants
and lawyers
anyone who has to afford a home on their
own
and even families are very much
struggling to find houses they can
afford
follow-up yes
so you're really talking about the
reason i ask is i have seen recently
that there's a conflation of missing
middle and middle income and i just
wanted to make sure that that was not
happening here because missing middle is
a building type middle income is a money
so it really is you're really talking
about money and income here
that's right representative thank you
for the clarifications
representative power
you mr chair and thank you senator for
taking my question as a freshman state
representative
um
i'm new to
to to concord and so my question is
are you aware of any other studies or
commissions that have been
conducted to study the issue of
workforce housing from
if i'm correct i believe that there was
one that resulted in 2021 house bill
86.
so um
is this another study to study the same
thing that's already been studied and
how might this be different than others
sure thank you for the question so um
there were two efforts probably in the
last few years
to look at housing one was a commission
that my predecessor senator martha
fuller clark
brought forward which was a commission
to study barriers on density um
that commission
was not able to fully finish its work
due to the pandemic and so there are
some aspects of its charge that
are being proposed to be picked up by
this commission um so it's it's a
continuation in that way however
um
and then there was also another uh
task force essentially out of the
governor's office that i participated in
that resulted in hb
586 which in the previous year was
hb 16 29 and 32
and is now back as sb400
so
those efforts have both been undertaken
in the past few years but
as far as i'm aware at this time there's
nothing else proposed to be going
forward
representative guthrie
yes in that same regard do you know
if the governor's task force is an
ongoing
operation or is this going to be
parallel
or
to take the place of the task force
i i do know the answer to that question
i participated in the governor's task
force and it
was a 90-day charge so it was short and
this one would be the only one that
exists at the time
thank you thank you for your answer
yes
representative already
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
this is my first year on municipal
county and government but
what has come to my attention from the
bills that have come before us is that
there are many barriers that
are created at the local level
particularly with local planning boards
i was wondering why there wasn't someone
from there on represented on this
commission
sorry representative could you just
clarify someone from for example new
hampshire municipal association
i'm really thinking of people that are
really at the front lines of
of approving these kind of houses so it
would be a representative from a
municipal planning board
um
it's a good question i would certainly
be open to adding such a member
i would think
my short answer is that as you say
they're on the front lines and so i view
this as a way to
allow those at the state level to to
think and provide tools to support them
in their work not necessarily ask
more of them but it's certainly
an expertise that would be welcome and
as a former city councilor and planning
board member i know that um
you know making sure that sort of we're
all working on it on different levels i
think is very important and
supportive to the cause so if that's
something you'd like to discuss further
i'm more than happy to do that and then
uh one follow-up
thank you and then uh just another
suggestion
is um perhaps the
this the the member of the house of
representatives could be um specified
that it would be someone who sits on
this committee
okay i like both of those changes thank
you representative
yes representative stephen
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
following up on representative wrong's
comment about a planner being on the on
this commission
um would it be appropriate to have
someone from the new hampshire planning
association
who covers you know most of the state
yeah so um just to clarify uh there is
an amendment in front of you 1072 which
would add someone from the office of
planning and development
thank you but okay
i didn't know if that was your question
or if there's another one my apologies
representative gilman uh is there
any other question yes representative
lasalles
thank you for taking my question
um
is there a requirement
we see these
commissions and committees come and go
we know that there have been
this issue
has been a need for for
decades probably
we said that the governor had a had a
90-day commission
is there a requirement for these
committees and commissions
to produce a report
so that the next
rendition of this
study
doesn't have to start from zero previous
reports
as a basis foundation for going forward
thank you for the question
representative and um in this particular
bill there there is a requirement to
report out it's found on um
lines 28 through 30 of page one so that
would be a report
by november 1st of this year um
but i can also assure you on this issue
that um
and i'm going to use the word us those
of us that are in the housing advocate
community um
you know are very much aware of the work
that has been done what we're building
on and sort of where we go from here i
know the council for housing stability
has been
a convening ground for sort of
many different aspects of the housing
crisis and so that strategic report has
some action items that have been
implemented this year and um again you
know just me being here asking for this
commission is sort of an outcome of the
previous commission having a couple
pieces of its charge in its final report
that it wasn't able to complete so
even though it's not in the bill
we very much intend to build on the
previous work done
thank you
any other questions from the committee
as the bill is written it anticipates
the committee finishing its work in
november of 2022 which seems like a
really tight timetable to me
i'm wondering if that
seems
yeah that that's also
a fair question i think that's a fairly
standard date to report out and
the re-standard date to report out and
the reason being that you know in
election years our legislative deadlines
for the house and the senate occur at
the end of the year so i think the
intent is
to make sure that we can act on those
recommendations and file any needed
legislation but
you know i'd certainly be open to that
being an interim report and the ability
for us to continue our work
follow-up just a quick follow-up
i wonder if
some language might be added that would
carry the commission's work forward
should it not be completed by november
20 22 so you won't lose the momentum
and any other
questions
for the senator
seeing none uh thank you very much
senator thank you chair thank you
next we're going to hear from
mr david juvette
from concord
thank you mr chair members of the
committee a pleasure to be here this
afternoon in support of this bill for
the record my name is dave juve i'm a
senior vice president for public policy
with the business and industry
association
i've been before this committee before
but not often so i would like to tell
you first of all a little bit about the
bia we serve as new hampshire statewide
chamber of commerce we have about 400
employer members
with over 90 000 employees in the state
and i want to focus on those 90 000
employees because every single one of
them needs a place to live hopefully
they do but we know many others are
having a hard time finding affordable
housing either rental housing or
or what
in my generation we used to call starter
homes
[Music]
some of you have asked questions about
you know we've had commissions do we
need another one and my response to that
is things are always changing
there are
considerations now obstacles if you will
to being able to develop affordable
housing that we didn't think about five
years ago um
retaliatory tariffs on building
materials inflation
uh just to name a few um some things
um
continue on such as um you know concern
from some municipalities about ruining
the nature of their cities and towns
but uh there is a lot of new information
for a commission to do and and i would
by the way support that recommendation
to extend this beyond november of of
2022. i think the november date is
helpful to have an interim
report in case there is some legislation
to be filed for next year
but
this is a complicated issue
there are many things that impact the
ability to to build
affordable housing in the state and i
would uh support efforts to to extend
the life of this commission beyond the
end of this year mr chairman that
concludes my testimony i'd be happy to
try and answer any questions any
questions
from the committee
saying none thank you very much for your
testimony
and lastly we have um
oh i'm sorry we have two more speakers
alyssa margolin
from concord from the from the housing
action
group
she's going to speak in support of the
bill
thank you mr chairman members of the
community alyssa marglin i serve as
director of housing action new hampshire
we're the statewide affordable housing
coalition in the state and we work to
improve state and federal policy so
everyone in new hampshire has a place to
call home
we thank senator perkins cuoco for
introducing the study commission i've
been in this role as director since
2009.
i can tell you that a little over 10
years ago senator bob odell had chaired
a commission on housing
and um
and we thought that
the
the the shortage of the housing supply
was of a concern then it's certainly in
a crisis space right now but we have an
unprecedented resource opportunity with
the federal resources in play some
investments that the legislature has
made into our affordable housing fund
and it's it's the reports generated by
these commissions have been very helpful
um not only in
policy development but in understanding
compromise
ahead of time and making some progress
in the policy realm so we would welcome
um another commission on housing at this
time especially focused uh uh on the
problems of today
wrong yes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh you mentioned a previous commission
several years ago
and then you brought up how things have
changed because there's more resources
becoming available so was the um outcome
of the previous commission solely on the
cost basis of funding for housing my
recollection of that report and it's a
while ago was that the recommendation
was that the state
start um
regularly funding our state housing
trust fund at the time
there was an analysis and we realized
that new hampshire was one of four
states that didn't have a dedicated
funding source for our revolving loan
fund that provides below market rate
capital so you can
you know pass it along to developers in
those savings go to residents
we thankfully we changed that and now we
have a dedicated funding source and we
have increased investments in the
state's affordable housing fund i also
remember and um perhaps um
others who served on that commission
something about the alteration of
terrain i couldn't give you the the
details on it but it was very specific
at the time and then
um the conversations that happened at
that time between
developers and
um
safety officials um
was a good start of a conversation and
since then there's actually been a
conference when building uh building and
safety officials together to talk about
you know streamlining things so we have
found these legislative study
commissions to be to be helpful
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
and our last uh speaker is jack
rudeman
welcome
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is jack ruderman and i
serve as the manager for public affairs
at new hampshire housing i'm here to
testify today in support of sb 329
we believe that it is important to
establish this study commission for
primarily two reasons
first new hampshire is continuing to
experience what governor sununu has
described as a housing crisis
and i apologize if i'm preaching to the
choir here but i did want to cite a few
statistics
that that really paint the picture of of
the
nature of the housing crisis so
just to cite a few the vacancy rate for
apartments right now is at an historic
low of less than one percent roughly
point six percent
meaning there are very few apartments on
the market and they are extremely hard
to come by
a normal healthy vacancy rate is
considered to be a roughly five percent
apartment rental costs have increased
steadily in recent years the median
gross rental rate for a two bedroom
apartment as of a year ago was fifteen
hundred dollars over five years the
price of a two bedroom apartment has
risen nearly twenty five percent
meanwhile
home prices are skyrocketing the median
sales price for a single family home has
risen from and seventy thousand dollars
in 2019
to four hundred and five thousand in
february of this year
an increase of fifty percent
and in rockingham county the median
sales price is now an astronomical 550
meanwhile the inventory of single-family
homes statewide has plunged from 3 500
homes in february of 2019
to just 928 homes this past february
a decrease of 74 percent
so we've got
a twin crisis here of both a shortage
of supply
uh and unaffordable prices
what all these statistics translate to
is an economy in which homelessness is
increasing
families can't afford to buy homes
young people are hesitant to settle or
stay in new hampshire
and employers can't hire the workers
they need to grow their businesses
the second reason we support creating
the study commission is that the work of
the prior study commission which other
speakers today have referred to
was only partly completed due to the
covet 19 pandemic the commission
did not meet for a period of roughly six
months in 2020
as a result there wasn't enough time to
investigate several important topics for
instance the commission was unable to
explore possible methods of increasing
the supply of of workforce housing
we believe that it is important to
complete the work of the prior study
committee and for new hampshire to
continue in its efforts to explore all
potential measures
to help resolve the state's housing
crisis
that concludes my testimony i'll be
happy to take any questions thank you
for your time from the committee
yes representative tripp
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh
you mentioned that there was a 74
decrease in
housing availability
uh
would you consider that to be a result
of the
coveted refugees immigrating from the
well it's a great question but i think
that goes to demand for housing whereas
the the supply i think is is an entirely
different matter that has to do with
a multitude of factors from people aging
in place
to people being unafford people being
unable to afford
moving to new homes you know for
instance folks who are in their
retirement years who want to downsize
there's just not a lot of turnover in
the market right now and not a lot of
housing stock that is on the market
yes representatives davis thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question and i don't know if it's a
question you can answer
but maybe someone can um
i represent lebanon
which is as you know right on the border
with vermont
um and
we together with hartford vermont have
pretty much absorbed most of the
increased density in housing in the
upper valley region
and i'm wondering if the commission can
somehow
discuss or take on the issue of
inter-community
maybe bi-state solutions
to some of these problems because we
don't exist in isolation and many of the
people who live in lebanon and
towns to the east of lebanon regularly
commute into vermont and vice versa and
the same is true of maine and
massachusetts
sure um
perfectly good question and i would
expect that the committee would be able
to or the commission would be able to
look at some of these issues in a
regional context and not just limited to
our own borders
so i think it's an excellent suggestion
thank you
okay thank you very much for your
and that's going to conclude our
senate bill
now we're going to open the
the hearing for senate bill 334
which is uh
establishing a committee to study
property blight
i had it i had a note here that senator
prentice was gonna
oh
welcome come on back up please and uh
okay get it go ahead got to get it all
squared away
the floor is yours
thank you very much
jared dolan and members of the house
municipal and county government
committee
for the record my name is suprentis and
i'm the state senator from district five
that's nine communities in the beautiful
connecticut river valley of new
hampshire i'm also a resident of west
lebanon and
neighbors with my uh my friend laurel
stavis so it's a it's just nice to see
everybody and i'm one of my neighbors
[Laughter]
in fact we were together last night i'm
a former city councilor and mayor we
were together at the um at the lebanon
city council meeting so i have some deep
roots in the work that you spend your
time on here and appreciate that and i
know what a long day you've had so i
will try to keep this short so i'm
introducing
a
study committee for
property blight managed property blight
in cities and towns and
this came to me as a request to the city
of clermont and actually at first
my this is the amended version of this i
was actually wanting to put in place a
tool that's been used in neighboring
states
in other parts of the country which is
enabling legislation for vacant building
registries because one of the common
problems with
vacant and or abandoned properties is
finding the responsible party when there
is a code violation there's you know and
what the code you know whether it's
multiple
whether there's water coming out the
windows because the pipes are broken was
an emergency whether there has been a
minor fire on the property whether there
is
there are abandoned vehicles that are
not registered there's a whole host of
reasons but what we do know is when
these conditions exist if they go
unenforced by
local officials
then it starts to become a property
value issue for the neighbors so it's
not so much about that building as much
as the impact that it has on the
character of our neighborhoods um here
in in new hampshire and you know
certainly in the the communities that i
represent
and one of the most important things
that we have in our lives is you know
our our property and their value
my mother just recently sold our
childhood home in massachusetts and
that as an out you know she's 90 years
old and that is the really the only you
know besides the contents of that house
that was her you know her only
investment that she had left and she
moved to new hampshire to one of the
only homes that was
was for sale at the end of my street
thank god thankfully so anyway i
originally tried to do a vacant building
registry which is a tool that's been
used but there was a lot of discussion
about who was the responsible party
because responsible parties we often
think about are like the owners of a
property but that you know like like say
me but
it's not always that case because the
building might be in the hands of a
creditor you know i worked with the
bankers on this it might be a different
it's not always
a person it might be someone an agency
or an entity that's owed money to and it
may not even be a bank so it's who's
first in line so that became an issue
trying to really narrow that down and
the other piece is what is what do we
consider you know vacant or abandoned
you know and there are some conditions
that i brought forward but there was
friendly disagreement about what those
should actually be so
my sense was i want to keep the
conversation moving forward because i do
believe that it is a tool to protect for
the communities that want to do it
protect their character of their
neighborhoods and the property values
within those neighborhoods
but i think we need to get more
agreement on what exactly
you know vacant and abandoned properties
would be and is there you know and what
the responsible parties are and is this
a tool that we actually want to enable
our communities to use
um in new hampshire
i'm a fan of of enabling legislation
only because again a former mayor and
city councilor
there are some things that we did hur
you heard earlier about solar exemptions
you know as a as a city council or we
had adopted that so we could actually
provide exemptions you know and
you know and have that as a tool for
people so that's an example of something
that's been done in the past that being
said
this is what i want to do what i what i
wanted to move on
but saw that we needed to really look
into this and make sure that this was a
good fit and we needed to gain agreement
so i approached with you know the
committee about an amendment which is a
study committee and i we do have a date
so we're looking at that this would be
done
an issue to report by november 1st and
you know we may come out of that people
might not you know agree and we might
not have you know that might not be the
tool to deal with blight there may be
something else but i think the larger
conversation needs to be had so with
that in mind i appreciate your time and
the long day i've had i'm happy to take
any questions and if i can't answer them
i will
i'll find an answer or i'll call senator
uh perkinsquoke and ask her
you mr chairman and if i can i have two
uh really quick questions uh
you talked about abandoned
uh
housing and i've had a occasion i'm a
selectman in hampstead and we had the
occasion to
end up having somebody actually tear
down their house
because it was vacant but
my problem is with blight
and it's sometimes it's in the eye of
the beholder so my question is do you
know what blight is
well that's what we want to study okay
because i have an idea and i put if you
look at the bill before it was amended
what i thought would be common
definitions but we didn't have agreement
on that so things like you know what the
condition of the yard is unregistered
vehicles you know damage to the property
like broken windows there were different
items like that that i had
pulled together from similar legislation
in other states but again there was not
agreement on what the definition was so
what we want to study is like you know
what do we do about black is there black
problem what do we do about it and
should we enable communities to handle
this so it's a really good question my
second question is
in your
investigation into this uh problem do we
have a rsa that we can hang our hat on
if
uh that would be the extension of
what you want to do with blight so local
officials uh have
they have the ability to enforce you
know their own ordinances and codes as
it's related to that but what often
happens is
that if you know and i know not every
community is equal in terms of what they
have available for municipal services
and that's again why this would be
enabling
if
you can't find the responsible party
because there's no central place to look
you know and you're
you know going down the line and trying
to find that person it makes or or
entity it makes it harder and harder to
actually enforce this
and if i may also offer um i have a
background in public safety a long time
paramedic and although i
don't practice in the field anymore you
know i often responded for with fire
departments for water emergencies and
abandoned properties where water was
literally because the pipes had burst
were coming out the windows like and
or you know there had been a fire and
our we're trying to find the responsible
party because we have to not only deal
with the emergency but release the
property you know and have someone take
it over and that was almost the hardest
part of it was actually finding somebody
to talk to so that's part of this but
again going back
is there an rsa that we're going to
build on
there is an rsa i don't have it in
the language in here and i can add that
but it allows the local communities to
do the code enforcement okay so i can
find it out anyway
thank you for senate i appreciate it
thank you say hi to look counselor
warnock or select warnock member
representative tripp
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh i noticed that you there's only like
three members so
uh one member from the senate and two
from
the the house
uh
would you consider having someone from
say a municipality or a city
be part of the
the study so that
they'd add a little diversity to the
study
so great question uh my understanding
was and i heard i heard some folks say
they were you know new to concord i'm a
freshman senator so i'm a little new to
this but what i understood was that for
study committees we could only put
members of say the legislature on but
they're open i didn't do a commission i
wanted to do a shorter window and so
they uh these meetings are open and
members of the public and these
organizations like if i'm a study
committee i'm going to make a list of
who i want to talk to
and i'm going to call them in including
municipalities well thank you i'm wrong
i've learned something today too that
yeah if i'm wrong i'll fix that but that
was my understanding
so
any other questions for the senator yes
representative ron thank you mr chair
and thank you senator it's nice to see
you nice to see you um
along uh i chair a commission a
statewide commission on pfas and uh
my wonderful colleague from litchfield
is on it with me and
um we one of the things and i should
have brought this up when um when
senator perkins cloak introduced the
last bill but she's here is um many
times the and you're correct the
commissions include other people or name
other people outside the new hampshire
general court but study committees only
include those people who are members
but
one of the things that we found
successful in the pfas commission is
also recommending not just legislative
remedies but non-legislative remedies so
i don't know if it's something that
would deserve an amendment but it would
be something to keep in mind i know
there's been several things that we've
been doing mainly around community
engagement and communication holding
town halls which don't require
any legislative action but we've
identified that as a need that our
commission can fill
thank you you are welcome thank you
representative rung uh that's
a great observation because it is say
you know because the originally i'd been
proposing legislation and had shifted to
a study committee so we could really dig
into this deeper so
uh
i just want to make sure that we can
do that with this with us because you
can do with the commission can we
and
i guess if we open the language all
right well um
this is this is actually i think a good
approach you're having legislative
representation and if you need to bring
other people and you can but it's not
required
in statute
so this is actually a good approach
thank you very much
well thank you senator uh appreciate you
having the
patience to wait this out i
i appreciate your time i know it's been
a long day so i'll i'll wrap it up and
that ends the hearing on
senate bill 334
our last bill of the day
is
senate bill 400
which is relative training and
procedures for zoning and planning
boards and relative for financial
investments and incentives for
another
who do we have uh
to introduce the bill
good evening mr chairman and members of
the committee carol alfano from the
senate and now i'm delighted to
introduce senate bill 400 for its prime
sponsor senator jeb bradley district
three again inclement weather impacted
his travel plans he could not be here
today
this bill makes changes to the training
and procedures for zoning and planning
boards offered by the office of planning
and development
it will help
new hampshire communities that are ready
to respond to local marketing demand for
more housing it's going to provide a
foundation of enabling policies economic
incentives
improved timelines and more transparent
local review it also allows for more
tools and improves the predictability of
process to help address housing shortage
supplies
more specifically
sb 400
allows for voluntary training for
community volunteers
enables communities to provide economic
incentives to build more affordable
supply
updates reasonable timelines for review
improves the viability of workforce
housing projects and discloses
application fees and improves
documentation of local decisions
it enables inclusionary zoning
requirements and launches a housing
champion communities program and lastly
senator bradley just wanted me to
address some myths and misconceptions
that might be around this bill
it increases training for planning and
zoning board volunteers and it's it's
voluntary participation in the housing
champion certification program is
voluntary and adopting any type of
inclusionary zoning ordinance is also
voluntary and lastly municipal use of
economic development tools to encourage
housing projects is voluntary and they
may not use tools for eminent domain or
other taking
senator bradley says this is a great
bill i believe him
he appreciates your support um that is
the extent of my introduction i'm going
to defer any questions to ben frost
sitting right behind me he's from
housing action he knows more about this
bill thank you for listening
thank you
i'd like to invite the senator perkins
colcott back
thank you very much chairman um
hopefully for the last time today um
i'll introduce myself for the record i'm
senator rebecca perkins quoca
representing district 21 portsmouth and
surrounding towns um
i am thrilled to be here in support of
sb 400 today i think that um as has been
previously discussed at length housing
is an urgent problem in our state
this is um a bipartisan bill that has
technical solutions to our housing
problem we call it the community toolbox
bill because it's designed to provide
tools to our municipalities
there is nothing
and i'll say that again just because
it's important nothing in this bill that
is mandatory it is voluntary
options for our municipalities to
address the housing crisis it's my
belief that we need to do that little
bit by little bit and so
all parts of this bill are derived from
many years of experience
of the members of the governor's housing
task force and are meant to be
ideas
that will help us tackle this problem a
little bit by a little bit um
i will say that the housing champions
program is something i particularly
think is
something to be allotted for the state
especially in light of the governor's
recent announcement of the 100 million
invest new hampshire fund
it is
a program where municipalities can
voluntarily adopt housing friendly
policies and
by doing so
now opd
incentives that would reward our
municipalities for doing so so examples
of that would be housing friendly zoning
sewer and water improvements in parts of
town where density could be accommodated
or other planning you know towards
supporting housing in our municipalities
because we all know
our towns and cities are the are the
leaders in the front lines on this so i
will leave it at that
and i'm happy to take any questions any
questions to the senator yes
representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman i have a question
can i ask questions from here
as a matter of farm when i'm going to be
sitting
later in the
testimony as an opponent to the bill if
you can if are you the prime sponsor no
you can't if you are your sponsor no
oh
so what other i just have questions of
the senator when asking can i ask her
questions
if i'm going to testify
against the bill oh yes you can alright
thank you thank you senator for
yes yes do you have any more detail as
to
what's going to make up the housing
champion certificate
the bill itself does not seem to
dot the eyes across the t's you know
where that information
would be available
sure thank you representatives so
this would be a process that um the
office of planning development
underneath the bureau of economic
it would be probably a process where
there would be input
that could be made as it developed but
define everything in the bill but rather
make sure that we had input for example
from our municipalities about what would
be most useful
if i'd follow up mr chairman if i can i
concerned about what the scoring when we
got a scoring system what that means i
mean i i know i think there's no
criteria
to to qualify there's
no whether it's going to be a score of
10 there's going to be a hundred i mean
i'm living a small community of 9 000
people
on a border community to massachusetts
we're
i think we're in pretty good shape as a
town
because we do business
in a good manner and feel that we've got
a good
good town does that mean we can't
qualify because some other community
that may not do as good a job and may
have
problems that we don't have
maybe even self-made are they gonna
they're gonna get the money and i'm not
gonna get any money yeah i see what you
mean um
the intent and i don't know that um you
know the intent of the housing champion
program is is to award money per se it
could be for example that
what's most useful to our municipalities
is access to low interest money to build
out their sewer and water for example
but
um
you know the entire intent of the
program is is to be something that's
additional to where we are and so if
your town um
where are you from representing
hampstead amsterdam maybe i shouldn't
tell you yeah
um
you know if you feel that your town has
done what they need to do on housing
then this program wouldn't affect you if
you felt that there were actions you
wanted to take
you know to
to sort of do more on the housing front
then
then you could participate and and maybe
be eligible for something helpful to
your town so uh
it's certainly not something that's
intended to um
i mean maybe if there's some friendly
competition but not to put towns against
each other but just be an asset yeah
i'm 92 years old i'm not very naive so
i just wanted to express my concern
about the program not knowing all the
facts and thank you senator i appreciate
it i understand i agree
thank you representatives davis
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
is this bill um
related to
house bill 1632 and senate bill 586
1632 i believe was tabled and 586 was a
victim of covet is this pretty much the
same bill yes coming back again that's
question one sure um
there are many similarities there were
some changes to accommodate um concerns
that have been raised with previous
versions of it and i'm going to
respectfully defer to mr frost behind me
because he he knows the ins and outs of
that um but yes in short and follow up
if i may mr chair yes go ahead please um
do you anticipate or do the do the
sponsors anticipate that the work of
this
bill
should it
be passed
will dovetail in any way with the work
of the commission that we previously
discussed
and i guess it's a rhetorical question
because i can't see how one could
proceed well without the other so i'm
wondering you know are there
conversations going on about
meshing the work of these two groups
sure and um and i appreciate the
question very much so
in in my mind and i don't want to speak
for anyone other than myself but
you know this bill represents the
solutions
that we could think of from a technical
you know
non-political just merely trying to
provide tools to our municipalities
perspective at the time this was drafted
if these are passed and available to our
cities and towns we can then turn our
attention to a new set of tools again
support our municipalities um it without
some of these in place i think it would
be important to continue to to work for
these and make sure that they are
available because again
the intent here is merely for the state
to support our towns and cities on what
should be an important goal um to all of
us you know making sure that we address
housing that we have our next generation
here um that we support our state
economy and and that we make progress on
the under supply of housing
thank you
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question i have a number
of questions and concerns with regards
to this legislation but
i can only ask one question right now
and um i'd like to draw your attention
to page six line fifteen section fifteen
which um
speaks to tax relief
so um i am noting that the
um
that the number of years of tax relief
has been increased from
two
to up to four
years
to four to eight years and i'm also
seeing a scribner's error on line 18
that four should have been struck
so that that's a concern because that's
increasing the tax relief
and also if i'm understanding this
correct is this not shifting taxation to
current property tax
payers within a municipality and
how is that a good idea okay
thank you for your question
representative so uh the provision
you're talking about on on page six um
line fifteen it is indeed um enabling
legislation to allow a municipality um
to consider whether
uh providing this tax relief would would
work for that municipality so
again um the intent of this bill is
simply to provide tools to our
municipalities to have that conversation
um you are correct to say that when
tax relief applies to one party
you know
often it is done you know the amount of
the tax is often applied to other
parties but we do see this happen all
the time with um
you know exemptions for the elderly for
the amount of their assets for veterans
um from local property tax and so
it's a policy decision and in my mind um
it's very likely not one that all 234 of
our municipalities would make the same
way and so
in my mind by including a provision like
section 15 um
we we move that conversation to the
local level where it can be had
yes go ahead thank you mr chair um and
thank you for taking my follow-up
question so um i would assume then is it
possible for municipality to get an
estimate as to how this would impact
the current taxpayers locally and uh to
be clear so what you're saying is that
all these different provisions
one through whatever it is
what
i don't know one through let's say 20.
each section can be it's enabling
legislation individually and therefore
each section would be put to the voters
because i
i like to see the exact wording as to
how that would appear on the warrant and
maybe this would make this bill
humongous
but
could you speak to that because in other
statutes where it isn't enabling
legislation the question to be placed on
the warrant is explicit
is there a reason why that that isn't
provided for okay that's um that's a
helpful question and i appreciate it to
clarify
um
yes the intent is for all of this bill
to be enabling but there are provisions
in here that affect court procedures and
so um
that would be sections 9 10 and 11 but
other than that it is intended to be
enabling i am going to respectfully um
defer your question on warrant language
to the folks that testify behind me just
because i don't have the experience to
answer your question about whether
that's a standard practice or um or
whether only included in some
legislation
yes representative maturi
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question and my question
is in the exact same section as
representative power has but maybe
throughout the bill
where where the community or where where
the uh where the issue might be that it
meets workforce housing can we add
something where it remains
workforce housing my fear is that and
maybe it's in here already and maybe mr
frost can answer that my fear
is that
you build something that meets
and then after a while
that goes away and we're back in the
same place that we are now we have
something that met that now does not
meet and we've lost the great
ground that we have gained is that
possible to add something or does that
exist um that's a great thank you for
the quest
of course yeah thank you for the
question representative it's a great
suggestion and um
you know i think with your question you
draw attention to the fact that this is
not only about
building new
housing but it's also about retaining
housing that remains affordable
because
you know otherwise we do see
existing affordable housing redeveloped
sometimes coming back on the market for
higher prices so i think your suggestion
holds a lot of merit and i for one would
certainly be open to discussing it
representative
thank you chairman and thank you again
senator
perkins cuoca
to follow on with the questions that
you've just had about tax relief and
about the continued affordability
is it not true that
as we have a more adequate supply of
housing
the constant upward pressure
does diminish to some case i'm just
thinking about this whole question about
how do we maintain affordable housing as
affordable
and what's your take on that
i'm sorry
the question was if we have more houses
don't they stop going up in price every
five minutes
thank you for simplifying it's late
yeah um so i mean just as someone that's
been in this field um not even in this
field just as an advocate in this field
you know for 10 or 12 years um it you
know
everyone
i have spoken to and and i continue to
believe and continue to see research on
the fact that the long-term solution to
this problem is supply you know we have
a lack of housing supply and in places
like portsmouth
if we had just seen a one percent
increase in our housing stock per year
over the last 20 years it would have
made a meaningful impact on the prices
that we have now so
thank you for bringing that up because i
should have started by saying you know
the
new hampshire housing has published a
figure of a shortage of 20 000 housing
units statewide
and the tools that we are trying to
provide are towards the end of um of
increasing housing supply to meet rising
demand and ultimately bring prices down
so
thank you
okay uh uh
mr graves from nhma if you'd like to
join us thank you chair oh uh before
before you uh leave uh i'm sorry the
vice chairman had a question oh i'm
sorry yes thank you yes and thank you
turn your microphone on please
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question um
following up on that line 17-21
what what
would be the maximum amount of years for
tax relief
and who would support that i mean is the
tax shift going right to the taxpayers
for six i don't know is it does it go up
to 16 years
that's my question
it's a great question and i respectfully
representative i'm also going to defer
that one to represent to mr frost
because
um i know that he knows 70 90 inside and
out and i think he can provide you with
thank you senator who appreciate your
thank you chair i appreciate it and
waiting
thank you mr chair nate grace for the
new hampshire municipal association um
in the interest of time we are neutral
on the bill uh we did do a fiscal note
which very nicely summarizes our
position which is results would vary on
a town by town basis
and i'm happy to take questions
we should model our rest of our
next we're going to hear from
thank you mr chairman and
good afternoon i think it still is
afternoon
i'm ben frost from new hampshire housing
where i serve as the deputy director
i'm here to speak in support
of senate bill 400 i do have written
testimony which i will not read to you
but i will pass out
i also have
a copy for the committee's file on this
bill
of the governor's housing task force
report
sure
as that's going around that is a letter
from our executive director rob dapis
who very much wished to have been here
today but
came down with a sore throat this
morning and didn't want to
his letter
expresses new hampshire housing's strong
support for this legislation noting that
we did participate as
members of the governor's housing task
and the letter also indicates uh the you
know the the dire state of the housing
market in new hampshire uh referred to
many by as a crisis i would agree with
that
uh my colleague jack ruderman testifying
on senate bill 329 gave you some figures
on on just how tough it is out there and
it is it is really tough
you can't excuse me would you bring the
mic closer i can here
i will certainly do that looks like
there we go thank you how's that
all right
um
the housing market is a question of both
supply and demand we have
great demand for housing part of it is
an increased number of people moving
from uh out of state although
the numbers uh generally don't suggest
that there's been a tidal wave of people
moving from massachusetts during covid
but there has been uh an increase in
numbers and probably more in some
communities than in others
the fact is that most of the
purchasers in new hampshire continue to
be from new hampshire most most people
most purchasers are local to their uh
their own communities
but
as as
as jack rudeman indicated the numbers of
houses on the market for purchase is uh
shockingly low
it's below 1 000 for the entire state
homes on the market right now
and that pushes people into rental and
that pushes the rental prices up it is a
question of supply and demand and right
now we have a problem
of supply
senate bill 400 presents uh a series of
changes uh and incentives changes to the
local processes to make the process
more efficient incentives that
municipalities can avail themselves of
to help induce development
of housing
i would be happy to
go through any of the sections of the
bill that you wish
and mr chairman i'm at your disposal i
recall
on house bill 586 i testified before
this committee for two hours
i
don't think you want to be doing that
today
um you get two hours two hours okay uh i
always want to ask you a quick question
uh yes mr chairman you you and i work
together on senator clark's commission
emanate from that work back then or is
this a completely different uh
that's a good question i think it is
different
but
i'm trying to think back to the report
on that commission
and
i think for the most part these are
different things
mainly because
that commission was looking at
big picture things and and this is
really getting down into the details of
the local process
um
are there members of the committee that
have specific questions that
mr chairman
i did i was writing down the questions
and i could start with those and and it
and seek to address the questions that
were previously asked by representatives
davis guthrie power
uh maduri and uh the vice chair
all right once you do that then we'll
come back and get uh representative
vasalis representative power and anyone
else who has open questions um so
representative stavis asked if this was
uh linked to if there were a link could
be a link to uh the
bill previously heard
twice before
senate bill 329 the density commission
and i'd say yes
but i think that
the one proceeding does not mean that
the other can't also proceed they
couldn't the the the commission uh that
uh senator perkins cuoco is uh bill is
would propose creating might very well
come up with some different things than
are in this legislation and i frankly
would expect it to
so i think the measures that are
proposed here are really getting down
into the details whereas that commission
might have um much higher issues that
it's dealing with i think they can
proceed in tandem
um
and representative davis you also asked
if there were changes from house bill
586 and indeed there are and senator
perkins quoca noted there was a change
with regard to
the the tiff district section and i'll
section 13
uh the the language and this starts on
on line 32.
uh the language from line 32 through 34
came from house bill 586 and also came
from
prior to that house bill 1629 in the
what's new here this is a response to
a
part of the discussion the debate on the
bill on the floor of the house house
bill 586 last year when it was tabled
one of the criticisms
and this was by representative barbara
griffin
that
she said accurately that
a municipality could use the power of
eminent domain to take private property
to
create workforce housing and
i think the
the likelihood of that happening is very
very very remote but she was correct in
in effect in saying that it was possible
but the change this year is to directly
address that
uh by saying and this is new language
starting at the very end of line 34 on
page five
the municipality shall not acquire
property for this purpose through the
powers of eminent domain
expressly forbidding the use of tif
districts to use eminent domain to
create workforce housing that is a
direct response to representative
griffin's comment last year
the other change is a very minor change
and that is in the workforce housing
definition uh previously uh house bill
586 and before it
that might have been house bill 1629 or
1632 uh in
2020. uh
talk
would have changed
the definition of workforce housing to
allow it to be affordable to people
making incomes of up to 120 percent of
reflecting on that we looked at
this did the math
on what that would mean
and
that pushed the recommended purchase
prices as workforce housing to a number
that just seemed unpalatably high
so for something to be affordable to a
family of four making 120 percent of the
median income for an area in some parts
of the state
would would mean that workforce housing
could be sold at over six hundred
thousand dollars and that just did not
seem right uh so
uh
we recommended to senator bradley uh
that that be struck from the legislation
keep and to keep the existing definition
of workforce housing as it exists in the
law now and has since 2008
at 100 percent of the area median income
still it's a big number
but it is the number we've been working
with uh for
now 14 years
so those are the two changes uh from
representative guthrie you you asked
senator perkins quoca about uh the the
um the scoring system for the housing uh
champions uh i would urge you to
recognize that that would go through the
standard jl car process
so
anyone i'm not sure if anyone here
serves on jlcarr but it is a pretty
rigorous process of policing
how agencies do rule making and
so
i think you know jlcarr and the office i
guess it would be the lba would ensure
that the scoring system that the office
of planning and development comes up
so that's my response to that that point
appreciate that
thank you
representative power
uh you asked about the section dealing
um
and i'm not sure that that is a
scrivener's error it looks like there is
a strike through it but it's it's part
of the four
on line 18.
but your substance your substantive
question was um
whether this was a a tax shift
and
it is and that is that is the design
of rsa 79e which is a statute that has
existed since the legislature adopted it
in 2006.
it is local option so municipalities
decide whether they want to do this and
if they don't want to do it they don't
do it but a lot of municipalities have
adopted some provisions of rsa 79e which
is the community revitalization tax
relief incentive
to induce
the redevelopment of properties you know
derelict properties that have been
sitting
unused for years
because the owners
for whatever reason don't have the
capital to do it this is a means by
which a municipality can induce a
property owner to rehabilitate property
by giving them
uh some relief in increased taxation
that's attributable to the rehab cost
the the value of rehab that they put
into it
so the idea and is this universally true
no probably not
but the idea is uh it's to induce
redevelopment to increase
taxable valuation
that would not have occurred but for the
availability of this incentive
so the property owner gets a a relief
from increased taxation that's
attributable to the the value that's
brought back to the property for a
limited period of time after which
it's fully taxed at its full fair market
value
so there is that limited period of time
when there is a shift in taxation
but
the argument is
that that increase in tax taxable value
might not have happened but for the the
incentive that exists
um
there have not been any studies done on
that uh but that's the that was the
theory behind it at the time
um uh and representative power you also
asked about uh the estimates of local
impact um i i would think that any
municipality
that was the governing body of any
municipality that was thinking about
proposing this to the voters would want
to do
that kind of estimate of impact it is a
local question though and so it's
something that your local select board
should do
when they're thinking about doing it and
presenting it to the voters as a means
of saying this is what the impact will
be this is the the shifting of taxes
that what might occur over what period
but recognize too
that these are all individualized
decisions under the statute
so
for any
single property to get this tax relief
even after the municipality has adopted
the power to do it
each property has to go before the local
governing body the select board
for access to this and have to get
specific individual approval
for each of these tax reliefs it's not a
not a blanket approval once the town
meeting adopts it
it is it's a pretty
uh
rigorous approach to getting tax relief
um
uh and
last question represent representative
power you you had asked about the the
process and there is an existing process
for adoption of rsa 79e and this is you
look to 79e colon three and that spells
out the process by which a municipality
would adopt these the provisions
in the existing statute
and that would apply as well to what's
proposed here in senate bill 400
so this
rsa 79 he e has been around since 2006
it is a well-established mechanism that
a lot of municipalities have used very
successfully over the years
and this is simply tapping into uh that
existing statute by providing additional
periods of relief for uh workforce
housing
and then again
remind you this is at the municipality's
discretion it says up to
that is the local governing board body's
decision to make on each individual case
so they might say no in this case
because of whatever reasons they they
determine we're only going to give you
four years of additional relief or six
years or the eight years that the
statute allows it is a decision that
each local governing body would make on
an individualized basis when presented
with an application
representative maggiore got to your
question
the duration of the affordability so
let's say
a
property owner is doing workforce
housing approaches the select board for
tax relief under rsa 79e
and
how long
would that property be workforce housing
rsa 79d does have a provision on this
it's not specific to workforce housing
but
but is uh related to the
what's called the public benefit
covenant so in order for a municipality
to award this tax relief uh the select
board the local governing body has to
find that there is a public benefit
and then there has to be a covenant that
gets recorded in the registry of deeds
recognizing that public benefit
and that places limitations on the use
of the property so the public benefit
covenant
can
this is again another discretionary
question
can last for up to
twice the length of the tax relief that
is granted
so
if
through whatever combination of factors
a property gets say 10 years of tax
relief under 79e whether it's whether
it's under the provisions in
senegal 400 or the existing statute as
it exists at this time
the municipality could
require the public benefit covenant
to last for a period of 20 years
and that could be a term of
affordability for workforce housing
recognize too that if a developer were
pursuing a
an application through a local planning
board for workforce housing and at the
same time seeking tax relief uh through
the select board the planning board
could also impose long-term
affordability covenants as a an approval
of workforce housing and those typically
are on the order of
20 30 years
some municipalities do perpetuity which
is an awfully long time
if they're if a development is seeking
public funding through say my employer
new hampshire housing
we require long-term affordability
generally no less than 30 years of
affordability sometimes 40 sometimes 60
years sometimes longer depending upon
the mix of financing so there is there
is an opportunity to keep these
properties affordable for a long period
of time but it does require
action
at the municipal level or through a
funder
um
and mr vice chairman you had asked
what's the maximum period of time you
can get relief
under under the current statute
the base period of relief of
affordability is up to five years
and then if you're doing additional
housing units you can get an additional
two years if they're affordable an
additional four years if it's an
historic structure i think an additional
four years i think the total possible
maximum right now is 13 years
again
that's up to the select word to decide
are we going to grant it for that period
of time
this would
add
to those those periods uh so an
additional four years uh for uh
workforce housing if you will so
i guess 17 years would be the total
follow up
online thank you mr frosting thank you
mr chief if you want me to ask a
question
um it gives an additional eight years
for a project that includes affordable
housing that meets the definition of
workforce housing
and up to an additional eight years for
a project that includes residential
units so are they not calculating 16
potentially yes uh
again up to the local select board to
decide is is this good for our community
uh and they might say no you're not
we're not gonna give you that
much more followers go ahead
they are the amount of money that
that
would be
is there any way to determine that
because that to me it sounds like it's a
huge amount of money and the taxpayers
are going to if that goes through a huge
amount of money taxpayers are going to
have to come up with
and you know do you have a percentage or
anything
along those lines that
would give us an idea
that's a great question mr vice chairman
i i don't know that there have been
analyses done
like
looking at the
the use of rsa 79e over the years
but you could
on an individual basis i think very
easily
calculate what the attack shift would be
and you'd look at the number of years
you you could very easily come up with
that number on each individual
application
and it's similar to what representative
power was asking what's the what's the
the aggregate that a municipality might
be looking at but it does require some
individual decision making from property
owners approaching a select board and
then the select board making those
decisions
and again i want to emphasize this is
all discretionary and the local
governing body can do decide to do less
than
what the statute authorizes
both in presenting
a warrant article and in making the
individual specific decisions
then you had a question from uh
representative lasallis
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking my question you mentioned a
couple of statistics about
uh people
coming into the state uh from uh
surrounding states and so forth
in the case of
a
family from massachusetts
who had a vacation home or a second home
in new hampshire
who
now maybe they're not retiring
but
zoom the new zoom era
they're not required to live in
massachusetts
they sell their mansion in massachusetts
and downsize to their second home in new
hampshire
would your statistics
that's a great question
um
the the statistics that i was citing
would not pick that up
and and it's a great question because
it's some it's a phenomenon that we do
recognize
it is happening it it it is happening we
don't know
exactly to what degree it's happening um
but we know that there are
there are a lot of people who own second
homes in new hampshire who do not live
in new hampshire
primarily they live in massachusetts
uh and
i'd say most of the second homes owned
in new hampshire are owned by people who
live in new hampshire but there's a
substantial portion of them owned by
people from massachusetts and we do know
that
for a period of time
during covet especially during 2020
people when their kids
were remote learning
they wanted to be in their townhouse in
waterville valley so the kids were in
school in the morning and then they
could ski in the afternoon and we saw
the impact on the waterville valley
school district we saw a similar impact
not quite as dramatic in
conway
but those impacts this year last year
and this year have receded
i've not looked at the numbers but
anecdotally that's what i've heard that
we're not seeing so much of that
especially as
the kids are going back to school
physically in massachusetts they they're
only coming up on the weekends instead
of living there you know months at a
time
we
what we've been tracking and we do have
very good numbers on this
is
the
proportion of people who are buying
homes in new hampshire and where they're
coming from so we we look at the actual
deed transactions
and so every deed that gets recorded
we're analyzing and figuring out where
people are coming from and there has
been
since
20 the beginning of 2020 there has been
an increase in the proportion of buyers
from massachusetts
shifting from about
15 percent of all buyers to about 20
percent of all buyers
but still the vast bulk of buyers in new
hampshire are already here they're
they're they're moving from one place in
new hampshire to another place
but you're that was not your question
your question was about you know people
who already owned a home here in new
hampshire but weren't currently living
here
those numbers don't account for that
and i think that the school district
information is one way of looking at it
um
cell phone data is another way of
looking at it where you know the where
people are making calls from and where
they're where they got their phones
originally that's that's one thing
credit card transactions is another way
of looking at it uh we're not analyzing
that but um that's that's one way of
doing it it is happening
it's not not in the same degree that i
think a lot of people think it's
happening
uh ben i i just i have a
small bit of homework for you i can't
we're going to execute this bill on the
18th yes
and
i will just ask before we
get to the exact meeting if you could
help
i don't want to belay it right now but
the the
in the
front page of the bill and under the
how the bill creates incentives
blah blah blah
could you
help point out
for the committee what those incentives
are and where they are where they are
i could i could do that right now
oh
we
uh so
mr chairman are you asking for a short
memo on each section is that
uh
i'll leave it i'll leave it up to your
creativity
i i will be happy to do that for you
thank you
and i'll uh you're executing this on the
18th so i'll try to get that to you um
by the end of next week
and should i just email it to the entire
committee
uh yeah that would work okay i'd be
and it is evening now
representative thank you mr chairman um
mr frost thank you so much um
and i don't really know if i can explain
this clearly
but
my impression of workforce housing is
that
it's providing affordable housing for
people that are working to support local
businesses and it may even be an
incentive for businesses to come into
new hampshire because their workers will
be able to afford housing
so if we take a small community um and
i'm gonna i'm gonna pick on litchfield
my my colleague from litchfield it's a
rural community it's a wonderful place
to live it's close to a lot of business
hubs
what incentive do they have to consider
the this tool box
they can go ahead and build this but
businesses are probably not going to go
to litchfield so they're going to be
providing a benefit to businesses but
they're that's not going to be offset by
increased property taxes that would
offset
the increase in
residential
like i look at
i look at the the
a town's property
the pie the assessment pie
and it's an advantage to residential
property owners to have business and
commercial because they don't require
the municipal costs or services that
residents do and that's primarily with
education
so what would incentivize litchfield to
participate in this
when it's
it's building businesses
but yet they're not getting the benefit
from that
do you see there it's not it's just
increasing the portion of their pie
that's going to residential
likely increasing their school dis their
school costs
so that's sort of my issue and i guess
it's sort of a concern with just the way
we do things in new hampshire because
each town each municipality is not an
island
you know there's a lot of people that
live in my town that don't work in
merrimack
i mean we have some big employers but
there's still a lot of people that just
get on the highway and go into
massachusetts so for merrimack to build
more workforce housing
it's
it's not as likely and less likely than
would be in in
in litchfield that they would that would
be offset by increased commercial
industrial tax base
i don't know if you have an answer but
that's i'm trying to figure out what are
these incentives
for a town to really invest in
increasing residential housing
let me follow up on representative
wrong's uh question because
back in the time when i was working on
senator clark's commission
we talked about
real incentives and how do you get
communities to step up and say i'm
willing to do this because there's some
trade-offs here and one of the things
that we talked about is some of the most
expensive items
for communities
that are developing
is sewer and water
so how do we maybe incentivize
sewer and water to some of these
communities that are looking for it
uh
with with this particular program if if
you do this then
you'll get that benefit
well let me turn to
this is a great philosophical question
and and
you know we could spend
days we could you could do a
dissertation on this
but let's just
in response to the chairs prompt
let's turn to
um
this is the housing champion
certification
lines 34 35.
municipality shall receive preferential
access to state resources including but
not limited to discretionary state
infrastructure funds as available water
and sewer so communities that are
open
to housing development that seek a
housing champion certification
have that that leg up in getting access
to the water and sewer that is needed to
support the housing development they go
hand in hand it's connected they do it's
a nexus there that we have to recognize
there is a very clear nexus
and again
not everything here is going to be
applicable to every community
so i'm very familiar with litchfield i
used to work for the nashua regional
planning commission and you know i know
i know what the town is like
um
and you know what works in litchfield
might be something very different from
from what works in its neighbor
londonderry
you know it might be looking at some
really small scale commercial
development which in fact
may be the best return for the
municipality for a place like litchfield
in terms of tax revenue not the big
projects
but the iterative small-scale commercial
and so
and we have actually new hampshire
housing has
worked with
a really interesting consultant called
urban three don't let the name get in
the way of of your perceptions but what
they look at
is
the tax revenues that go to
municipalities based on different types
of land uses and we just we completed
the first phase of the study last year
it's on our website
and we
had them work with 15 different new
hampshire municipalities all over the
state different types of municipalities
you know cities small towns
and
when in each one of them what they found
was
as expected
the the best return for
tax revenue was on the small scale
mixed-use development so
the highest return in dover for example
was
a pizza shop with two apartments over it
in terms of the use of land
and the return and taxes on that
property
you know walmart generates a lot of
taxes but it consumes a lot of land too
so it's not an efficient from a property
tax standpoint it's not an efficient use
of land
you get a much more efficient use of
land returning on taxes on the
to the municipality from the small scale
stuff that might be the best thing for a
place like litchfield
and and
that would
support
uh that small scale housing development
and if they like like lines 34 and 35
follow up mr chair
yes go ahead
thank you to my colleague for bringing
up
the town of litchfield because i think
in a way
although it's kind of unique
in a way but yet it's typical in some
ways also i recently did an analysis of
what uh
representative run talked about as far
as litchfield it is totally a bedroom
community there's almost nobody who
works within with a few exceptions
very few people
work in litchfield that live in
litchfield but
it's surrounded
by some of the largest communities in
the state
manchester bedford londonderry hudson
nashua merrimack all right
almost a quarter of the population of
the state
can be reached from litchfield within 10
minutes
you know
and but yet we have no commercial we
have no sewer we have
no water there's two things that people
in litchfield
are would be against any sort of
workforce housing one is to
maintain
the
bucolic nature of the town
and secondly is the fear
of being inundated by kids in the school
system
those two things keep us from
in addition to
lack of
a little sewer and and affordable water
we have water but it's not affordable
all right it's like gold
um
but
so i don't know if there's a question in
there i'll i'll take it as a question if
i may reply okay um
i i think that
um
again i'll repeat
what's in this legislation is tools for
municipalities to use
if they want to and i understand exactly
what um
the folks in litchfield are thinking
about one thing i would encourage you to
do is
to
question the assertion that
new housing
automatically brings brings a flood of
school-aged children
we've
done plenty of studies on this they're
available on the new hampshire housing
website where we've looked at
new residential development in different
new hampshire communities
and
the numbers of school-aged children that
that new residential development
generates
it is a lot lower than most people think
but the wreck we recognize that
increasing the school population has
certain costs
those costs and i would encourage you
also to look at a study that
unh's doc dr richard england did
a couple years ago
the costs are not linear
they they are quantum jumps so you have
a certain capacity and most you know a
substantial portion of the costs that
are born in your uh
represented in your school tax bill are
capital costs that are not going to
change
when the population changes until you
get to a critical point where you need
to expand or rehabilitate
where you're talking about shifts of 20
or 30 students
there's not going to be a perceptible
change to your school tax bill ben i'm
going to uh at the
risk of frustrating you i'm going to
do some rearranging here in real time i
am at your disposal uh well that's good
i'm going to ask you to be our final
speaker
and that way those who want to hang
around and listen
we can do that but i'm afraid we're
going to start losing more and more
committee members and audience
uh as time goes on here and i'm happy to
step back mr trump so uh so let me let
me go through some of these pink cards
and then we'll see where we are and
we'll come back to you at the end
former representative dan mcguire yes
welcome thank you very much mr chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is dan mcguire
and i'm from epsom
um
i'm here kind of in a dual role i'm on
the board of directors of granite state
taxpayers are the oldest
statewide taxpayer organization in new
hampshire
and i've handed out to you the position
of the organization
on this particular bill they're we or
they are opposed to it
um
for
just sort of simple um
it it interferes with local control that
that kind of but there's a lot more
detail on this paper you can read it
i also want to speak to the bill
on my own
i'm a member of the planning board of
epsom i've been elected i think three
times possibly four i can't remember
and
i've certainly seen our planning board
do things that add costs i mean
delay people
mess with their plans all that sort of
stuff
and so
just in general
i'm in favor of
some of the things in this bill
that help planning boards
be more efficient
act quicker
be fairer all that sort of stuff
but in reading this bill
it's it feels to me
like
a couple of different bills pasted
together
the first few pages the first four or
five pages are of the character that i
just described they seem to
tighten up the what planning boards can
do what what towns do
and make it fairer and simpler and
quicker and all those kind of things so
in general i'm in favor of the the first
sections of the bill
but then it starts to get into
things where
it starts to
give give ways of pushing people to use
their property
in ways that the state likes okay and
that's where i think it goes off the
rails and in particular especially that
that last section where it creates some
kind of um
um
housing champion certification i mean
that's just silly stuff um
and
so
in general i mean i go back to to the
first principles here um
in general the people who should control
the use of property are the ones that
own that property maintain that property
pay taxes on that property and so on it
shouldn't be
the neighbors of people who own property
and pay taxes and maintain property
right and if it shouldn't be the
neighbors of those people well it
certainly shouldn't be the legislature
either
right the the legislature should let
people use their property the way they
want and if if
housing is expensive
the legislature needs to look in the
mirror and and see what they are doing
that creates that situation
and i'll just give you a simple example
my my house is on a three acre parcel of
land
um on a state road and and i have a lot
of frontage i got like 800 feet of
frontage and my house is on one side and
i could easily
if i thought it was economical and
put up a small house or manufactured
house or whatever on the other side of
my property and rent it out and if if
that were
a way to make money i might do it right
but the rules prevent me from doing it
why because my town has two acre zoning
so i can't
uh
if i wanted to you divide the the
property it's three acres even though i
have plenty of septic i have plenty of
water all that sort of thing
my and and the rules prevent me from
having more than one residence on this
piece of property right so it's the
rules that prevent affordable housing
and so
uh
that's why
if you can if you control um
you you let people use their their
housing the way they want to
um the market is going to push them to
do things that are affordable you can
that are that are economical right and
so if there's a giant demand for for
less expensive housing people will do it
if they're able to do it and the problem
is they're not
thank you mr chairman thank you any
questions for mr mcguire
seeing none our next
hello thank you good to see you again i
think i called it at seven o'clock
earlier when i testified we're close
um
my name is sarah holland i am the vice
chair of the public policy committee on
the new hampshire realtors
you've already heard the specifics of
the legislation and the realtors would
echo those sentiments
i would add that the lack of housing
availability in new hampshire is not
simply a local issue it's a state
problem
in 2021 the medium median sale price for
single-family home was 395 000
keep in mind that in 2019
the median sale price was just three
hundred thousand dollars so that was a
thirty percent increase in just two
years and today it's
over four hundred
perhaps more importantly the total
inventory of homes for sale in new
hampshire is currently at an all-time
low
in february of 2016 there were 7 500
homes for sale across the state and in
february of 2022 there were just 928
that's an 87 percent reduction in the
available inventory in just six years
the inventory crisis is real and it's
not getting any better and i want to add
that it started well before covid but
kovid certainly did accelerate it
senate bill 400 is a needed step forward
in ensuring an adequate supply of
housing that is available for new
hampshire's workforce
the legislature has worked hard to make
new hampshire attractive to businesses
and to all people
our favorable tax climate and beautiful
scenery are great incentives but they
are all for nothing if a business person
cannot find a place for their workers to
live
so a healthy housing outlook would be in
a specific community a variety of
housing types and price points so people
can kind of move around as their life
kind of changes whether they have kids
they're just starting out maybe they're
retiring and downsizing and if they can
do that all within one community they
everyone in new hampshire takes pride in
their local community and its ability to
conduct its affairs in what it is what
is in that specifics town's best
interest however if one town places
exclusionary zoning restrictions in an
attempt to stop housing development
their action is going to be impact and
impact on all surrounding towns
so what happens when one town's local
control starts to negatively impede on
another town's local control
at that point we think it's appropriate
for the state to step in and try to
incentivize housing opportunities which
sb 400 does
so in march new hampshire association
realtors conducted a statewide poll and
we asked people if housing availability
was a problem in their community
78 that it was said that it was a
problem
60 percent described it as a very big
when we asked if they believed housing
costs and availability are a problem
because of the pandemic so these issues
will resolve themselves as things return
to normal or did they believe that
housing costs and availability have been
a problem for a long time and won't get
better until elected officials take
action
61 percent said elected officials need
to take action while 32 percent said the
market would take care of itself
so sb 400 represents an opportunity for
the state to begin to turn the tide on
housing availability in new hampshire
and we certainly support that
a couple of examples that just occurred
this week in my line of work um
one young woman whose house that she was
renting is now for sale the owners are
moving on for a variety of reasons and
she no longer can live there so we're on
the hunt to find an affordable property
for her to either purchase or for her to
rent we started the search within 45
minutes of where she worked
could not find anything
and then so we started searching over an
hour which brought us into vermont
and yes i'm licensed there as well
and we only found two options and each
of those two options there were droves
and droves of people in her similar
situation
not folks from out of state who were
looking for a vacation rental or a
or a second home
and the competition was fierce so it is
not just one or two people that are
looking for homes
there are a lot of our workers that are
willing to sacrifice their precious
hours on the road to find an affordable
house so we need to do something here in
new hampshire to keep them local
thank you thank you any questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
very much oh i'm sorry richard tripp
thank you mr chair and thank you
it's interesting that uh
you said that
there's a lot of homes that are either
vacation rentals or second homes uh
could you put
a
number or a percentage on that
so i think what i referred to is that
the number of people that we were seeing
at these the houses that were available
in the price point for this particular
person
were
not looking for second homes they were
very similar they were
the same demographic of the person that
i was representing so a person who has
a an afford is looking for an affordable
home based on the workforce housing
definition
and is looking for a place to live
primarily in new hampshire
so the folks that are lining up the out
the door at new listings are not
necessarily or overwhelmingly second
home buyers or investors
thank
well i'm still interested in you know
the
the percentage of housing in new
hampshire
that
vacation rental or second homes you know
because it seems like
uh
there is a large quantity of that
that that
reduces the amount of housing available
to
others so i am not um i don't have
numbers available for you
maybe it's something that then i don't
know if ben has numbers on that and he
can speak to that later
but what i am seeing
is the housing that we are looking for
in the state that my clientele are
looking for in order to stay in the
communities or near the communities in
those properties are not necessarily
going to second homeowners they are not
necessarily going to people who are
looking to
to rent it out short term as an
investment
thank you
thank you appreciate your testimony and
now i want to call up alyssa margolin
again
thank you mr chairman good evening
members of the committee alyssa margolin
i serve as director of housing action
new hampshire i'm distributing for the
committee a sign-on letter in support of
senate bill 400 that has 108 signatures
from about over 80 organizations
and uh
a one-pager summary on the legislation
and a copy of my testimony that i will
not read to you
um
we have a
severe housing crisis
newly graduated medical residents are
declining jobs at dartmouth-hitchcock
despite their reputation because they
can't find a place to live
engineers are declining jobs at nobis
because they can't find an affordable
place to live
we have an increase in family
homelessness
this is really severe and so as a matter
of policy development as a matter of
action we're asking the legislator what
can
we do
since 2019 the governor recognizing that
an economic issue for the state
put the best and the brightest in the
room for 90 days and said come up with
solutions and respect local control
and they came up with
two bills house bill 1632 in 1629 this
committee supported both of those bills
we had covered truncated session
end up next year 586 we combined both of
those bills this committee again
supported those proposals so we're back
again
this time the bill is called sb 400 it's
got a little more compromise
it's got it addresses all the issues
that we've named over the years
it is
not a mandate it is not the state saying
to a municipality you have to do this
because we have a crisis we're saying
we will give you tools
that already exist for other things
and say
if you are ready to say yes in my
backyard community
then we are empowering you to do so
if litchfield does not want to change
the bucolic nature and does not want to
take any action with sb 400 it doesn't
have to but if dover wants to if dover
wants to use 79e or wants to use tiff
the legislature is saying we recognize
we have a problem here are more tools
that's what this bill does
the um
the it's
it's a carrot approach it's not going to
put folks on a list and say these
communities are bad and these
communities are good it's saying if you
are doing well yes in my backyard and we
can use you as an example we're going to
give you an award and call you a
champion
um
it's like tree city usa or bicycle
friend communities or any of these other
municipal incentive programs that say
you're
you're doing a good job on this if you
don't want to do it you do not have to
so essentially i just there's
i don't think this
these proposals can be watered down
anymore
i think we have a serious crisis and
so many organizations and business
interests are asking the legislature to
act
and give tools for those ready to meet
market demand
so that we can ensure that we have a
workforce for the future
i'm happy to take any questions any
questions yes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so if these
provisions are already in statute what
is the reason why that you know
this type of housing is not being
developed in new hampshire and
i'm not sure that
senate bill 400 is going to fix that
well for example 79es already exists but
they might use it to restore a local
theater or preserve a historic farm and
so what we're saying is
if you want to use it for housing
municipality
you can do that it's up to you so that's
what i mean these are tools that exist
for their economic development tools
that the state has already put into play
and so a group of thoughtful people
who really know what's out there in
terms of policy and economic development
tools that are already
available to municipalities said let's
put housing in the mix and that's all
okay thank you very much for your
testimony appreciate it and and i
appreciate your patience and us with our
schedule that we're
up against
thank you mr chair members of the
committee i'll be real brief because
like all of you i want to hear more from
ben frost so
once again i'm dave giuve i'm a senior
vice president for the business and
industry association i want to make just
two points and i'll make them very
quickly the first is again to emphasize
the lack of workforce housing which
we've all come to understand is a
significant issue for an employer and
it's making their job of hiring and
retaining workers much more difficult so
this is something that employers around
the state care about
the second thing i'd like to do is
refute what a previous testifier said
that i found was astonishing
when he said he was opposing the bill
because it takes away local control
i assure you there was a lot of work
done in drafting this bill to make sure
that it did not take away
local control and that the
tools that were given were something
that a community could choose to use or
choose not to use
the the idea that this somehow takes
away local control i find astonishing
and you don't have to believe me
look at the new hampshire municipal
association who said they were neutral
on the bill i assure you and i think you
all know this if there were issues in
this bill taking away local control the
municipal association would have been
the first to say so mr chairman that
concludes my testimony i'd be happy to
answer questions but if not i can't wait
to hear more ben any questions from mr
juve
thank you very much
next uh
thank you mr chairman uh you got the
name
my name is joe garuba for the record and
i've
been deeply involved in the weeds of the
details of local planning and zoning for
the last five years
i'm here
to give my testimony to refute the
notion that everything in this bill is
voluntary and that it doesn't damage
if
sb 400 is passed it will significantly
limit the authority
of local land use boards relating to
development projects
sb 400 is a bill which is incompletely
titled relative to training
in procedures for zoning and planning
boards relative to financial investments
and incentives the bill actually
contains several provisions which reduce
the authority of local land use boards
as well as boards of selectmen
the bill narrowly passed the senate
on 317 and i'll describe seven
problematic aspects for you now
sp 400 states
that if towns offer incentives
for senior housing such as increased
density reduced lot size expedited
approval
or other dimensional or procedural
incentives it shall shall offer those
incentives to workforce housing and i
want to draw your attention to page one
of the bill
i'll just read that one sentence it says
beginning in july 1st 2023
incentives established for housing for
older persons shall be deemed applicable
to workforce housing what that actually
means is the voters of a town who may
have decided that they wanted to provide
some sort of incentive for workforce
housing for people to downsize in their
community
their local zoning ordinance is going to
be overwritten if you pass this and any
of those
those
benefits that were applied to housing
for older persons those retirement
communities they would automatically be
applied to workforce housing
many towns have prioritized senior
housing
and their voters have approved these
developments on smaller lot sizes
forcing towns to apply these densities
to workforce housing will result in
increased water usage and require
additional town services
these senior housing incentives were
approved by the voters
with the assumption that one to two
residents would occupy a smaller lot
workforce housing will not be limited to
one to two residents
and demand for groundwater is greater
in summer of 2020 the state experienced
the significant drought
and some wells in the southern towns
went dry
if family housing
development requirements are forcibly
linked to senior housing development
requirements this will create a burden
on water demand
as well as educational services
local residents are in the best position
to determine the specifics of their
community this bill overrides the
decision of those voters
and unreasonably links two separate and
distinct types of housing
it's important that local land-use
decisions are made by town residents who
have a vested interest
in the outcomes
so that certainly is not a voluntary
provision of this bill
the next item s p
400 states that if land use boards
fail to provide specific written
findings of facts
which are supportive of their decisions
with regard to developers applications
or disapprovals
it shall be grounds for automatic
reversal
of the board's decision
this language is vague
how would the housing appeals board
determine what is or is not
supportive
[Music]
automatic reversal
is not an appropriate action
for a technical problem with a
disapproval
this clause has the potential to force
approvals of non-compliant projects on
towns for process-related technicalities
next
we've got
it imposes a new
90-day time constraint on local zoning
boards and it imposes a 65-day limit on
planning boards eliminating the present
methods for extension
as you know projects before land use
boards vary in size
and scope greatly
how could the same deadline be
appropriate for the construction of a
single house
and also for the construction of a 200
unit complex
large projects involving many housing
units require additional technical
review time the engineering work
including storm water and roadway design
demands commensurate attention
how could a strict deadline serve to
allow local boards to make careful and
informed decisions
why override their ability to
deadlines next we have sp 400 initially
initiates an unelected board greatly
insulated from the voters of the state
the 16-member board includes
representation
largely consisting of housing and
development special interests
the board would determine rules for
access to state tax dollars
why would you consider voting this
authority to the likes of home builders
associations realtors and the new
hampshire housing finance authority
do you think this will be a fair way to
distribute tax dollars
the authority to make decisions related
to the distribution of taxes
should reside in the elected legislature
[Music]
the bill states that when a case is
appealed
land use boards but not applicants can
be sued for attorney's fees and costs
when it can be proven that said boards
have acted with negligence
sb 400 would authorize the office of
planning and development to create tests
for planning and zoning board members
this provision
could be used by developers attorneys to
discredit decisions by local land use
boards who haven't completed the office
of planning and developments training
program
moving on
s p 400 would allow the same developer
to resubmit a denied application
present case law known as the fischer
doctrine holds that the denial of a
local project is final
sp 400 would allow re-submittals if the
case were dismissed without prejudice
this process
would
put a financial burden on the local
who would now have to oppose the same
project multiple times
the finality of local land use board
decisions is an important protection for
abutters who cannot afford to fight
non-compliant development projects
over
last point here sp 400 changes the
procedures and the timelines currently
used by planning boards city councils
and select boards to consider a
development application
the current procedures are well
established and understood protocols the
amended language removes the ability of
city councils and select board to
identify non-compliances with ordinances
and regulations
so this isn't about timing this is
taking away the ability to identify the
non-compliances
[Music]
this reduces local oversight
and only serves the interest of
developers
the goal of the state statute should be
to preserve due process
for all residents and to be sure that
any developments that are approved are
compliant with the ordinances that the
residents voted for
it seems sp 400 is designed to
facilitate development approvals without
regard to compliance for local residents
local regulations and ordinances
so wrapping up
considering all these uh reductions
in local municipal authority created by
the inclusion
all
the ones that were created by the
inclusion of the housing appeals board
which was added as a negotiation
into the budget in 2019 how can the
passage of sb 400 be justified
it's my belief that the serious
limitations on local authority
should result in an itl recommendation
from this committee
in addition to being state
representatives
you're all residents of your local
municipalities
i ask that you vote to itl this bill for
the sake of your neighbors and local
land use board members who deserve your
support
please feel free to reach out to me with
any questions or comments and if you
have any questions i'd be happy to take
them now
[Music]
thank you mr chair and thank you um for
taking my question
so um
you have stated that you're
intimately involved with local planning
and zoning
and
with regard to any feedback that you've
received from your town and your
you know
elected officials what is their feedback
with regards to this bill
so i believe they are working on a
drafting a letter
to provide to this committee i i haven't
seen the language of that letter yet
but i'm expecting it'll be available to
you
before you execute the bill on the 18th
[Music]
thank you for the question any other
questions
thank you very much appreciate that
you
enduring the schedule that we kind of
adopted here and
your patience and waiting it out so
thank you thank you for allowing my
testimony
thank you mr chairman and in the
interest of time that gentleman just
said a lot of my comments so i'm going
to refrain from stating those right now
okay
my name is regina barnes i am a new
hampshire patriot and i am here
representing statewide citizens who
cannot make it today
i have been following the housing what
has been happening in concord here for
quite some time for about the spri
pretty much since 2019 when the housing
appeals board um was snuck into the
budget as part of the budget deal
so i do i am completely opposed to this
i believe the hampton buda selectmen has
sent a letter to you in regards to
senate bill 249 i'm not sure if they
acted on this bill or not and that was
to oppose senate bill 249.
i can tell you that is a prior
selectment in hampton and also as a
pretty much lifelong resident
hampton is a prime example
of development at a very very fast pace
it has been summarized to us recently
that approximately only nine percent
of our town is conserved so 91 percent
of it is developed
so our planning board and our zoning
board i believe do a very good job
at working with property owners
developers to make sure the projects
that they want to pass get passed and i
don't think we need any state
interference we haven't so far
so
primarily objective to this sb 400 is
this in my view now i know a lot of
people said this is all you know it's
all up to the community but when you
offer the community
money
whether it's going to be state money or
federal funds i'm not sure but when you
offer them monies that are going to be
either grants or low interest rates for
water and soar things have been needed
in their communities to me that's a
bribe that's a bribe to do what is
wanted by the state of new hampshire and
its government so
in my view this grants more authority to
unelected conquered bureaucrats
in conjunction with the already
unconstitutional housing appeals board
it will cause the demise of what is left
of state and municipal sovereignty
i know a lot of people behind me are in
support of this bill and i know where
they represented they stated who they
represent but my question is who
represents the regular people that have
lived in this state for decades who's
representing those people i'm going to
try to represent some of them right now
sb 400 grants authority to the office of
planning and development to determine
preferential access to state resources
which is what that whole
community
i'm not sure what it's called incentive
plan is i know hampton's in one with
regards to um flood insurance
we have to do all these extra things go
over all these bat all these hurdles and
you know what we can't we're not even
getting into the program
because we have four or five properties
that are not compliant
so unless they actually go to those four
or five properties and force the
property owners to do upgrades
then it's it's been a waste of time and
we've been it now for at least six seven
or eight years
so um
how is it fair for royal towns to choose
not to urbanize in my view this is going
to pit towns that want to stay small
local
they don't want to be rural communities
not everyone wants to live in an urban
community that's why many of us moved to
new hampshire
so
shouldn't all of the state have access
to the state resources not just a select
few
please vote against this bill to
preserve the unity of the state's rural
towns and cities
and the question i really want to leave
with you is
who should control the housing
developers should it be the
municipalities or should it be state
appointed boards
and the senate failed by passing this
bill onto the house and i hope that the
house will kill it on on its arrival
thank
you barnes
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
now last speaker is uh
i'm going to mangle the last name joe uh
guthrove
i didn't associate this uh handwriting
with you
well my handwriting wasn't my hand
wasn't shaking though
earlier joe you disclosed your age i
know
92 yes and here i am god bless you 92
thank you mr chairman for the record and
joe got three rockingham 13 hampstead
and kingston
and i'm here to speak uh
against uh
400 senate bill 400
and the reason be
as submitted
uh maybe in fact my comments should have
been saved and they probably rightfully
belong personal privilege before the
full house
because my objection is
at the way the bill is submitted and in
spite
of all the due respect i have for the
governor
and particularly the
prime sports or this bill
i i just i'm going to have a hard time
supporting it
and if you all recall last session
we had what they used to call what they
called omnibus bills it was because of
the virus
you know where they put you know 25
bills or whatever it is
and we all voted on them and it was
either take a
leave
and
some of them might have been germaine as
these are germane
uh but you know it was take it and leave
it and that was the way it is
i said to myself when the virus went
that i couldn't vote for
omnibus bill and i submit to you that
this is an omnibus bill there's three
separate items in here they're all
germane
maybe you like the the uh
the first two sections you know like
like the certificate
like i have a concern maybe you're like
me
or maybe you like the certificate but
you don't like the planning
what are you going to do
take it or leave it
and i object to the way the bill is
submitted to this this committee and i
think it should be split into three
bills
and if there was a way to do it
and i don't know if there's a way to do
it
but uh i really uh i'm offended
that at this stage of the game we're
playing games like this
and i blame my own leadership
and i don't have a problem going on
record
that i blame my own leadership for
submitting a bill like this with three
separate
issues
in one bill
and
that's all i have to say and
i certainly take questions but i don't
know how it's either a yes or no
take it or leave it so appreciate the
time and thank you for saving me till
the end
and i hope uh i didn't keep anybody too
long thank you joe thank you mr chairman
okay we're at the point uh
oh we have a question yes
this is a question of the chair mr chair
it's my understanding that um
committee member
statements of supporter opposition to
bills are for the executive session when
we vote on the bills and not as
testimony my understanding is that
committee members participating in the
hearing do not testify
and that that is for the executive
session
uh
i appreciate the comment
i got some clarification on that and uh
the clarification i got was that
if you were a
primary sponsor of a bill
you we're not we're not allowed to
uh testify on that and you had to
actually uh we have had people step down
from
being at the desk here and sitting in
the audience
during that time period
so that that's
please there's no need to apologize for
representative guthrie but thank you
okay we're at the point where i told you
we'd be at if
we get mr frost to come back to the
microphone
so i'll leave it to the
committee
to prompt
mr frost with questions that you have
that
can help
get a better understanding of how this
bill came together and what it's uh what
it's proposed to accomplish
and then when we're done
so so you stand between dinner
and
thank you again mr chairman i am still
at your disposal
um
i
do you want me just to take questions
yeah let's start with that and it'll
maybe it'll germinate into uh something
thank you mr chair
i i merely wanted to comment that it's
actually not mr frost that's between us
and dinner it's all of us who are
between us and dinner
thank you
just a reminder good comment yeah
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you sir for
taking my question
my question is
pertains to page four
section 10
that discusses
in statute the ordering or of the
schedule of both the
superior and supreme courts
and
to put it simply it allows appeals to
cut in line
um i'm troubled by that and also i would
like to know if there are other examples
in statute where such a provision is is
allowed for
thank you for that question
and representative power i i would
start by pointing out that
um
the priority
on the court's dockets for land use
decisions is existing law
this simply modifies the existing law
so it's called it's called the rocket
docket
and if you look at
and you see the language here
on line 15 of page four that's the
existing law
so there already is priority in the
courts docket for in this case
uh planning board decisions
and if you look down same page section
um rsa 677.5 priority that's for zba
decisions and the the existing law has
simply been removed there and the entire
section has been replaced so both
planning board and zba decisions on
appeal to superior court have priority
in the courts docket and what we're
seeking to do here is to spell out what
that means so the court has some
instructions from the legislature on how
to prioritize those things
and this language
that is here both in section
10 and section 11
is actually language that the judicial
branch drafted
so
and this was an amendment to the bill as
introduced in the senate
attorney richard head appeared before
the the senate committee i think it was
the
election law and municipal affairs
committee that was hearing the bill and
said that the judicial branch had a
problem with the way the bill
was written as introduced he came up
with language negotiated with
uh senator perkins cuoca and senator
bradley
uh talked with us about it and this this
is what they came up with and we are
perfectly fine living with this language
that the judicial branch came up with
thank you
any other questions
i think uh i think what i think you're
worn out i think you're yeah i was going
i can keep going but
i know you could
you could go until midnight
uh so so we have uh a schedule that
we're going to eject this bill on the
18th
uh and
mr frost has some homework
i have my assignment sir to go uh
complete i would suggest that if
if any of you have uh
follow-on questions that you hadn't
thought of up to this point
for either mr frost or maybe the nhma
or
all those others that have
shown an interest and testified that you
contact them directly
and accumulate additional information as
as
as you see fit
and if you if you find a nugget or two
i'm talking to the committee members if
you find a nugget or two that we all
should know about i would suggest you
bring it to the executive session and
let's kick it around and and educate
each other a little bit
and mr chairman if i may given that that
invitation i'd be happy to email the
entire committee tonight so you have my
email address and feel free to fire any
questions at me i'll take them all
appreciate it thank you i know that
we all have
families and we have other commitments
and
i appreciate your efforts so i'm going
to
close the public hearing
on senate senate bill 400
thank you all for uh
for staying late and getting this work
done
mr chairman
our next our next meeting is on the 18th
is that correct
the 18th
at 10 o'clock at 10. that's a monday
correct yes
and and depending on
depending on which caucus you belong to
there may be a caucus that prior to the
meeting